branch davidian compound outside waco
texas
chairing the joint hearing republican
bill zelif of new hampshire and
republican bill mccollum of florida
this part of the event runs two hours
and 20 minutes
[Music]
good morning
the joint hearings of the oversight
subcommittee on national security
international affairs
and criminal justice and the judiciary
subcommittee on crime will now come to
order
i'd like to welcome all those present
our witnesses for the first days panels
the public my friends in both the
oversight and judiciary subcommittees i
would especially like to welcome my
co-chairman during these
hearings chairman bill mccollum of
florida my pleasure
without further ado then we will move to
opening statements we will hear first
from the majority subcommittee chairs
then subcommittee minority ranking
members and the full chairs and ranking
members will then hear from our opening
panel
all remaining members can submit copies
of the opening statements for the record
today
two subcommittees undertake historic
joint hearings on executive branch
conduct during the that led up to the
events at waco texas in 1993.
these hearings were planned in early
february by the subcommittees that are
here today the oversight subcommittee on
national security international affairs
and criminal justice which i chair and
the judiciary subcommittee on crime
which congressman mccollum chairs
these hearings are being held because
very important questions questions that
are still
trouble the american public and many of
us in congress
have not yet been answered they are
being held because hearings in 1993 and
the waco tragedy lacked vital
information information that we now have
today
today's hearings are the result of an
extensive five-month congressional
investigation
tens of thousands of documents have been
reviewed hundreds of potential witnesses
have been interviewed
in human terms these hearings are about
a tragic loss of life
four brave young law enforcement
officers lost their lives on february 28
1993
a planned raid went badly and off course
these four agents dedicated and proud
deserve our full respect they did not
choose to die but like many others in
law enforcement community they chose to
serve
in these hearings we will honor them and
we will seek accountability and
responsibility
these four young men so that the nation
may know their supreme sacrifice are
conway le blue who is 30 todd mckeon who
is 28 robert williams who is 26 and
stephen willis who is 32.
if we can get to the bottom of what went
wrong and why these lies will not have
been given in vain
but this is a complex event on april
19th 1993 after a 51-day
siege
other decisions led to the use of
so-called cs gas
and a fire broke out the fire rapidly
consumed the entire davidian compound
killing all 22 innocent children and
more than 60 adults
the truth behind that part of the
tragedy is also important and is the
obligation of those who have
responsibility for oversight to pursue
the truth relentlessly
speaking for myself that is what i am
here today to do to find the truth to
let the chips fall where they may
at their core these hearings are about
how a constitutional government works
but how one branch of our federal
government oversees the activities of
another about how we as americans seek
after the truth and do not rest until we
get full accountability and
responsibility
oversight is good in fact it is the
genius of our constitutional system of
government
these hearings are also about difficult
legal and policy decisions
did agents die because a well-planned
raid was hurriedly executed despite the
loss of surprise or was the plan itself
flawed
who approved the raid and the original
plan
and where are the commanders who ordered
it
how did the treasury when it reviewed
its own behavior reach its conclusions
on the use of military personnel and
heavy equipment against u.s citizens
other questions linger
how much was used and why
what was the legal justification
was there a drug connection or not why
did we need so much force
what are the legal limits and were they
violated
on the use of cs gas did the justice
department know that it could seriously
harm children did the president know who
advised the attorney general and who
advised the president was the attorney
general pressured by the white house to
end the siege
what were the roles of webster hubble in
vince foster
who actually made the decision to use cs
gas with 22 children inside the davidian
compound after two years why is there
still no clear answer
finally what can we do to keep a tragedy
like this happening again
what lessons have we learned and what
lessons did we learn about having
agencies do their own reviews
in these hearings we'll hear nearly 90
witnesses they have all been called to
tell their accounts
all will testify under oath to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
at the end of the hearings my hope is
that lingering doubts about what
happened on february 28th and april 19th
questions about who ordered these events
and why will be answered
some facts may never be known but most
significant facts will be for the first
time openly and vigorously discussed
three last points first i spent the
better part of my life supporting and
being supported by law enforcement i
come from new hampshire and up there we
have great respect for our law
enforcement people
second many have tried to take these
hearings off track once and for all
these hearings are not about the
oklahoma city bombing the bradyville the
militias gun control or any other issue
they are about constitutional oversight
we have sought factual information from
every available source we have done so
doggedly and i'm proud of that i make no
apology for seeking the truth and i will
add that there has been greater
accommodation in the minority party in
these hearings than in any oversight
hearing that i'm aware of during the
past 40 years
one last final point as we listen
carefully to every witness and as we
search together for the answers to the
many unanswered questions surrounding
the events at waco i would urge my
colleagues to back away from the
attraction of political rhetoric
americans are very forgiving people they
seek the truth and they will accept
nothing less
if we can perform that function for them
not as republicans not as democrats but
as truth-seeking americans doing our
oversight role there will be no more
wacos that is my personal prayer and i
urge you all to join me in that effort
thank you
the chair recognizes and introduces the
co-chairman of the joint subcommittees
and the chairman of the judiciary
committee's crime subcommittee my good
friend bill mccallum of florida well
thank you very much chairman zelith i'm
very pleased today to be here and to be
sharing with you these hearings over the
next eight days
stephen willis
conway lebeau todd mckeon
robert williams
you don't know these men but they are
four of the reasons why congressional
hearings into the events surrounding
waco will be held this weekend next
these four federal law enforcement
agents were among the more than 90
americans killed in the single most
fatal episode in the history of federal
law enforcement the calamitous incident
at waco
last week a new york times editorial
called it one of the biggest law
enforcement fiascos in recent memory
the disturbing truth is that all of
these deaths were the direct result of
federal government action this tragic
incident has added to the distrust of
the federal government and specifically
federal law enforcement the deadly
mishandling of the crisis and the
ensuing mistrust is why congress must
independently investigate all the events
surrounding waco
in looking at this the basic fact
remains no matter how you look at it
that more than 90 people including four
law enforcement officers and 22 children
died as a direct result or indirect
result of federal government action
unavoidable some say
maybe so but before we close the book on
those 90 human beings we better be very
sure we know exactly what happened
ensure that everyone who should be held
accountable is held accountable and
determine how we can avoid such
tragedies in the future
there's a woman in the audience today
whose husband an atf agent for 17 years
was wounded during the raid she traveled
a long way just to remind us that there
is a very painful side to waco besides
the deaths of those that i mentioned
she describes her husband as a man of
high integrity who witnessed horrors on
that fateful day in february 1992 that
were worse than anything she saw in
vietnam this devoted wife came to
washington to tell us not to forget the
sacrifices of the wives and children of
the thousands of brave agents like her
husband well let me assure you ma'am
that we will not forget in fact when
these hearings are over it is my hope
that law enforcement officers will be
safer because the supervisors and
political officials who give them their
orders will be more vigilant when
placing them in harm's way
the fact of the matter is that there are
a lot of questions that have to be
answered when we go down this process
the four main objectives of the hearings
are one to probe the lingering questions
to uncover the errors
four find out who should be held
accountable
and craft reforms to prevent these
mistakes from happening again
in looking at the questions that are out
there to be answered there are a number
of those the toughest of those questions
are were atf supervisors predisposed
towards using military-like tactics to
serve a warrant could koresh have been
apprehended outside the compound making
the execution of the search warrant
safer the senior treasury department
officials warn atf to call off the raid
if the element of surprise was lost or
was that added to the story after the
fact did atf purposely mislead the u.s
army when it claimed there was a drug
lab inside the davidian compound was the
judgment of attorney general janet reno
and others in the administration to use
cs gas and storm the compound reasonable
essentially could the atf and fbi have
delayed the assault or handled the
entire operation differently if so would
the four atf agents and 86 other
americans be alive today
we still have not uncovered the truth
the mishandling of the crisis and the
ensuing mistrust is why we're here
independently examining this question i
want to assure the american people that
those responsible will be held
accountable for their actions these
hearings are a step in that direction
until we learn the truth and restore
accountability to government we cannot
begin to rebuild our citizens faith in
federal law enforcement
let me be clear we cannot anticipate
every future crisis but we can be better
prepared and not have federal law
enforcement repeat the errors of waco if
these hearings can prevent another waco
i feel that they have been a success now
today's washington post says on a
headline clinton team focuses damage
control on waco
we're not here for damage control the
article describes how white house
political operatives in coordination
with the treasury and an outside damage
control czar
went to work to prepare for these
hearings etc
let me assure everyone here these
hearings will be objective they will be
fair and they will be thorough
at the end of the day we will have as
many of the answers as we can possibly
have the chips will fall where they may
there will be some of the questions that
have been raised that will be
corroborated some of the issues that
have been raised is very damaging to the
administration may be cooperative but
they're going to be quite a number they
come out on the other side of the coin
because there are a lot of conspiracy
theories running around out there that i
really believe after the sun is set will
defined are unfounded but i'm not here
to prejudge that's why we're having this
hearing we're here to find the answers
to go back and review what we have to
review and at the end of all of this we
must restore confidence in the rule of
law and in the federal government and
its federal law enforcement arm that's
what these hearings are about
that
and keeping the faith with not only
american people but with the families
of those who were wounded or killed at
waco and the faith of the families of
those many men in law enforcement
throughout this nation of all
persuasions at all levels of government
thank you mr chairman
thank you
chair now recognizing the ranking
minority member of the oversight
committee's national security and
criminal justice subcommittee my good
friend karen thurman from florida
thank you mr chairman
um
today we begin eight days of hearings
devoted to the tragic events that took
place two years ago at the branch
davidian compound outside waco texas
there is a great deal of national
interest in our proceedings chairman
zelif and chairman mccullum let me state
right from the beginning and for the
record that i'm glad to hear and that
you hope that these and the public
pronouncements about this process being
fair and nonpartisan are accurate
because we must not lose sight of our
mission and who we serve the american
people it would truly be a tragedy if we
wasted taxpayers dollars on a political
sideshow that added nothing to the body
of knowledge we already have concerning
this incident
remember these kinds of events happen
regardless of which party occupies the
white house and i believe we should
proceed with that in mind
subverting these hearings to a political
agenda will do nothing for the
reputation of either this congress or
our law enforcement
i do believe that the events at waco
deserve deeper examination
we need to fully understand exactly
where mistakes were made both in
planning and performance and to ensure
that they never happen again
and the only way this can be achieved is
through impartiality and openness
let us not forget why we are here this
morning four law enforcement officers
lost their lives 20 were seriously
injured and more than 80 people died at
the branch davidian compound
we must never allow our work here to
drift away from the interest of those
families who lost loved ones
david koresh and his followers were
under intense secure scrutiny by local
officials
after all it was local law enforcement
resp responding to very suspicious
activities who contacted federal
authorities
the af the atf obtained a lawful warrant
which subsequently was not challenged in
court cases involving surviving
davidians in trying to serve the warrant
officers came under heavy gunfire after
a ceasefire was negotiated the fbi took
control of the scene and attempted to
negotiate a settlement that prevented
any further loss of life unfortunately
the agency was only partially successful
some adults and children left the
compound in the days following february
28 1993
but on april 19th the branch davidian
compound erupted in fire there are
obvious and distressing problems
surrounding the strategy and actions of
both the atf and the fbi and they must
be examined and resolved the department
of treasury issued an exhaustive report
that strongly criticized the plan of the
atf however some questions still remain
if our government reform and oversight
subcommittee is to achieve its mission
then we must conduct fair and proper
oversight finally mr chairman i want to
reiterate that my purpose over the next
eight days is to see what went wrong to
determine if the problems have been
corrected and to make sure we do not
engage in trivial partisan politics i
want my constituents and the american
people to know that government while
fire far from being perfect works for
them
if these hearings produce a clear
understanding of what really happened at
waco then we have done our jobs well
otherwise the public will only be left
with questions hearsay and more reasons
to doubt and mistrust us let us not
follow the tragedy at waco with the
tragedy of waco hearings let us have the
heat of passionate debate but the light
of understanding and the certainty that
only true knowledge can bring
thank you
chair now recognizing the ranking
minority member of the crime
subcommittee
charles schumer of new york for his
opening statement thank thank you mr
chairman and let me begin by saying that
i believe with all my heart that we
should have hearings on the incident at
waco
this is the first of eight very sad days
we're going to talk about the deaths of
scores of men and women and children
including four atf agents
if we can learn the lessons of this
tragedy by bringing out new facts
or even if no new facts come out
by looking at the old facts in a fresh
light then this is a worthy endeavor
because in the words of justice louis
brandeis
sunlight
is the best disinfect disinfectant
the danger here
is that we won't shine sunlight
but rather a strobe light
flashing on and off
and distorting our vision
i have two goals as we enter into these
hearings first
to make the investigation constructive
we interrupt this this opening statement
for a commercial message
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay are we all set there
we can listen to her
okay first is to make this investigation
constructive
not destructive and divisive
the atf and fbi should leave this
hearing stronger
better and more effective at enforcing
all our laws including gun laws
because when the next david koresh
appears
we don't want law enforcement to make
the same mistakes
but we definitely want the next koresh
and if found guilty
then punished
the men and women of atf and fbi made
terrible mistakes at waco
those responsible for our federal law
enforcement agencies have admitted those
errors
law enforcement officials more than
anyone on this panel feel awfully about
the mistakes that cost the lives of four
of their colleagues
it is they
who go to bed at night
thinking about the partners and friends
left behind
and law enforcement officials have made
reforms to correct the problems
nevertheless if we can leave these
hearings with constructive suggestions
on how to improve the atf and the fbi
then they will be a service to the
american people
the second goal
is to keep these hearings honest
we will challenge anyone and everyone
who presents a bias or factually
incorrect view of what happened at waco
i will not let this become a show trial
with law enforcement as the defendant
these waco hearings must not degenerate
into a kangaroo court
it is unfair for us today to look at
what law enforcement did at waco in a
vacuum
and it is unfair to twist the facts
making law enforcement the villain
and david koresh
law breaker the victim
that is like saying right is wrong
and night is dead
let us be very clear
david koresh was a dangerous
sick man
who molested children
preached violence
and led his followers into a horrible
suicide
david koresh was not a peaceful cleric
in an ivy colored chat in an iv covered
chapel or even an eccentric with strange
religious views
david koresh was an armed fanatic who
was excoriated in his hometown newspaper
in a series they entitled quote the
sinful messiah
koresh sexually abused children
and called it holy
david koresh was obsessed with guns
because he claimed it was commanded by
scripture
he hoarded a military arsenal that
included at least 48 illegal machine
guns and scores of illegal hand grenades
remember ladies and gentlemen
david koresh and his followers did not
greet federal law enforcement officers
with a psalm or a scripture
they greeted them with machine guns and
grenades
more firepower
than even the atf agents themselves had
nothing excuses that ambush
nothing in american law excuses it
nothing in the bible excuses it
you do not meet a warrant with a machine
gun
even if you believe the warrant was
illegally obtained
so let us put aside double standards
i doubt that the most vocal critics on
this panel
would argue for delay if atf discovered
an arsenal of machine guns and hand
grenades mere blocks from here in
washington's inner city
and i doubt that today's monday morning
quarterbacks would demand that atf wait
for the advice of sociologists social
workers neighborhood preachers and
professors of religion before
asking for such an arsenal
from the beginning
and this is my concluding point
from the beginning
these hearings have had the odor of bias
hanging over them
and over the last week we've discovered
where that smell is coming from
the national rifle association
we have uncovered covert payments by the
nra to high-priced explosive experts
lawyers associated with the nra being
sneaked onto panels and finally a
witness who was deceived by nra
employees passing themselves off as
congressional staffers
it's no wonder that the nra has tried to
hide their role in this hearing
everyone knows their bias this is the
organization that buys advertisements
calling law enforcement jack-booted
thugs
frankly
i don't think that the nra gives a damn
about the tragedy at waco but rather
wants to destroy the atf because they
enforce the laws that the nra despises
the brady law and the assault weapons
ban
and i'm very troubled that some on the
majority staff have conceded at least
part of the planning and organization of
this hearing to the n r a
in order to fully understand what
happened at waco and what went wrong
there we need a fair
impartial unbiased and factual
investigation
unfortunately i cannot today say that
the hearing is fully living up to that
standard
we have requested
that there be an investigation
into the role of the nra including
questioning under oath employees of the
organization and staff members involved
in this hearing
so far
our requests have been denied
now you may ask one final question who
cares whether the nra is involved or not
well it matters because their hatred of
the atf so distorts their view of the
incident at waco that this hearing runs
the danger of missing the broader point
one man
bears the ultimate burden for the
horrible scar on american history of
waco
this man is david koresh the sinful
messiah
david koresh is ultimately to blame for
the horror of waco no matter how others
seek to twist and revise history
these hearings must not run away from
that fact
they must examine where law enforcement
failed and seek to improve
not decimate the atf in the fbi
when we run into the next david koresh
we want smarter law enforcement to avoid
to avoid the mistakes of waco and
stronger more effective law enforcement
to apprehend and punish those who molest
women and children who molest children
and stockpile weapons thank you mr
chairman
thank you uh in the interest of fairness
and openness i let you have a little
additional time three or four minutes
and uh i appreciate it i just want to be
on the record with that
chair now recognizes the chairman of the
full judiciary committee my good friend
henry hyatt of illinois for his opening
statement thank you mr chairman
it seems from my good friend mr
schumer's remarks that
uh somehow these hearings could be much
more abbreviated the gentleman has a lot
of answers
that uh
i don't think were available to
everybody else
in any event
these will be interesting hearings
as chairman of the house judiciary
committee
i shared in the authorization of them
because i think they're necessary and i
think they're warranted
more than two years after the tragedy of
waco millions of americans continue to
wonder why
many of my constituents are asking an
almost universal question how could this
happen this episode in our history
raises many difficult and lingering
questions about timing judgment motives
and the proper exercise of the federal
police power
some believe the approach taken at waco
first by the atf and then by the fbi
was unnecessarily confrontational did
the actions and activities of the branch
davidians and their leader david korres
justify the lengthy costly standoff at
their compound still others have raised
questions about what appears to be the
increased militarization
of federal law enforcement itself
this series of tragic events for dead
atf agents on february 28 1993 and the
death of 86 civilians whose names have
not been read here today inside the
compound on april 19th does raise
questions about the bureaucratic
structure of federal law enforcement we
have the fbi the atf we have the dea the
secret service customs the u.s marshals
service and the ins border patrol each
of these entities carries out basic law
enforcement
and investigative functions is the
authority too dispersed and too
scattered among too many federal
agencies
does this fragmented authority with the
accompanying overlap and duplication
undermine the quality of the
decision-making itself
as a member of this committee the house
judiciary committee in the last congress
i participated in our only hearing on
these events and that hearing took place
april 28 1993
i think too close to the events to allow
for a balanced perspective but even at
that time i felt one day of
congressional hearings was hardly enough
few documents were available to be
reviewed by members of the committee and
many relevant sources were not
interviewed or asked to testify
subsequently the two agencies conducted
their own internal investigation of
themselves the american people have
asked for and demanded more there is a
sense of national discomfort about what
happened at waco
and congress is the appropriate form to
respond to these legitimate questions
and concerns
now congressional investigations have at
least one thing in common with baseball
you don't get very far if you don't keep
your eye on the ball
there has been a concerted effort by
some
to divert attention away from the events
at waco
away from the question of what happened
why did it happen where blame if any
should be allocated and what lesson
should be learned and how we can prevent
this from happening again
it will be our effort to focus on the
essential facts
in a bipartisan way so charges of
political motivation while inevitable
will be discounted by fair-minded people
the minori the minority democrats have
been accorded great latitude in helping
prepare the list of witnesses and i'm
confident these hearings will answer
most if not all of the outstanding
questions regarding this tragedy most
importantly i hope these hearings will
help restore the confidence of the
american people in the professionalism
and judgment of federal law enforcement
officials and officers there is no
tougher job in america than that
undertaken every day
by our law enforcement personnel
on the other hand when government is
accused of abusing its great power
citizens are entitled to look to
congress for redress and that's why
we're here today no function of
government is above criticism or beyond
scrutiny the judiciary committee has
legislative as well as oversight
jurisdiction over the department of
justice the fbi and the atf
there are lessons to be learned from
waco and those lessons will be applied
as the judiciary committee considers
relevant legislation affecting these
agencies in the future thank you mr
chairman
thank you chairman hyde chair now
recognizes the chairman of the full
oversight committee my good friend bill
klinger of pennsylvania for his opening
statement thank you very much mr
chairman and let me begin my statement
by addressing what appears to be a
palpable truth that is that vernon wayne
howell also known as david koresh was
criminally reckless at the very least
and likely indictable for murder had he
lived no matter what mistakes federal
law enforcement authorities made and
there were many
koresh broke the law
by collecting a cache of illegal weapons
broke the law by violently opposing the
service of search warrant and broke the
law by allowing the siege to continue
for so many weeks worse still
koresh broke the law of morality by
refusing to allow otherwise innocent
women and children to leave the branch
davidian compound thus resulting in
their
violent and horrible deaths
after the search warrants were served
vernon wayne howell could have taken
steps to end the siege and save the
lives of his fathers he did not do so
these hearings should not distract the
nation's attention from who bears the
ultimate and principal responsibility
for what occurred in mount carmel texas
in 1993 it was david koresh
as my colleagues will attest in their
opening statements and haven't tested
these hearings have several objectives
and i agree with those who suggest that
a principal objective of these hearings
must be to try to answer lingering
questions regarding these tragic events
and to restore the level of respect to
which the federal law enforcement
community must have in order to be
effective if the members of this body
are open-minded in the pursuit of truth
and if the witnesses we call are honest
and complete and the facts they present
i have little doubt these goals will be
met
i must say i disagree with those uh some
in congress and the clinton and the
administration and the media who have
argued that these hearings are
unnecessary they contend that the
detailed reports prepared for the
agencies involved in the volumes of
evidence presented in the criminal
trials leave few issues unresolved and i
contend that any time federal law
enforcement officers are murdered and
any time innocent women and children are
killed in the course of government
action extensive congressional oversight
is clearly is definitely in order
uh
just uh
monday alan stone who was a member of
the justice department waco report
review team wrote in monday's new york
times that he found the government's
investigation seriously deficient mr
stone added that the government never
gave the review team quote a candid
account of what went wrong comments such
as these are quite an indictment of the
processes that brought us to this point
i'm also i must say disappointed with
those who have characterized these
hearings as a front for the nra or for
the military movement
this is i think a little more than an
attempt to shift the nation's attention
away from the actual focus of the
hearings which is to find the truth
some have requested hearings of the
militia movement or the involvement of
the nra and i would certainly seriously
consider that request but today
other questions no less serious must be
asked and those questions have been
outlined by the previous speakers
i have one additional goal for these
hearings
the government reform and oversight
committee which i chair has been charged
with the responsibility of ferreting out
redundancy and efficiencies in the
federal government that includes
downsizing government departments and
agencies where appropriate perhaps the
members of this joint subcommittee
should ask themselves whether federal
law enforcement functions should be
consolidated not downsized necessarily
but consolidated early national
performance review recommendations
called for the consolidation of some law
enforcement activities unfortunately
these ideas were not considered
seriously hearings on waco alone will
not answer questions about consolidation
but maybe they will raise them anew
because every day it seems we open the
newspaper to find unflattering news
about federal law enforcement officials
and their activities i know the vast
majority of our federal law enforcement
personnel are hardworking dedicated
public servants who put their lives on
the line every day and i know the
distinguished service of those
individuals seldom makes it into the
headlines as these hearings and
subsequent hearings on events at ruby
ridge and the scandalous annual atf
roundup unfold my appreciation of the
dedicated service of the vast majority
of federal law enforcement officials
will remain undiminished however i
strongly believe we must uncover the
truth about these unfortunate events
find inefficiencies where they exist and
restore their faith in the federal law
enforcement community i want to commend
chairman zellath and mccullum for the
hard work that they and their staff have
put in in preparing these hearings i
know this has not been an easy process
these will not be easy hearings and they
will not be comfortable hearings but in
the end i believe they will put to rest
some of the lingering suspicions and
doubts that americans have had in the
advent of these tragic events thank you
mr chairman
thank you mr chairman the chair now
recognizes the ranking minority member
the judiciary committee my good friend
john conyers of michigan might add that
two years ago in reading the uh
transcripts uh you were involved in
judiciary hearing i believe a week after
waco took place and look forward to your
your comments and your opening statement
thank you good morning
i want to begin by emphasizing
my deep commitment to what
is going to be the most important thing
to me to come out of these hearings
and that is
how we reform law enforcement
to make it a better tool in all of the
agencies
and if that doesn't happen
then i will have to tell you in advance
that as we prepared for these hearings
i've come across absolutely no
new evidence
that
requires
eight days worth of hearings
uh i want to emphasize my
deep commitment to law enforcement
reform
and i've talked with the secretary of
treasury
about the investigation of the
waco raid that underscores the need for
reform to restrain abuse
and the the most
emblematic of these problems is the
race relations that infest
all of law enforcement all of the
agencies i've been working on judiciary
for 30 years
and we're finally now beginning to get
to the
terrible oppression and discrimination
that still goes on and within
the bureau of alcohol to back when
firearms they had the nerve to again
hold this this graceful tennessee old
boy's roundup which is a symptom
of the kind of problems that we have
now
of course we can abolish that roundup
every year but the circumstances and the
environment that creates it won't change
unless the leaders here
and in the congress and in this
administration do what i believe they
have committed to me that they will do
is to change that that's the kind of
reform that leads to better law
enforcement
now the question still legitimately
lingers whether there is
some other motive for these hearings
we'll have to listen to conspiracy
theories of every stripe
but i don't think we'll hear any new
facts to contradict the findings that
have been brought forward already
and the reform on the agenda here today
that i'm most worried about
is the collateral attack on assault
weapons
that is the agenda that i am very
disturbed about and so no one need look
around and act like they're surprised to
hear
that that was the first thing this new
majority was coming at
in this session of congress
oklahoma city stopped that
and now
all of a sudden i'm finding friends who
are worried about law enforcement and
racial discrimination and disparities
that have never said a word before all
the years that i've been working on this
and so i don't want to give any uh extra
credibility to anything that may come
out of these hearings as mr zella
referred to i was the only member of
judiciary who severely criticized this
raid when we held a hearing
uh in 1993
and i think it gives me cause
and and further legitimacy to have great
reservations
about the purpose of these hearings
this isn't just for the american people
it's a about
how
some forces within our government and
nation and the
the national rifle association attempt
to repeal the assault weapons ban
by tearing down the agencies that
enforce the ban
and that's not to say that the events
surrounding the raid and the agencies
conducting the raid
are without legitimate criticism
but let's be clear
about that
because i've already stated my
criticisms and i don't change them
but i'm also astounded by the fact
that like
americans in this country by a margin of
three to one we believe that the
hearings on the militia
and the clan
and the skinheads and the aryan nations
are the ones that deserve the hearings
before congress
not the
law enforcement agencies and waco which
is had
as most people know
many hearings more than four complete
hearings
and so as the only member who of this
committee who in the aftermath of the
raid dare to publicly criticize it i
would tell you now if there was an issue
that i believe that needed more scrutiny
i would be the first to call for a
hearing but in my preparation for this
hearing i found nothing new
now i welcome all the new friends that
we have to this subject and to these
kinds of of problems
but let's remember this
before previous support for the raid
was before the assault weapons ban
gave federal law enforcement the power
to make our streets safer by prohibiting
assault weapons and because in the wake
of oklahoma city
this new majority
i hope
will find the courage to keep assault
weapon bans in the law
and
and attempt and do not attempt a de
facto
repeal by going after federal law
enforcement agencies and with that mr
chairman
i thank you for the time
and look forward to this process that
brings us here today
thank you
chair now recognizes the ranking
minority member of the full committee
our friend cardis collins of illinois
for her opening statement
thank you mr chairman
during my 22 years of service on this
committee
i've always been a strong supporter of
vigorous oversight by congress over the
activities of the executive branch
these hearings are being portrayed as an
effort to hold fair
open and unbiased hearings on the raid
at the brass davidian compound at waco
and therefore i should have few
reservations about these hearings many
observers have noted that despite many
hearings and reports on this subject
over the past two years
further hearings can only shed more
light on the rate and perhaps resolve
unanswered questions
taken at face value this logic is hard
to contradict
i certainly have never been adverse to
criticizing federal state or local law
enforcement when i believe that they had
overstepped their bounds
i know all too well how law enforcement
officials can abuse their authority
that's one of the reasons why several
months ago i vigorously opposed the
efforts of the republican majority to
weaken constitutional requirements for
search warrants as part of the contract
with america
moreover i am totally outraged by the
recent revelations of federal law
enforcement agents participating in a
disgustingly racist outing known as the
good old boys roundup
therefore i immediately wrote to
president clinton to express my outrage
and to demand a thorough investigation
and swift action which has now been
promised
these hearings also do not suggest any
outward partisan biases
the plans for the atf raid on waco began
in the bush administration and continued
in the clinton administration to the
extent that errors and abuses occurred
they were bipartisan in nature
similarly the ruby red siege which is
gaining new attention occurred during
the bush administration
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle would be well advised to seek the
facts and not attempt to turn these
hearings to partisan advantage
nevertheless i continue to have serious
concerns about these hearings and i
would like to share with you my reasons
first
i cannot help but conclude that the
recent bomb in oklahoma city has caused
a rush to eight days of hearings on waco
the only reference in our committee's
oversight plan is a vague statement
about a review of atf activities to
occur at the end of this year
the word waco never appears and we had
no indication of eight days of hearings
until very recently
the fact that we are holding extensive
hearings on waco just weeks after the
bombing in oklahoma city by a suspect
who reportedly was upset by government
action at waco can only send the wrong
signal to disturbed individuals who
believe that bombs will bring attention
to their grievances
second i am troubled because i believe
that these hearings are not so unbiased
as we are being told
and may have been hopelessly tainted
by the involvement of the national rifle
association
our first indication of the relationship
of the committee republicans and the nra
on these hearings occurred when the
republicans sought to use a company
known as failure analysis associates to
examine weapons recovered at waco
later we learned that failure analysis
associates have been retained by the nra
more startling was a recent revelation
that individuals calling themselves the
waco hearing team
were contacting committee witnesses this
team was not employed by our government
reform and oversight committee but
instead was employed by the nra
at this stage we had no idea to what
degree the nra hearings team was working
with the republican committee staff
however this is an unprecedented case
of an outside advocacy group using
congressional hearings to further their
own agenda and at the same time
potentially tampering with congressional
witnesses
i've called upon the chairman of our
committee to immediately take action to
remove the stain of this outside
involvement
as an important first step members of
the waco hearing team must be called
before the government reform and
oversight committee to explain under
oath their involvement in the hearings
by subpoena if necessary
to further wipe the slate clean the
chairman should also disclose all
contacts staff has had with these
individuals
third i am concerned that some members
the true that for some members the true
agenda is not to find the truth about
waco but instead
appears to be an effort to attack the
nation's gun laws
more important to divert attention from
one of the real issues raised by the
oklahoma bombing namely the rise of
militias and their implications the
american people have expressed the three
to one preferences we've already heard
for hearings of militias not waco and i
have also requested militia hearings
from the chairman of the government
reform and oversight committee
fourth i am forced to note the odd set
of priorities in the government reform
and oversight commitment in the past six
months
when this committee considered five
items in the contract with america we
held a total of just five hearings on
one bill the unfunded mandates we held
no hearings yet now members are being
asked to deal with at least eight days
of hearings on waco we have plenty of
time to rehash waco but where are the
hearings and matters americans care
about such as our health care system and
putting people to work
at the end of these hearings there will
undoubtedly be some positive outcomes
perhaps members on the other side of the
aisle will begin to recognize some of
the concerns i have had over the past
decade in the increase involved in the
militia and the military and domestic
law enforcement maybe they will also
reconsider their efforts to weaken
standards for search warrants perhaps we
can learn additional lessons that will
avoid another weight code however i'm
concerned that our republican colleagues
new interest in constitutional
protections such as the fourth
amendment's protection from search and
seizure has made them feel obligated to
reinvent the facts in this case
a number of our witnesses are being
called to place david korish in a
brighter light the facts remains that
courage had amassed an arsenal of
illegal weapons that there were serious
cases of child abuse including sex with
minors that karish and his followers
fired upon federal agents seeking to
serve a search warrant killing for
agents and that cars ordered the fires
that led to the deaths of his followers
including women and children we will
undoubtedly love of significant efforts
made by government officials and we all
know that two wrongs don't make a right
however we must never forget the context
of this tragedy i would remind my
colleagues that those who wish to
protect civil liberties must be willing
to recognize that those protections
apply to the guilty as well as to the
innocent they apply to all citizens of
this country not just gun owners it's a
mistake for those who feel the necessity
to try to prove that david courage was
innocent of serious crimes to justify
their newly found interest in civil
liberties
so finally as we begin some of the most
controversial hearings the government
reform and oversight committee has ever
conducted i urge the chairman to take
immediate steps to rehabilitate the
long-established honor of our committee
by coming clean on the involvement of
the nra in this hearing anything less
will leave as many doubts in the minds
of americans as they had before these
hearings began i thank you mr chairman
for your extension of time and yield
back the balance of the time
thank you
may i be permitted to ask a question
you can ask a question
yes you can ask ask a question thank you
mr chairman
mr chairman as you know
in a previous congress as chairman of
another subcommittee
i held 27 hearings on the hud scandal
as we begin this series of hearings i
think every member of this committee
is profoundly concerned
that the cloud which hangs over the
opening of this hearing be dispelled
i read very carefully your opening
statement mr chairman
and there is no reference in your
opening statement to the involvement of
the national rifle association in the
preparations for this hearing
several of my colleagues have raised the
issue
i have before me a letter from
my good friend the distinguished
chairman of the judiciary committee mr
hyde which says in part
i share your outrage over an apparent
attempt by an outside party to mislead a
texas social worker
by identifying herself as a member of
the waco hearing team this letter was
addressed to mr conyers
since the media reports clearly indicate
that it was members of your staff
who involved in a surreptitious and
sinister way the nra in the preparation
of these hearings
i believe members of this committee and
the american people are entitled to your
response to these
charges if i may be permitted to finish
myself for the chairman i'm in the
middle of a sentence if my colleague
will grant me the courtesy
mr chairman i think the integrity of
these hearings demand
and the american people are entitled
to your response to this basic question
we need to begin these hearings with
this cloud removed
i believe you are a man of integrity
i believe that you did not know of the
surreptitious involvement of the nra but
i also believe on the basis of preparing
myself for this hearing that members of
your staff
were directly responsible for the
surreptitious and sinister involvement
of the nra in the preparation for these
hearings i think you should have an
opportunity to tell the american people
what the facts are concerning the nra
members of your staff and preparations
for this hearing thank you mr chairman
the gentleman may not uh think
parliamentary inquiries are important
but i believe they are i do
i do too think they are important thank
you for clarifying that uh mr chairman
we were provided prior to the hearing
both in oral communications from the
stats as well as
written communications here certain
procedures we would be following
and at this point i would appreciate if
the chairman could
perhaps summarize those because
i wasn't aware of the fact that there
would be opportunity for
questions uh that are apparently
unrelated to the scope of these hearings
as we've been led to believe in that are
outside the scope of the hearing
procedures we were given could the
chairman uh basically summarize what our
procedures are going to be
the
we're going to move forward
we've discussed
much of this uh in the past few days
i think the key thing here is is that
not only myself but i think all of us
are going to be held accountable for our
results after these eight days and uh
our commitment to everybody is in to the
american people is to give a full
uh open process so we can get at the
truth at waco uh all other issues uh in
in my judgment uh are can be solved or
talked about at a different day but i
think the key thing here is we will be
held accountable for our results and i
think that's the bottom line so i think
with with uh with i think we'd like to
move
inquiry forward your priority
parliamentary inquiry i'm here mr
chairman
my my inquiry then follows on mr barr's
question whether or not uh you would
reconsider and i appreciate the comments
you just made but whether you would
reconsider the rules
that disallow full questioning by all
members of these two committees mr
lantos just asked a question mr barr
asked you to recite the parliamentary
procedures i would ask that you
reconsider because you are disallowing
the full hearing because you're
disallowing members of this committee
from asking questions and i'm wondering
whether i think by prior agreement we
have a process here that that was agreed
upon both by the majority and minority
and and that will give
everyone an opportunity to give
questions at the appropriate time thanks
chairman i raise an objection thank you
would you mind answering the question i
post to you
okay we're going to uh we're going to
move on the chairman and the ranking
members of the two subcommittees have
reached an agreement about the procedure
for questioning the witnesses during
these hearings which is contained in the
document labeled hearing procedures
which all members have before them
without objection these procedures will
be utilized for these hearings
preserving the right to object
uh mr zelda reserving the right to
object
uh
may i uh
reach an agreement that this reservation
will be
sought every day
in this proceeding
so that we may agree upon this procedure
on a daily basis
with with that agreement i would be
willing to uh withdraw my reservation
well i'd like i'd like to get to your
well if i could would you yield to me on
this uh mr conyers as the
chairman of the other subsequently i'd
be delighted uh i realize you wish to uh
with
to have that reservation every day but
if we proceed as you know the reason why
the
hearings are being conducted by the
agreement that we've discussed you and i
and
chairman the two full chairman of the
full committees and the ranking members
on the on the subcommittees have
discussed is because we could not get
through the hearings in eight or nine
days with nearly a hundred witnesses if
we did it by other ground rules and i
understand that you may have some
apprehension about this some of the
members do but i think they need an
explanation i'm using your reservation
to do that and i think you would concur
that what we're about to do if if you're
going to agree to it as i think you you
will
is we're going to move through at least
today and i would hope each day because
we couldn't do it otherwise with 15
minutes of questioning
by each
side each committee
each democrat and republican for four
questioners and then five-minute
questions back and forth and then the
chairman and the ranking members get
five minutes of questioning and we of
course have the power to designate who
does it if we did it by the regular
five-minute rule if the general continue
yield we couldn't we just couldn't
conduct these hearings the way we want
to reclaiming my time all i'm pointing
out to the gentleman is that i'm in
agreement with that procedure all i want
is that this unanimous consent request
be renewed every day of the eight day
hearing i don't have any problems with
that and i guess what we really tried to
do here instead of making this a 51-day
siege within our own
process here we try to limit it to eight
days uh if it doesn't work out we go
back to five minutes according to the
rules and uh we'll be happy to accede to
that request with that agreement i'll
withdraw my research
mr white
i thank you uh mr chairman um i may not
be
uh as kind on this issue because i'm not
a ranking member or a
one of the people who has been
designated to question it seems to me
that a number of the members of this
committee
have effectively been disenfranchised
from participation
by the leadership
whether it's the leadership on one side
or both sides
and
that we just might as well pack up our
bags and go home and review the
transcript of the
of of whatever hearing you all conduct
um
we're not going to be given any
opportunity to to ask questions
we
we are going to
witness a hearing
that proceeds as if it were a
prosecution
with one side
being the prosecutor and the other side
being the defender as i understand the
the process rather than
starting from a neutral position on the
part of
all of the members of this committee as
we typically do
in in hearings where we're gathering
information
and come to a hearing with an obligation
to the american people uh to come
without biases with and and to gather
information for the benefit of the
american public
i
hear you say that
that
the rationale for this is expediency and
and saving time but i'm not sure what
the pressure is
to get through this set of hearings
if they are important hearings to the
american people
then it seems to me we ought to be
taking the
the sufficient amount of time to give
the members of congress the opportunity
to participate
in the process and
so
i wish somebody on my reservation of
right would explain to me the rationale
for
how we are proceeding otherwise i would
uh uh do more than reserve i would
actually object if you would let me and
i and i understand your concerns
um
what we tried to do may be a little bit
unusual but i think we tried to be very
fair and maybe went too far
we tried to split
um the questioning a half hour for the
democratic and the minority in a half
hour for the republicans
and then we tried to just do that in a
very fair and open process we took and
added some 30 witnesses to the list so
we're really trying very hard to make
this thing work in the final uh hearing
panel with mrs reno we went back to the
five-minute rule to give everybody a
chance to to uh question uh
her mr chairman reclaiming my time i
hear the democrats being represented and
the republicans being represented
what i don't hear being represented in
this equation is the american people for
whom we profess to be having this uh
hearing
and um
i'm happy to yield if somebody can
explain to me how we're doing justice to
the american people just by giving the
leadership the right to
to question witnesses rather than each
of us having
the right to
to exercise our responsibility to our
constituents that we were all sent here
equally to to uh to do well if the
general yield of roughly each round of
the panel under the five-minute rule
that we would normally proceed under uh
for every panel we have down here would
take at least three hours
and with all of the involvement of what
we need to do to get through
the process of doing these you're going
to stretch out the hearings knowing what
goes on we take a recess in august and
so forth over a period of weeks not
eight days we're talking probably at
least a solid month of hearings would be
required i think both subcommittees feel
that it is the best interest of all the
parties concerned to attempt to get
through these hearings in the period of
roughly eight days or ten days or
something close to that and it's
strictly a matter of pragmatics
on the han on the one hand i would hope
that your side would have given you a
certain amount of time to be designated
i think on at least my subcommittee on
crime on the republican side every
single one of our members participates
in 15-minute rounds and five-minute
rounds on i think more than one occasion
certainly with a five-minute rounds and
then on the two days we reserved out of
the eight
uh for the main participants at treasury
and at
the justice department for attorney
general reno and for mr noble i believe
uh we will be under the five-minute rule
and you every member here will go
through the routine questions you're
really talking about a portion of the
time
just to try to get through
all of these panels that have multitudes
of witnesses as you know mr chairman
reclaiming my time i i would just say
that um i i'm not going to object at
least not today
if we're going to to redo this every day
but i i really do think we are doing a
disservice to
to the american people
and when we justify that disservice in
terms of
republican democratic politics i think
we do more of a disservice to the
american people because we've simply
acknowledged that we have politicized
this process to the point uh where it's
a political process which is what i
really thought about these hearings in
the first place rather than having any
substantive
benefit
and
i'll i'll withdraw my reservation
and
don't be surprised if i just read the
transcript because if if i'm not going
to be allowed to participate in the
hearing then i just might as well uh
read the transcript and stay at home and
and do some other things thank you miss
jim we we appreciate uh you're
withdrawing your objection uh we hope
that it works out so that everybody will
be able to participate and i think
that's that will be the case the
objection has been heard chair would now
ask
mr
mr chairman i was particularly appalled
in looking at the list of witnesses
at a total lack and a total void
when it comes to the events as mr
klinger the chairman the full chairman
of this committee pointed out at the
events leading up
to the raid at waco
reminds me of a boy
hearing about the events where the
federal soldiers had chased a man
literally through the countryside of
virginia and maryland interrogated
houses shot up a barn and burnt down the
barn that he was in sounds like a
terrible thing
do you realize that man was john wilkes
booth man who killed president lincoln
if we start only with the raid itself
and not the events leading up to it
aren't we in itself going through the
same void
and aren't we in turn
depriving those four dead atf agents in
the 18 or so who were wounded the same
right that the scum criminals of this
country get every time they walk into a
courtroom
that is the right to be presumed
innocent
until they're proven guilty now my
question is
are we going to allow the members of
this panel who have just been cut off in
the time they have to interrogate
witnesses
at least the right to move that we
subpoena additional witnesses so that we
know about the events that led up to
this so we know whether or not it
happened in a void
or that maybe some people were doing the
job that the congress of the united
states hired them to do enforcing the
laws
that the congress the united states
wrote
the whole day is going to be committed
to the events that led up
will the members of this panel be
allowed to addition to subpoena
additional witnesses for example
the people who in the local newspaper
wrote this series of articles called the
sinful messiah
we'll be allowed for example to
interview the branch davidian who claims
he was held captive there for three
months
will be will i be allowed to interview
the deputy sheriff who called into atf
without me yield on that legitimate
yield on that sure asking we have yes
let me answer the question and tell you
that uh i did not know and i don't think
mr zelloff did that your interest in
particular witnesses had not been
addressed through the minority side
because we no i'm serious we had brought
this government's attention yesterday
let me just say this i'm not on your
subcommittee but i just want to make the
overall point with you because we've
been trying to be very fair i think
about 85 percent maybe 90 of all the
minority requests have been granted
we've expanded the panels we've done all
kinds of things and i believe we need at
least to proceed today but if there are
missing witnesses that really are
critical to this that you feel at each
stage we go through we're not really
addressing if you going through ms
thurman mr zelif and your committee want
to bring them up uh we'll look at
bringing more witnesses in here nobody
wants to keep us from having the whole
story told least of all me
with if i can have the that
understanding from the other chairman i
will drop my objection
you want someone the same understanding
okay
the understanding is is that if there
are people
that we feel like need to be subpoenaed
who need to have their side of the story
told of the events leading up to the
rape
that they should be subpoenaed and
brought before this man you know
i certainly i assume you agreed to that
i i mean within reason the names we'd
like to review them with you yeah what
do you say
and the bottom line is is we have been
open to everybody's suggestions we have
now got 90 witnesses if we've missed one
that you think is really vital you know
sure we'll be willing to listen and talk
to you about that mr chairman says we
have with everybody else mr chairman
reclaiming my time i think it is
inexcusable
that the people who wrote the series of
articles that appeared in a local paper
that
around the time of the raid were not
subpoenaed
i also think it's inexcusable that the
deputy sheriff who initially called the
atf in which is the purpose of the
federal government is to help out the
locals when they need it the sheriff
will be willing to not but the deputy
sheriff his name is uh we meyer if i'm
not mistaken
the deputy sheriff is here i think it's
also important that we have the
gentleman who claims he was held hostage
there for three months
join in with you in a more informal way
about the list that you're concerned
with miss conyers if if i can have that
agreement from the chairman
about my objection i i think the
chairman has given it and i think the
other ranking members have joined in
with him already without objection so
ordered thank you i drop objections
mr chairman i i will not actually object
i just want to add that
certainly this these two subcommittees
as we proceed
should look carefully at adding to the
witness list if it's appropriate to do
so
as we go along and as we take testimony
from the witnesses
i just want to point out that in
response to the gentleman from
mississippi's observations the only
federal charge
that was made as a
point out that in response to the
gentleman from mississippi's
observations the only federal charge
that was made as a basis for the alcohol
tobacco and firearms department raid
mentioned weapons charges
there was no charge of any other kind of
criminal violation
so that this is not a a
investigation of the of the branch
davidian
uh group it is an investigation of the
law enforcement procedures that related
to that group not to the extent
that any additional witness would
contribute to that i would certainly
join with the gentleman from mississippi
but i would i would ask the chair
to keep us focused on what the purpose
of the hearing is with that i withdraw
my reservation and you'll back my time
mr chairman i reserve my right to reject
mr chairman
mr chairman i just i wanted to follow up
on the gentleman uh mr taylor's comments
about additional witnesses
i had the opportunity to
discuss with
one of the spouses who might be here in
the
audience
of one of the wounded atf
and i would like to add to the
discussion that we might have in this
combined committee that there were not
enough
line officers on the witness list
and add to mr taylor's inquiry about
additional witnesses to get
an understanding as to whether or not
additional witnesses are added and
whether or not we
may modify some of the rules that may
allow full questioning whether or not
these hearings could go beyond eight
days would you be willing to consider
that because i really think that
that opportunity should be present only
to get at the facts and the truth both
uh justice and and uh both the fbi and
atf were were very upset about our
request for line officers and we
tried to honor that request
we certainly
can discuss it but we tried very hard to
work within their needs and their
requests on that particular issue
well i will respect that but i think
that it's certainly something that we
should pursue further within the realm
because i think the information will be
helpful for where we're trying to go
which is to correct any errors that
might have occurred the other point that
i'd like to
hear from you on is the extension of
these hearings beyond the eight days if
uh
we we hope it's not necessary but uh
obviously if it needs to go beyond eight
days then we're gonna have to be
flexible and complete our business
thank you mr chairman
i will yield
i'm very happy to have the lady on on my
subcommittee and we have had a lot of
good rapport and i want to continue that
let me make the statement so you
understand and i hope everybody else
does that the procedures that we are
trying to accomplish here today are
unusual and unique and different and
they cannot be done under house rules
unless we all concur i don't know how
many people realize that and i thought
that was what we were working through
through each side of the aisle now
obviously we have not done it through
our majority minority may be sufficient
to vet all of this but we would have to
completely reorganize the scope of these
hearings in the order in which they come
maybe the days even they're going to be
held on
and maybe even carry these hearings over
into september when we get back if we
have to call too many witnesses more
than we already have but i would suggest
for everybody's benefit that if we don't
have all our heads together as we don't
seem to have here and i i did think we
did i think chairman zelf did too
but we don't seem to that maybe after
today's hearings the close of the day
let us proceed today the way we are
because we have our witnesses here at
some suitable time maybe if we have a
break during the day or maybe at the end
of the day we have a caucus
a bipartisan caucus because again this
is not something we're doing
in any partisan way we've tried very
very hard to work out something
everybody could agree to and very
democratic process on these two
subcommittees almost unheard of to be
this democratic in this process claiming
my time let me appreciate the leadership
of all of those who participated in
attempting to structure these hearings
so that we could move forward i think
the key objection in my remarks is not
to take away on how difficult
it is to have these hearings and to
proceed with the number of witnesses but
in fact to get at the true mission as i
understand these hearings are to review
all of the facts to ensure that we've
heard uh if not almost all of the
witnesses and be able to then secure
reasonable responses to the solutions
that we all would like to get at i hope
we will be able to have those
discussions because i think i uh made it
clear that i respected the process
uh in attempting to ordinary uh to
organize these hearings but what i am
concerned about is that we may not be
getting uh the fullest review in light
of the shortness of the time and also
possibly limitation on the witnesses so
i thank the gentleman for his comment
and i hope
i i hope i will not need to object mr
chairman
the question i raised mr chairman
goes to the very integrity of these
hearings
you have not yet answered that question
mr chairman
and you clearly have that option
for the record for the record that i i
would like to if i may continue mr
chairman
for the record i would like to restate
my question
and request that you either respond to
it which would clearly be my strong
preference
or you indicate for the record
that in an unprecedented fashion in
terms of congressional collegiality
you refuse to answer a legitimate
question by a colleague on this
committee so my question mr chairman is
for the record
what in fact has been the involvement
of members of your staff
in
working
with
the national rifle association in a
surreptitious fashion in the preparation
of these hearings i would be most
grateful if you would respond to this
question happy too and i've mentioned it
several times and be happy to do it
directly to you
um
as chairman uh in my involvement here
and i believe uh bill mccollum felt the
same way
that
we wanted to hear
information from anybody in this country
that has anything to do with this
we are very happy to receive information
i think that's that's the critical stage
here we do not have i do not have since
you asked me directly the question a
private agenda
um i do not feel
that the nra uh is controlling these as
you and others have said but that's your
choice that's your decision certainly if
we heard from mrs brady on the opposite
end of that issue or we hear from chuck
schumer just let me let me finish um
everybody has an opportunity to put
their points of view forward and i'm
happy to receive those points of view i
may not agree with those but i think
it's up to us to make sure that whatever
evidence we got
in the process
is evaluated and if credible
uh becomes part of this hearing if not
credible gets rejected now that's that's
the answer to your question reclaiming
my time mr chairman with all due respect
i will be happy to yield to my
colleagues in a minute reclaiming my
time mr chairman with all due respect
you have not responded to the question
the question i ask and sometimes members
of our staff get out of line it is my
considerate judgment that your staff
members did get out of line by involving
the national rifle association we in a
surreptitious manner we don't my
question is did they was this done with
your approval if not what disciplinary
action are you planning
let me before i yield to yeah mr
chairman i'll be
i just want to help
the chairman out here because all i hear
mr lantos asking for
is your agreement to conduct
an investigation
around the nra activity and i think if
you would accord him at least that
simple affirmation
we might be able to get on with this
chairman chairman if the gentleman would
yield i believe
and then to you since i've been active
in these objections and uh we have sent
a letter asking that that happened we
have not gotten we've gotten a response
but it was not responsive to saying
either yes or no whether that would
happen but i would make this point
the national rifle association has every
every right
to make its views known to let the
committee know its views to be here
just as sarah brady would
but
what i would say is very simply this
when they step when when the line is
stepped over
when at least one witness is interviewed
by somebody passing themselves off as a
member of the committee team
the waco team
and then only later because she is a
diligent and careful person does that
person admit that they were from the nra
and that person has mentioned not just
names of nra higher-ups
but that she was going to talk to staff
members here
then something is gone amok when
we know the story of the first instance
the second instance mr sanders isn't
mentioned he's listed on the sheet
as former atf agent
but leaders of the nra say they're
paying them
and he's on the payroll that's the
problem here and we have not gotten a
good answer to those questions i don't
want the record to reflect this is
simply
a group of people who disagree with the
nra saying they shouldn't be heard not
at all i'll be happy to yell after i
finish my point mr lam thank you um
that's would if the gentleman would just
let me con finish my point here and then
i'd turn from new york and then to the
gentleman from illinois always like to
hear what the chairman has to say
because he's a fair-minded gentleman
very much and um but the point is
what
what mixture did the nra take roles that
the staff should have had
did they do it
with the knowledge of the staff
did they do it
with which other witnesses i don't have
any idea how many other witnesses miss
hager who was the person who interviewed
the witness also interviewed and said
she was with me committee team waco and
they may not have been perceptive as mrs
sparks the witness who discovered this
we don't know that
now we can ask each witness when they
come here
but that of course does get us somewhat
off track because they are as the
chairman and both chair people have said
separate issues but there is a cloud
let's make no mistake about it this is
not what usually happens in a hearing
there is a cloud hanging over these
hearings and we are attempting
in good faith to get that cloud removed
so far we've been met with silence i
yield back to the gentleman the
gentleman
i thank my friend for yielding
uh i i think we're getting
a little bit of field here
this woman who represent evidently
represented herself as from the waco
hearing team
had no connection with the judiciary
subcommittee
and as far as i can determine from
talking to staff no connection
with the reform and oversight
subcommittee she is an independent
person acting independently and what she
said was in fact a
misrepresentation and i would suggest
you take it up with her
or take it up with the nra but don't
hang that around the this subcommittee
uh
or mr zella subcommittee now furthermore
when staffs are preparing for hearings
you use the word unprecedented it is
unprecedented to want to know who
they're talking to what their work
product is
certainly on the freedom of access to
abortion clinics the question of who
your staffs met with uh i don't care
it's none of my business and who our
staffs meet with and their work product
and their correspondence and their
interviews is confidential we don't want
to know what your staffs have done and i
don't think it's appropriate to delve
into the preparation for hearings that
is unprecedented i can say i can say
this with all a vigor
there is no connection whatsoever
between the national rifle association
the gun owners of america sarah brady
handgun control congress watch or any of
those organizations
in preparation for these hearings and so
i really wish we'd get off this
diversion this side trip
and move forward on what happened at
waco
i thank you if i may reclaim my time and
i will yield to my friends i would like
to tell congressman hyde with great
respect and great affection this is not
a diversion some of us view that this
undermines the integrity of these
hearings it is anything but a side issue
it is anything but a diversion it goes
to the integrity of the congressional
hearing process that we all ought to be
deeply concerned with i'll be happy to
yield to my gentleman to my colleague
from michigan uh
may i remind chairman hyde of the letter
that mr schumer and i sent to him if the
nra has been working under color of the
committee then certain questions are
raised undisclosed efforts to have
private organizations fund weapons
analysis on behalf of the committee
raised troubling issues both criminal
statutes and rules of the house
restrict certain activities this is not
a
an incidental matter this is goes to the
heart of the integrity of the hearing
for instance 22 usc section 59e
prohibits any member from using an
unofficial office account or from
defraying officials expense from any
other funds that are not specifically
appropriated for official expenses
similar with house rule
of 45. now
only the chairman can subpoena issue the
subpoenas to quiet this problem and all
we're asking chairman zelif is that you
agree
uh so that mr lantos can withdraw his
objection
by agreeing to issue a subpoena to
determine
the appropriateness or perhaps
inappropriateness i'm afraid of the
conduct of which we're complaining this
letter has not been answered that is
precisely the basis of my reservation mr
chairman and if you agree to the point
so ably stated by my friend
from michigan i would withdraw my
objection i will now yield time to my
friend from new york
um mr chairman and i thank the gentleman
for yielding just two points in
reference
in re in response to uh the gentleman
from illinois the chairman of
distinguished chairman of this committee
first of all
what leads us to think that perhaps
ms hager the person who passed herself
off as working for the waco committee
team
was more involved with the staff of the
committee
than you were saying is she told that to
this witness and in a memo i have here
which she sent to mark barnes who was i
guess her boss he's the outside counsel
for the nra she said everything that she
well i'll quote it
she said information and resources
information resources and evidence
gathered goes to march bell
who is charged with the coordination of
the congressional effort he is a member
of the staff now maybe she's just doing
this on her own but it doesn't sound
like it and we ought to know that the
second point i would make to the
distinguished chairman who talks about a
committee's work product being
sacrosanct
if i just might
if i just might
er
mention this to the chairman
is we've spent about a week i see the
council for the president negotiating
the very same point
that the work product of the president
ought to be sacrosanct just as you say
we don't want our committee staffs to be
uh looking we don't want everybody to
look at how we set up a hearing and how
we did this
well the majority has been spending a
week making the opposite point with the
president that his private notes and
what he said to his staff
we should be able to examine and perhaps
should be public we went through a
process which with your good offices and
that of chairman klinger worked out okay
and with the generosity and the wisdom
of the council the president's council
mr mikva but it certainly seems to me
that it is not fair to on the one hand
say well the committee's work product is
sacrosanct but the president's work
product is not the two arguments seem to
me to be the same i yield back to the
gentleman be happy to yield to the
chairman
i i just would like to say that that i'd
be very happy to be held accountable for
our results of these eight days hearings
we have worked very hard to work with
both sides of the aisle here we've given
instead of the proportional we've taken
an hour and divided up equal time for
both sides
we have taken and we've done everything
we can to adhere to your request for
witnesses i think it's been
unprecedented i think it would be a real
shame if we can't move on with our
hearings and the schedule that we have
here and get to the panel
you certainly are able to ask witnesses
that appear before us any questions you
want as to who they represent and who
they'll be under oath
i just ask you to give us a chance to do
what we intended to do this is not this
is this i will be most happy to give
that chance to all of us mr chairman if
you commit yourself to subpoena
the persons requested in the letter i i
think what you're doing and and i have a
great deal of respect for you
but what you're doing is a diversionary
tactic that's going to do nothing but
throw us off track we're trying to waste
time now we have people have come here
from a long distance let us proceed with
what we tried to do here we have
agreement on both sides we selected
witnesses why not give them a chance to
appear before ask them we'll ask them
questions
the whole is accountable for results in
the end mr chairman i respectfully
request that a subpoena be issued to the
individuals indicated in the letter of
the distinguished ranking member of the
judiciary committee and if that is
granted i will withdraw my objection
so generally
i'll be happy to yield to my friend
thank you gentlemen for yielding i would
just say that uh i haven't been in the
congress that long but i certainly
know when there's a coordinated effort
to delay
and engage in dilatory tactics and i
think it's very important that we move
forward with these hearings there's been
a lot of discussion of the national
rifle association i happen to be one of
those members of congress
who has a zero rating from the nra i
voted for the brady bill i voted with
the gentleman from new york on the
assault weapons ban i thought those were
important i disagreed with some of my
colleagues i noticed that some of the
members of the minority have a hundred
percent ratings from the nra the point
is that those are irrelevant to the
questions we're asking today about what
happened at waco texas and we need to
have oversight questions asked and i
think that we should move forward uh on
these hearings in the interest of time
and in the interests of our witnesses
i i agree with the sentiments expressed
by my friend
i think it is a matter of collegial
courtesy to agree to a reasonable
subpoena request we cannot issue a
subpoena on the minority side only the
chairman has the authority to proceed
with a subpoena and i am wondering why
he is so reluctant to agree to this very
simple request which would in just one
moment which would then enable us to
proceed immediately there is no reason
mr chairman why this subpoena should not
be issued except your reluctance to
agree to it and i request i repeat my
request would the gentleman yield i'll
be happy to yield to the gentleman from
new york i thank the gentleman and let
me make a suggestion here because we
have even though as my opening statement
is clear and many of the others we have
many doubts about some aspects of these
hearings we do not want to see them
delayed although i completely agree with
the gentleman that there is a cloud over
these hearings and these questions are
legitimate what i'd suggest is this
since we are only going to
um
remove our objection for today
and tomorrow that objection will hold
again at the suggestion of the good lady
from new york
um that we proceed today that we meet
after the hearing with the gentleman
from california and those of us here
that we meet with the majority
membership leadership
this evening this afternoon and see if
we can resolve this issue and that way
we can proceed today and still have our
right to insist that the truth come out
in reference to the aspects the
gentleman brings up i would i would join
the gentleman from new york and his
appeal to the the the gentleman from
from california mr lantos uh
the only delay is coming from the
chairman's refusal to give you a y e s
on the question of subpoenas and so
uh in the interest of time i think we
it's pretty clear to everybody that can
hear where we are let's see if we can
meet uh
after these hearings today and resolve
this matter and i thank the gentleman
for his very important and timely
contribution i want to thank all my
colleagues and i withdraw my objection
without objection so ordered
unanimous consent request is agreed to
i would like to introduce
the
first panel
and if you would please the three
members please come forward and take
your places
as you're
settling into your seats
dick revis is the author of a two-year
research project that is now
a book published by simon schuster on
the events surrounding the confrontation
between law enforcement and the branch
davidians
the book is right here
so everybody can see it
i don't know whether there's a book
signing uh process but uh
stuart uh wright stewart is the editor
and it contributed to the forthcoming
university of chicago book on the same
topic entitled
uh armageddon waco
and ray yan rayon is the assistant
united states attorney who prosecuted
the branch davidians who survived the
fire
and i don't know whether he has a book
forthcoming or not i'll let him describe
to that if the custom of our
committees here that we swear in our
witnesses if you'd all please stand
and the testimony you're about to give
these committees do you solemnly swear
to tell the truth nothing but the truth
please be seated
but the records show that
answers were in the affirmative
before we go to the witnesses we have a
short film that was created for these
hearings by cnn
that runs from february atf 8 through
the april fire i want to thank cnn for
this special footage and effort we'll
now show this and it's approximately a
three-minute film
mr chairman
mr chairman
yes uh i thank the chairman we
in all fairness to the chairman some of
these procedures including the fifteen
five five five
procedure we had talked about
and we were informed we would know what
would be happening in these hearings we
were given some witnesses not as not all
that we would like but many and
we we exceeded to that we didn't know
anything about this cnn film clip at all
and i'd like to
say to the chairman one of the things
that i've appreciated is you've told us
you know in general what the structure
of the hearings was going to be the
reason for that was not pure generosity
it was because of the five-minute rule
you've listened to that for the last
while we didn't know about this so what
other what other thing can we go over
what's going to happen today from start
to finish
as you know cnn just offered three
minutes of overview there is nothing in
here that's been edited by us we have
anything to do with it presumably it's
an objective film there's nothing that
you don't know about that i'm aware of
going to go on today we have the three
witness panels that are been published
and a list of names that were given
to you last night are the exact names of
the witnesses that will be there none
others not to my knowledge
and is there any other audio visual uh
aid that's no
not that some witness has brought
something with them they haven't told us
about
okay
i'd yield to the general to the church
the ranking member of the government
thank you very much you know i find this
very strange that we'd have a film clip
going on here i mean that's not a part
of the process that we all agreed upon i
don't know anything i have never agreed
to having any film uh clip here
furthermore i mean it's impossible for
us to uh to interrogate a film well you
know what would china witness that what
happened and this is
what happened it's been on television
it's been on nightline it's many things
and i would object to that film clip
being shown at this point in time
is that a part of the regular procedure
mr chairman uh could i i yield to the uh
ranking member the judiciary might i
just recommend that we get this these
hearings underway by withdrawing a film
clip that no one had noticed about even
members on your side i don't see where
that's going to add
your two authors of the book
uh i don't know what more cnn can
contribute to this we're not asking
unanimous consent to show this film
and we we plan to show the film can i
just reclaiming my time
there was there is great dispute about
parts of this hearing as is obvious
there was also some level of committee
and that committee involved the fact
that we would know what each day what
was going to happen each day not in
terms of what the witnesses would say or
what questions were asked but rather who
was testifying who they were how the
panels would be structured and how the
questioning would go
i don't i doubt there's any problem with
a three-minute tape on cnn cnn is not a
uh
well i gentlemen's time you're inspired
please proceed with this
consent to make my point for an
additional minute i'm going to proceed
with the film mr chairman the the chair
is denying unanimous consent that i that
i uh speak for another minute to make my
point here
is there objection
i think
gentlemen reserves right
mr chairman i reserve the right to
object and i i regret that i have to
take this uh this step but we've seen
uh
delaying tactics by the minority that uh
in in my estimation are unprecedented
the
the
it's obvious that the minority
uh first of all hasn't taken the time to
consult with the minority members nor to
fairly distribute time uh to their
memberships
or to impart with them
the procedures
furthermore the majority side has been
over backwards to provide witnesses
the majority side did not know that in
fact
they were going to spend the first hour
of this hearing
or more in dilatory tactics
to use the occasion to bash
various organizations or interests with
which they disagree
and
uh mr chairman i move that the uh joint
subcommittees uh do uh
uh he do view this uh
film
would the gentleman yield yes
the motion is in order to consider the
evidence not yield and i asked the uh if
necessary the previous question on my
motion mr chairman mr chairman mr
chairman i wish to be heard on the
movies be heard on i was trying to solve
that i was trying to just make sure that
there wouldn't be anything else like
this nothing i wanted to finish the
difference
chairman i wish to be heard on the
motion listen
mr chairman i have a motion uh and uh mr
chairman i wish to be heard on the
motion
when you cut me off if there was
anything else he can't make this motion
until his time is expired
he's going to object to the time that he
didn't get recognized
is he going to object to the time can we
can we move
back his time has not expired and uh
we'd like to give him his time to finish
my emotion at this time okay i would
remind
my friend from florida if we wanted to
be dilatory any one of us could object
to these procedures and throw the whole
thing into a tumult and
stop them for today we're trying to get
fairness from our point of view which i
i hope the gentleman will respect all i
was asking is are there going to be any
other things that we didn't that we
weren't told about that were happening
today other than this three-minute film
no and as far as thank you i have no
problem with proceeding with the film
let's move forward parliamentary
importance
proceed with your parliamentary mr
chairman i was not aware that showing a
film clip
as a part of a hearing was part of the
regular order
um
could you cite me to a rule that
that sanctions this we have a list of
witnesses that has been distributed to
everybody
um
and uh
i i have never i mean i can see this is
just my second term here but i've never
participated in a hearing
that started with uh by by the showing
of a film clip of any kind
i thought we were here to hear witnesses
and
for those who are allowed to participate
in the process question those witnesses
even those people who have been
sanctioned to participate in the in the
questioning process are not going to be
able to question this film clip
so i i the the question i'm asking my
parliamentary inquiry is what is it in
the rules that that sanctions this
process
uh rule 11 clause 2
k-8
in the discretion of the committee
witnesses may submit brief and pertinent
sworn statements and writing for
inclusion in the record the committee is
the sole judge of the pertinency of
testimony and evidence that
uh addressed at the hearing mr chairman
uh this film clip is not submitted by
any witness that that is evidence as to
what happened at waco there's no there's
no witness who has
requested that this film clip be
submitted in connection with their
testimony and i would submit to the
germans this
does not sanction the subcommittee is
choosing to receive this three-minute
clip
as evidence from whom
i i have i have
received it from cnn chairman from cnn
beat my parliamentary inquiry what is it
in the rules which sanctions your
ability to come in and show us a film
clip
without
proceeding in the regular order of the
of the hearing which has already been
agreed to
may i speak to the gentleman's point
i served
on the government
operations subcommittee which is a
predecessor to government reform and
oversight and i can say
uh cite a precedent for this i served
under mr seiner who was chairman of the
energy environment natural resources
subcommittee and i was subjected to at
least a three minute film clip in which
uh uh white mice uh were put on
carpeting that was taken from the at
this time it wasn't revealed but
carpeting that was taken from the house
chambers
uh supposedly in the little white mice
uh
rolled over on their back and and uh
subsequently expired
i was not given
uh i was not given uh notice uh
of this and in fact we found out the
reason that the carpeting had
uh had been so contaminated
was taken from a storage area
that was in fact treated with uh reclaim
by a bug spray outfit and that's what
killed the uh
uh that's what killed the white mice so
uh there is precedent and there's
president within our subcommittee and
committee
thank you reclaiming my time on the
point of order mr chairman i think that
the gentleman's uh
uh
analysis is that two wrongs make a right
and and uh we should therefore agree to
this
can i appeal to you all i asked was is
there a provision in the rules of this
house or this committee which sanctions
this proceeding and yes there is i'm not
i'm not trying to delay this i would
just like to know what the rule is and
the rules that the chairman read to me
simply doesn't get us there
mr chairman
if i may address that i think that the
point was mr chairman i i've been
encouraged by my side to withdraw my
objection i still don't see anything in
the rules that allows this i withdraw my
reservation of right or reservation of
objection and we'll be happy to work
with you right ahead mr chairman sure
thank you it's obvious that you all are
going to run this hearing just like you
want to run it anyway
regardless of the rules um i'll be happy
to move work with you and and go
and discuss that rule with you we now
would like to proceed with the film
i assume you have somebody there to do
it
you turn up the
you have sound
were led by david koresh the
self-proclaimed prophet preached that
the end of the world was imminent and
that it would begin with a battle with
non-believers
on february 28 1993 caresh's prophecy of
a battle came true though the debate
continues about who fired first the last
words david said to me on the on the
morning of february 28th when he came
down the stairs and there were people
coming you know
we could hear the helicopters in the
background he said they're coming
they're on their way don't anybody do
anything stupid
75 agents of the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms raided the davidian
compound looking for weapons but as soon
as they arrived a gun battle broke out
number one what's your emergency
yeah the 75 men around our building and
they're shooting at us in mount carmel
the 45-minute shootout left four agents
dead and 20 others wounded
six davidians were killed that day and
koresh was wounded
for 51 days fbi agents encircled the
compound negotiators tried a mixture of
persuasion and agitation to get the
davidians to come out but only a few
left
so the fbi changed its strategy agents
began gassing the compound and knocking
holes in the walls
around noon on april 19th
fire broke out and within minutes the
building was engulfed in flames
nine davidians escaped the fire but
about 80 including koresh remained
inside and died i really don't know
eleven davidians were indicted on murder
conspiracy and firearms charges during
six weeks of testimony prosecutors
brought in more than 120 witnesses and
piles of charged weapons pulled from the
rubble of the compound
atf agents testified they were ambushed
news video of the raid and secretly
recorded audio tapes from inside the
compound were played for the eight woman
four-man jury
the government's key witnesses were
three former davidians they testified
about koresha's predictions of a war
with non-believers
one said the davidians were trained to
use guns
two others talked about a mass suicide
plan
but all three said there was no
conspiracy to kill anyone
defense attorneys claimed the guns were
bought and sold as a business venture
throughout the case they raised
questions about the atf and fbi tactics
they argued that the davidians were
assaulted by the atf
and acted out of self-defense
tony clark cnn san antonio
we'll proceed with the first witness mr
revis
thank you for being here and we
appreciate cnn for supplying that film
didn't have anything to do with cnn
supplying the film i understand that uh
you each have 15 minutes and we
appreciate very much for being here
is this microphone on it sure is
i'd like to start by thanking the
members and the staff of this committee
for giving me a journalist the chance to
talk to our government about what
happened in waco in 1993.
i want to emphasize that i come to you
as a journalist
that means that i'm not an expert as you
must know from your own sad experience
i'm not an expert on anything
i think the
job of journalists is not merely to
repeat what experts and authorities tell
us
but to look at it in the light of common
sense and i think that's the job that
the members of these committees
now face for yourselves
i want to give you an overview
of some of the things that happened in
1993 in waco
and in so far as i can explain why they
did
i have cut
the remarks i wanted to
present
in view of the
ruckus that i've just witnessed here
which is taking time from everyone
in brief what i cut says that
david koresh's community was founded in
1934
it had doctrines and traditions that
dated back to 1844
david koresh did not invent the doctrine
he taught
he altered the doctrine he taught
the people who followed him
did not follow him because he was david
koresh
they followed him because what he said
made sense of the tradition
from which they came as far as they
could see it
his followers whatever david koresh was
his followers were rational people
who were capable of evaluating things
and rejecting them and some did others
accepted him
one of the prophecies that had been
around mount carmel
since 1934
call for an ultimate confrontation
between god's people
or those at mount carmel
and the forces of an armed apostate
power called babylon
which in most fundamentalist literature
is is is recognized or and he would say
is identified with the united states or
the united nations
perhaps be
quresh had looked at those prophecies in
his own twist on them and it was only a
twist on existing prophecy
was that the confrontation would take
place in 1995.
perhaps with that in mind in 1991 he
began studying armaments
and buying and selling guns
he pretty quickly found out there's a
lot of money to be made at gun shows
and he and other people started going to
gun shows
and they bought and sold
they bought items that weren't guns and
they bought items that were guns
we now say or the press now says and
most people say they stockpile weapons
all gun dealers stockpile weapons all
gun shops stockpile weapons
we call those stockpiles and inventory
there was an inventory of weapons at
mount carmel
a number of guys were involved in the
gun shows
just as a number were involved
in
souping up and restoring cars
and just as a number were involved in
playing in the band there were circles
or knots or subsets
of people who had hobby interests that
were only indirectly related to theology
and guns were one one of those interests
those guys knew how to use guns
the rest of the people there did not
necessarily know how to use guns
some of them
were older women in their seventies who
were not capable of using guns
many of them were children who weren't
as tall as the rifles
in june 1992
the atf was advised that someone had
mount carmel had ordered a box of dummy
grenades
these grenades are legal in trade
they're used for paperweights novelty
items one thing and another
and though ultimately some of those
grenades were armed and used as weapons
the survivors say they were initially
bought to brad onto ammunition best vest
that they made at mount carmel and sold
at gun shows
the atf began its investigation its
investigation led to the house of henry
mcmahon who will testify before you
the atf was questioning mcmahon about
some guns that quresh owned
mac behan says and his girlfriend karen
kilpatrick has testified under oath
that back behind picked up a portable
phone and called quresh this was july
the 30th of 1992.
he said david they're here the atf is
here asking questions about your guns
koresh says
tell them to come out and see me
makbahan offers the phone with koresh on
the line
to special agent danny aguilera
when court testimony it said that he
made this motion
he would not accept the call
the atf refused to visit quresh and did
not ever speak to him until february the
28th
of 1993
when its words were police search
warrant lay down
one of the things that must be asked and
i'm not sure if we can get an answer at
this point because quresh is dead
is when he converted weapons illegally
from semi-automatic to automatic
my suspicion would be
that at some point he says
the atf is investigating me and it
doesn't want to talk to me
aha
the army of
babylon is preparing its attack
the affidavit that
ultimately came out of the atf's
investigation is weak on several points
there's no evidence between august of
1992 no notations and november of 1992
as if perhaps the investigation had been
dropped
i would like to know if that's the case
i have not been able to find out i hope
your committee can find out
why was there no activity from august to
november
in november aguilera and other people
began interviewing old associates of
koresh
dissident followers
who didn't know much about guns are much
about koresha's fascination with guns
but did know a lot about child abuse and
statutory rape
my investigations convinced me that
david koresh was guilty of statutory
rape
but i don't understand why two-thirds of
the search warrant is about child abuse
and statutory rape when the atf has no
jurisdiction over those offenses
what in a word what the search warrant
found
was gun parts
legal gun parts but in this way
both a hacksaw and a shotgun are illegal
anybody can buy them
owning a sawed-off shotgun is not legal
it was the duty of the atf to show that
those gun parts were owned with an
intent
to create illegal weapons
i'm not a lawyer or a judge but my
reading of the warrant does not convince
me that that intent was there
though we know that in fact the guilt
was there someone inside mount carmel
did convert those weapons
the next question that i encountered
during my research or the next important
one was whether or not the raid of
february the 28th was necessary
and i want to speak particularly to
those of you who are
congressmen here because i believe the
atf has
attempted to mislead our congress
when its executives have spoken to you
in the past about the necessity for the
raid
in april 93
david troy an atf executive testified
before the house subcommittee on
appropriations
and he said that the raid was necessary
because and i want to quote him directly
from the congressional record
we never saw him off the compound until
after we had an arrest warrant for him
that's the end of the quote troy did not
tell the subcommittee that the arrest
warrant was issued just three days
earlier on february the 25th
and that atf agents had begun training
for the raid on february the 24th
in june 1993
dan hartnett another atf executive
testified to congress that there was no
time from a time in january until the
day of the raid
that we had ever seen him off the
compound that's the end of the quote
now the atf conducted surveillance for
about 30 days prior to the raid from a
house 200 yards from mount carmel's
front door
and as it turns out on january the 17th
david koresh was next door to the atf's
undercover house
in the home of the landlord of that
undercover house
on january the 29th according to
testimony in the san antonio trial
he signed a receipt in waco for some
machine work on a motor
the receipt was introduced in into
evidence in the san antonio trial
and on february the 24th four days
before the raid
he visited a junkyard in waco a junkyard
employee testified under oath to that
if
as mr hartnett told the congress
they had never seen him off the compound
and they had him under surveillance
i don't understand what their
surveillance people were doing
next question becomes in the treasury
department's
report on the events at mount carmel
says that the raid failed causing the
death of those four agents and the
wounding of others because the element
of surprise was lost
i think that you all should probe to see
if the element of surprise was important
the advice the atf was given before the
raid
by the green brays and after the raid by
almost every commentator
was that if you want to surprise someone
you raid them at dawn
two men were dismissed from the atf
agent cereben and wanowski
because they allowed to raid to go ahead
despite knowing that the element of
surprise was lost
they were fired but they kept their
mouth shut
everyone who was still on active duty in
the atf was under a gag order
they kept their mouth shut and appealed
to a civil service court to arbitration
and serbian's brief and that civil
service arbitration says and i'll read a
direct quote
for the agency to contend that surprise
was the focus of agent cereben is to
misstate the decision to proceed with
the raid end of quote
that civil service arbitration hearing
was not open to the public and i don't
know on what basis it made its decision
but it reinstated both cereben and
wanowski
the next question that i think is
important involves the helicopters that
flew over mount carmel
according to the atf's report they came
simultaneously
according to the testimony of their
pilots in the san antonio trial in which
mr john was prosecutor they came perhaps
30 seconds after the ground troops had
arrived
but at that trial two waco reporters
dan maloney and john mclemore
showed a film they had made they had
been a half a mile away from mount
carmel
at an intersection 2491 and doubly ranch
road
filming helicopters as these helicopters
made three passes over mount carmel at
close range
they got the third pass on film
they were putting away their equipment
when the cattle trailers drove by
carrying the atf ground raiders
so they pulled in behind those cattle
trailers and followed them into mount
carmel and produced the footage we've
all seen
what their testimony in film proves is
that those helicopters came over first
probably a minute and a half before the
ground troops got there and that's
important
because the first shot
both sides say
in this context both sides would have to
say
was either towards those helicopters or
from those helicopters
at the san antonio trial
mr john and his associates were able to
bring about the conviction of a man
named kevin whitecliff
for having shot at those helicopters
the residents of mount carmel
say that those helicopters shot at them
they claimed the shots came first
attorneys dick to guerin and jack
zimmerman who visited mount carmel
during the siege say they examined
bullet holes in the roof
and zimmerman is a
reserve marine officer he'll let you
know that in a minute
and he says those bullets came from
above
from up in the air into the house
at the trial no one in that helicopter
a pilot testified that he thinks no one
in his helicopter fired but none of the
atf agents who were armed in those
helicopters took the stand
one of them will come before you in this
hearing dania aguilera i would like for
you all to ask him if he or anyone else
in those helicopters fired upon mount
carmel
use the helicopters is controversial
because in order to get them or in the
process of getting them the atf told
both the department of
defense and the texas national guard
that it needed them from for drug
interdiction
it claimed there was a methamphetamine
lab at mount carmel and eleven drug
traffickers
the list of 11 drug traffickers was
presented to congress in one of the
hearings and i checked out the names
one man at mount carmel was busted of
pot in 1983 five years before he came to
mount carmel
two of the names listed were the names
of people who david threw out of mount
carmel in 1988 because he suspected them
of running a drug lab your time is just
about expired if you would try to finish
this and run them
one of the people named was a 71 year
old lady who i call the arresting
officers cited by the atf in congress
and they said they'd never heard of her
the same for catherine schroeder and her
husband michael
that charge of the drug lab is
fabricated
i will close now
without talking about the fire but i
want to make one appeal to you all
like any good journalist i started my
book by writing the government agencies
involved in asking for information
the freedom of information act
has become the stalling act
i received letters two months later
saying wait six months at a minimum
some of the documents i requested were
scheduled for release in 1999 in the
year 2000.
the freedom of information act and all
the agencies i know is being ignored
how can the government tell the people
what really happened if the government
won't turn loose of its records
thank you thank you mr evans mr wright
uh with the witnesses full statements
being made part of the record yes thank
you
without a gesture so ordered
sure
there should be a hundred copies with
the everybody do you have a copy you
want to wait until it was
john you got it when we got it but
you have it located everybody else have
it
i have some foi letters i would like to
introduce can i hand them to someone
without objection so ordered someone
pick
mr wright
please proceed
i'd like
i'd like to preface my remarks to say
i'm a lifelong democrat i support
the brady bill and the ban on assault
weapons
may i interrupt mr wright just a moment
mr revis i didn't understand what you
introduced what did you hand forward
those are letters that i sent to
government agencies asking for
information and their replies thank you
uh having said that uh
i think there are some serious problems
with the federal law enforcement
response at waco
ladies and gentlemen we live in a
special time in history as we edge
inexorably toward the end of the 20th
century we bring closure to the second
millennium since the birth of christ we
are on the verge of a new millennium a
new age
i don't need to tell you that there is a
rich religious symbolism attributed to
this historical event
there are an estimated 30 million
conservative protestants evangelicals
and fundamentalists
most of whom hold fast to the doctrine
of biblical literalism and await the
return of the historical jesus of
nazareth in a cataclysmic episode
referred to as the second coming
many believe this event could take place
in the near future perhaps before the
year 2000
these themes are preached in pulpits all
over the country on any given sunday
one can hardly find a baptist church of
christ or pentecostal congregation in my
neck of the woods
that doesn't sound this message on a
regular basis
thousands of small churches remote
communities safe sanctuaries of true
believers
far removed from the centers of power in
wall street or washington
carry the biblical message forward
within this sector of the population
there are hundreds of religious groups
not unlike the branch davidians
independent proud defiant religiously
devout believers who think the larger
secular world is morally bankrupt
historians and sociologists know that
dissident millenarian and apocalyptic
ideas will become more widespread in the
next few years and this raises an
alarming question
could there be another waco on the
horizon
after the conflagration of the branch
civilians on april 19 1993 president
clinton asked the same questions all
americans were asking
namely why did this happen
could this terrible tragedy have been
prevented and perhaps most importantly
what did we learn from waco could this
happen again
judging from the government reports
media accounts statements from officials
and justice and treasury the transcripts
from the san antonio trial of 11 branch
davidians and the previous congressional
hearings on waco i would assert that we
learned very little
i would also hold out the strong
possibility that we could face another
waco in the future
federal law enforcement particularly the
fbi has refused to accept any blame or
responsibility for the violent outcome
at mount carmel
therefore by simple extension of logic
if the federal agencies did nothing
wrong they are not likely to correct any
policies or practices and future
altercations
after all the davidians did it to
themselves didn't they
let me outline a number of problems with
the government response to the davidians
and suggest why i think we could indeed
have another waco
first of all i have no confidence in the
atf
and they would not conduct the same
military style raid under similar
circumstances
most of the criticism criticism has not
been directed at the method of entry but
rather for not abandoning the raid once
the element of surprise was lost
but the more important question is why
was such a raid necessary in the first
place
why did the atf not seek to execute the
search and arrest warrants in a more
peaceable means
treasury report indicates that faulty
intelligence gathering led to the
preclusion of this alternative
the reports say they relied on the
comments of a social worker joyce sparks
failing to corroborate when amounted to
hearsay
i don't have time for a detailed
analysis of events leading up to the
raid i would refer committee members to
chapter 4
of my edited volume armageddon and waco
to be published by the university of
chicago press next month i have
submitted the text of this chapter for
the written record and subcommittee
staffs have been given pre-publication
copies of the book
suffice it to say that had agents served
the warrants while mr korus was visiting
an auto repair shop on january 29 1993
or at a junkyard in the waco area on
february 24th it is likely that four atf
agents and 80 branch davidians would
still be alive today
limited and overburdened government
funds would have been spent more
humanely and judiciously
you and i would have never heard the
branch davidians and these hearings
wouldn't be necessary
to put the matter succinctly the
enforcement actions were excessive and
this raises another point i would like
to stress
the atf garnered an exaggerated and
embellished portrait of the davidians as
particularly sinister
it is important to remind ourselves that
this was the largest raid in the history
of the atf
in effect the davidians became
caricatures of evil
posing alleged threats or dangers far
exceeding the actual problem
it appears now that the agency was
caught up in what social scientists call
a moral panic
undermine the agency's ability to make
more sensible judgments in its plan of
enforcement
there are reasons this came about it did
not develop in a vacuum
before during and after the siege of the
mount carmel community government
officials repeatedly referred to and
vilified the davidians as a cult
cult is a slippery and politically
loaded term with little scientific
validity at least in its common usage
it typically amounts to a moral judgment
not a scientific one
in this context it is pejorative and
derogatory invoking the worst possible
stereotypes and once a fixed as a label
it seems to just
give justification to the most heinous
discrimination
representatives of the u s government
have no business perpetuating this kind
of prejudice and stereotyping
the law does not make such distinctions
even as certain interest groups in the
media do
it is my opinion that in the development
planning of the atf investigation
agents adopted the ideology and
perspectives of anti-cult organizations
and deprogrammers
it seems clear to me now that we can
explain the sex excessive actions of law
enforcement
in terms of the fear-mongering and hate
rhetoric that often characterize these
groups
i would like to recommend a moratorium
on the term cult especially by
government officials
and i think federal law enforcement
should be more vigilant about their
sources of information in the future
these are not impartial and
disinterested sources
one does not approach the ku klux klan
to learn more about african americans
neither should law enforcement policies
be guided by religious hate groups
second i have no confidence that the fbi
knows how to deal with millenarian or
apocalyptic religious sex
they made a number of crucial mistakes
in their operation at mount carmel and
again these are clearly laid out by
several contributors to my book in
particular dr nancy amberman who was
asked by justice to review the actions
of the fbi and waco
and dr james tabor who has who had an
excellent grasp of porsche's adventist
theology
professor tabor along with dr philip
arnold had a key role in persuading
korach to reconsider his exegesis or
interpretation of revelation and i'm
convinced that the davidian leader was
well on his way to finish his finishing
his sacred writ and making good on his
promise to come out peacefully when the
fbi impatiently assaulted the compound
on april 19th
we now know that fbi officials never
notified attorney general reno of the
april 14th letter by courage stating his
intentions to write down his revelation
and then give up
because they had already defined him as
a con man using religion as a guise for
criminal activity
i read a few days ago in a hearst news
story that byron sage the lead
negotiator for the fbi and waco
dismissed korish's promise to come out
because korris had broken a previous
promise
but there's a lot more to this story
subsequently we have learned from the
newly released tapes and transcripts of
the negotiations that courage promise
the course promise wasn't broken at all
the fbi changed their demands and then
disingeniously told the media that
korach had lied and broken his promise
perhaps this was part of the
psychological warfare strategy to
humiliate and ridicule a sect leader in
hopes of breaking the bonds of loyalty
among his followers
but it must be said that they did so
without regard for factual accuracy and
the american public has a terribly
distorted view of these events as they
were conveyed by bureau officials in
press briefings
the use of psychological warfare
strategy also indicates that the fbi
misunderstood their adversary
this tactical approach has been used
effectively on terrorist groups and drug
lords the davidians were neither
and did the fbi never knew who they were
dealing with or how to assess accurately
the probable actions of the davidians to
make matters worse some of the people
they did consult were active in
anti-cult organizations
i refer specifically to psychologist
murray myron and deprogrammer rick ross
prominent members of the cult awareness
network whose comments distorted and
confounded the problem
dr amberman later stated in an addendum
to her report that ross was the expert
having the most success extensive access
to an influence upon the atf and fbi and
was listened to most attentively by them
i would exhort the committee members to
please read the reports submitted by the
behavioral science experts sullivan
cancro hammerman and stone
their assessment is damning pointing out
incredulously that the fbi ignored
religion as a viable motivating factor
on what basis do federal law enforcement
agents make such value judgments
does the fbi regard non-mainstream
religious practices or beliefs as
invalid
have they expanded their jurisdiction
into matters of theology
equally upsetting is the fact that the
fbi has refused any offers of assistance
from scholarly experts on marginal or
new religions those of us who have spent
our entire careers studying sectarian
religious movements have been shut out
we weren't consulted before the raid or
during the standoff and we have been
rebuffed since the waco incident even
though we have made good faith efforts
through the formation of the religion
crisis task force headed by dr philip
arnold
i find this arrogance
disturbing and it only convinces me
further that another waco is possible
a third reason to think another waco is
possible follows as a corollary to the
previous point the fbi assembly has no
response team or list of experts
prepared for the next confrontation with
a defiant religious sect
i'm assuming this to be the case since
they have not acknowledged any errors on
their part
but in truth they made critical errors
in judgment
in waco the fbi miscast the davidians as
hostages
the 50-person hostage rescue team a
counter-terrorist unit was called in at
the outset the standoff was classified
as a complex hostage barricade rescue
situation
but if the fbi had understood the nature
of the beast they would have proceeded
differently and realized that no one was
a hostage
the davidians sent out a videotape on
march 9th showing interviews with
members who asserted that they did not
want to leave
even the justice department report
conceded in hindsight that and i'm
quoting page 205 in the report
each person on the video male and female
young and old spoke in a calm assured
tone of their desire to remain inside
even after the experience of the atf
raid only a few days earlier
the abiding impression is not of a bunch
of lunatics but rather a group of people
who believe so strongly in korres that
the notion of leaving the squalid
compound was unthinkable end quote
unfortunately the federal agents had no
religious framework or conceptual scheme
from which to understand the motivations
of their captives
the idea of surrendering to pro a quote
proper authority end quote as the agents
demanded would have been tantamount to
betrayal assuming a judas role
one has to appreciate the purely
religious scenario these people believe
they were facing
they were principles in the biblical
tribulation standing with god's anointed
prophet they weren't about to come
cowering out in abject surrender to the
babylonians to be paraded in chains
before the unbelieving public suffering
mockery and scorn
the davidians lived in a separatist
religious community and in their
universe of discourse a religious
language was required to communicate
with them
i won't belabor this point but the fbi
had at their disposal experts who could
speak the davidians language doctors
arnold and tabor
their advice was not heeded
they will appear before you to testify
later in the hearings and they have an
important story to tell i hope you will
listen to them carefully
subcommittee members i implore you to
use these hearings to get at the bottom
of this tragedy
to ask hard penetrating questions of
those who know but are not saying
after two years of research and
investigation i still have unanswered
questions and i close by leaving you
with some of those questions perhaps you
can get answers
why was a warrant sought in the first
place since david korush on learning
that he was being investigated by atf
invited the agency on july 30th 1992
through his gun dealer henry mcmahon to
come to his residence and inspect his
firearms
why did the atf use armor-piercing
ammunition which would easily penetrate
the flimsy walls of mount carmel when
insulting a location known to be housing
dozens of women and small children
why did the atf or why did the affidavit
filed by the atf to obtain a search
warrant include allegations of child
abuse a state offense over which the atf
has no legal jurisdiction
how is it possible that a deprogrammer
associated with the cult awareness
network rick ross an ex-convict with a
psychiatric record came to be an outside
expert who in the atf or fbi decides who
is an expert what kinds of professional
criteria or credentials are considered
if any
one of the branch davidian survivors i
interviewed claimed that helicopters
strafed the roof of the mount carmel
building with gunfire killing a fellow
davidian
film footage by television newsmen on
the scene indicate the helicopters
arrived before the ground party where
the helicopters firing on the davidians
and if so doesn't that make moot the
point or the argument about who fired
first on the ground
why did the fbi abandon good faith
negotiations with korish and move to
psychological warfare strategy the
tactical commanders in waco had to
ignore the advice of their own
behavioral scientists
at quantico
agent pete smerrick who was in charge of
drawing up the psychological profile of
courage counseled a cautious
non-confrontational approach with
courage in four memos
written to senior fbi officials between
march 3rd and march 8th
according to mr smerick fbi superiors
pressured him to change his assessment
to justify
a more confrontational approach
was any consideration given to the
effects of psychological warfare on the
children at mount carmel cutting off
water electricity blaring tibetan chants
sounds of rabbits being slaughtered
dennis drills shining floodlights
why was his strategy of tightening the
news continued and escalated even after
residents responded to negotiations by
sending out children
this undoubtedly induced confusion and
sent mixed signals to the davidians a
result confirmed in my interviews with
them dr robert cancro an independent
expert later remarked that this
inconsistency we're going to have to
just let you know that your time has
expired if you can just take about 10
seconds because we have a vote and we're
going to have to move forward
dr robert cancro an independent expert
later remarked that this inconsistency
has many of the features of a double
bind
is it no wonder that the confidence in
the integrity of the negotiations
deteriorated and finally why was
attorney general reno
not informed of the april 14th letter by
korish promising to surrender
i think the american people deserve
answers to these questions
thank you thank you mr wright and uh mr
yan we'll proceed when we get back uh
we'll open up with you but uh the
subcommittee stand or the committees
uh stand in recess until 1 15 pm and
we'll resume mr yan's testimony thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you're watching the first day of waco
hearings before the house joint
oversight and judiciary committee
we'll return in a moment but first some
program information
our companion network c-span 2 welcomes
over third ban a public service created
by america's cable television companies
we now continue with the first day of
waco hearings before the house
government oversight and judiciary
committees
chairing the committee's republican bill
zelif of new hampshire and republican
bill mccollum of florida
this part of the hearing runs about 20
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
all right
subcommittees will come to order
will we uh review renew uh
the uh panel mr yan would if you would
proceed
the gentleman in front of you would just
uh kind of open up and give you a path
mr chairman ladies and gentlemen my name
is ray yahn appearing with me today at
the table is my co-counsel and my wife
laurie morganyon
jointly we were the prosecution or part
of the prosecution effort into those who
were charged in connection with the
events which occurred at mount carmel
between the two of us we have 44 years
of experience and investigation and
prosecution of those responsible for
violation of federal law
we are not appearing today as as
management within the department of
justice because we are not management
we're not appearing in a policy or
position or making or a decision-making
position because we're basically career
prosecutors and that's our duty we're
assigned to prosecute criminal cases
we are here though because of being in
that position we had an opportunity to
review more information and interview
more witnesses than probably any other
single person within the department of
justice and in that regard we were made
available as you know to your staff to
try to correct some of the myths and
misconceptions that have arisen during
the course of the last two years
in that regard we appreciate the
opportunity to appear here before the
committee to try to to gain give to you
our insight to give to you our direction
is perhaps where some of the answers may
lay that over some of these questions
that are have and to to
give you some of our opinion in
hindsight which of course is 2020 and
gained in in background uh some of the
the myths for instance that pop up you
see them everywhere just this morning
for instance uh and this is one of the
things that we might want to pay
attention to
mr riva suggested there was something
sinister
surely i'm sorry something sinister
about davey aguilera's failure to
conduct an investigation during the
period of august to november of 1992. i
have not spoken to special agent
aguilera about that i understand he may
be a witness later on but based on my
experience i'll tell you what the answer
is
during this period of time mr aguilera
works for an agency that's assigned the
treasury department those of us who are
in law enforcement know that treasury
department from about mid-summer until
november is tied up in the campaigns
that's their main function they borrow
from customs they borrow from atf they
borrow from internal revenue service
they get as many special agents as they
can to augment the secret service i
would be willing to surmise and that's
what it is at this point but i will be
willing to surmise that mr aguilera will
answer that particular that's the reason
that he could not conduct any
investigation at the time
it is not though or the risk is the
danger is that it's it's a basis on
which someone has formed an opinion
and then based upon that opinion they
start to scour the record looking for
evidence that will support that opinion
and that's what i hope and i feel this
this
panel will steer away from in this
particular regard uh for instance the
other gentleman made some comment about
how this was an ordinary religious
movement out there at mount carmel i beg
to differ with you my hair stood on in
when i read the interviews of five and
six-year-old children that came out of
mount carmel knowing how to commit
suicide knowing to put a gun barrel in
their mouth and blow the top of their
heads off
that is not ordinary religious doctrine
that is not what we are dealing with so
that's one of the reasons i wanted to
try to share with you some of our
opinions that we came to over this
period of time
and the first opinion i've we prepared a
joint statement which i'd like to ask to
be submitted and made part of the record
but our first opinion was basically that
the branch davidians were not coming out
that was a decision that was based or an
opinion that that came to be uh
held by virtually everyone
as of the middle part of april of 1993.
the tragedy that's involved here
actually begins back in 1992 when when
david koresh makes his prediction moving
his timetable initially from 95
up to passover 93. in the passover
season of 1992 this is based on our
witnesses testimonies he predicted that
that was going to be the last passover
that sometime during the year of 1992 to
1993 the confrontation with the beast
which in this regard he personified as
the government of the united states
had to occur that was his theology it
was based on his theology the the
followers were there they believed in
david koresh they believed his teachings
as he as every survivor who testified
testified to that quresh meant death
they followed that particular belief
they were there to die they were there
to die and according to croatia were
either going to die by bullet
they were going to die by fire they were
going to die by tank or if they were
fortunate they would be translated to
heaven without having to go through the
agony of death but the one message that
he taught and this again was testified
to by the three survivors who testified
on behalf of the united states was in
order to show your worthiness to go to
heaven you had to be willing to kill you
could not die for god if you could not
kill for god and in the words of one of
the survivors there were no
conscientious objectors at mount carmel
we were prepared to prove but the court
excluded it for the reasons i'll tell
you in a second of a instruction and a
plan that david koresh discussed with
his followers and this is what we call
the mcdonald's plan and in that he
encouraged them to go out in the
community in order to force a
confrontation with law enforcement to go
out in the community take over a public
facility a mcdonald's or if you recall
there was an incident in colleen
involving a luby's cafeteria take over a
facility
take the people inside hostage hold them
at gunpoint and force them to admit that
david corrections was the lamb of god if
they refused he encouraged and directed
his followers to do so to kill them if
they refused it it was our opinion that
what he was trying to do here was to
force a confrontation with law
enforcement authorities he later backed
off on that he later came back and said
well it was just a test and of course if
any of you are familiar with jonestown
and the actions of jim jones that's what
he did to condition his followers to
take the poisonous suicide sinai was to
go through these tests of it's time to
commit suicide it's time to impose these
things drink the suicide and die
he also during the same period of time
and you'll hear from this witness he
testified to it or told an outsider who
was there examining the child abuse
allegations
he told her that when i reveal myself my
true identity the riots in los angeles
will pale by comparison this is right
after they headed the major riots in los
angeles we were also prepared to prove
through the testimony of witnesses that
even even when that lady came to make
her interviews the branch davidians had
intentionally kept away from her the
small children who were david's children
they did not want to see the 15 or 16
children that ran around at about the
same age that were david's children
because they were afraid that if they
did they would start questioning the
ages of their mother indeed one of the
plans that we had in the event that
we've been successful on obtaining david
corrections arrest was to take dna
samples from him and from his children
to prove that he had been having sex
with minor children and then submit that
to the state so the state could
prosecute him for being the child a
child molester
we established that david koresh
intended to have a confrontation that's
what he was after he was going to have a
confrontation sometime between passover
of 1992 and passover of 1993 and
unfortunately it was atf who stumbled
into that intent unfortunately it was
atf who arrived on february 28 to to
initiate or execute a lawful search
warrant and instead koresh had 45
minutes warning had a notice that they
were coming and spent that 45 minutes
instead of preparing to to surrender or
to arrange his resident counsel he had a
lawyer inside the building with him to
arrange a surrender he spent that time
preparing
preparing to to resist the agents
there's some surmise concerning uh
helicopters and whether or not the
helicopter shot at uh the the davidian
compound that day we presented the
testimony of mr maloney uh i know mr
rebus wasn't there during the course of
the testimony and he had to go back and
read mr maloney's testimony mr maloney
was quite clear using the map that what
he was talking about was not the first
intersection but he was talking about
being in a location some mile behind the
compound back behind the hills this is a
very hilly area and then beyond that
seeing the helicopter circling and that
was perfectly consistent with the
testimony of the citizen soldiers of the
texas national guard who were flying
those helicopters that day that they did
some distance away some miles away orbit
because they were trying to wait for the
time factor they did not realize that
the raid had been moved up there was no
testimony from any pilot or any person
on board those helicopters of any
gunfire but more significantly there
were videotapes that were made from
those helicopters and they were
delivered to defense council and they
were paid played for the purpose of the
jury there is no evidence no sound of
any gunfire coming from any of those
helicopters indeed you can hear the
bullet striking the helicopters but you
can't hear the bullet any sound of any
gunfire going out of those helicopters
with this kind of mindset was also
confirmed the fact that there was a
suicide pact within mount carmel this
was something that wasn't discussed that
much in the press but every survivor
testified concerning that suicide pact
and basically what the design was or
what the plan was was that david koresh
thought he was dying he thought that
wound that he received on february 28th
was so severe that he was going to die
and when he died his followers were
going to come with him when he died they
were going to put his body on a on a
stretcher they were going to come
outside with their women and their
children the mighty men the men that
were loyal to him were going to be
carrying his children they were going to
have guns and hand grenades concealed
they were going to pull those guns and
hand grenades and open fire on the fbi
thereby forcing the fbi to fire back a
suicide by cop exactly what it was
trying to force the fbi in front of the
world press to be humiliated to be
criticized for shooting women and
children and shooting shooting people
that were there
at mount carmel and then if that failed
they were going to kill themselves they
even went around selecting their friends
as to who was going to be the person
that was going to kill you they went
around and rehearsed how they did it
this again is based upon the testimony
they went around and rehearsed how to do
it how many people
can dial a hand grenade should we have
three of us or should we have four of
them standing around when the hand
grenade is pulled who's going to pull
the pin
that was the degree of rehearsal it got
to the point where they finally even got
down to say goodbye to each other they
gathered in the cafeteria on about march
the second or third they had religious
services to the extent they had they
sang songs david all of a sudden send
out messages he was feeling better and
that's when the message came that god
said to wait now no witness testified
that god would told him that he was
going to surrender all he told him to do
was wait there was never any testimony
that david koresh intended to surrender
likewise during the 51 days of the siege
there was never any indication that
david koresh was going to surrender
there was more negotiations hundreds of
hours of negotiation tapes all of which
have been released to the public there
were hundreds of hours of title iii and
i understand now that the department of
justice has obtained finally obtained a
court order that permits those to be
released to the public those indicate
that there was no intention to surrender
the only people who came out of mount
carmel during the 51 days were people
that david koresh sent out he selected
for various reasons to go out an example
kathy schroeder the lady who who made a
deal with us and testified on our behalf
she was sent out because she was a
sinner when david koresh was weak she
had smoked cigarettes she had drunk
alcohol and and when he got his powers
back and when we recovered his powers he
became incensed over that he called her
in and he told her he'd already sent her
children out they were going to stay in
the world and not go to heaven and he
told her you've been such a sinner that
you're going to interfere with my
chances to get these my followers into
heaven and so therefore i'm going to
send you out and you're going to stay
here while i die and then once i die
then i'll come back and get you but
because of that because i can't risk
your sin
jeopardizing my mission i'm going to
send you out that's the reason that the
the negotiators no matter what they
thought
never could understand why they couldn't
get more and the reason they couldn't
get more was at the any time they got
something it was because david koresh
decided they were going to give them to
him
the branch davidian started the fire
we proved so conclusively that the
branch davidians started the fire that
two at least two defense council
conceded it during closing argument we
proved it through direct testimony of of
uh experts we threw proved it through
a multiple type of experts uh fire
marshals from all over the nation that
did an investigation a phd professor who
you'll hear from watches tape it's a
great tape uh who came up with the fire
analysis we proved it through the
scientific evidence showing the
scattering of fuel throughout the
compound we proved it through the title
threes they were the ones that were
heard on nightline the other day mr
rivas i think describes him as being
murky i'll be truthful to you i heard it
i heard it the first time i heard listen
to it if you didn't hear it go back and
listen to nightline again you can hear
the instructions even through the the
gas mask even though it was too
difficult to hear on april the 18th
april the 19th when you go back now and
listen to it you can hear the
instructions you can hear spread the
fuel have we spread the fuel yet have we
saved some well you can also hear some
of the passages where you say we set the
fires when the tanks come in this was
the type of evidence of the degree of
evidence that we used to affirm or to
prove those particular matters and then
lastly of course it was confirmed by the
presence of the forward-looking infrared
camera that was located on the plane
above this is another area where we have
myths that grow one of the myths is well
the fbi must have known there'd be a
fire or else they wouldn't put that
camera up there
this operation started in the dark this
operation started before sunrise that
camera was up every night during the 51
days it would circle it would make those
photographs it would follow that
particular area and they were trained
observers what better choice to the fbi
than to leave that camera up there even
though it did go into the daylight not
because they they thought a fire was
going to start but merely because they
wanted the extra set of eyes they were
up above what about the the
still pictures that were taken from the
cam from the plane of above take a look
at those examine them it shows where the
tanks were it shows how far they went
inside uh one of mr rivas's uh
suggestions is that the boom operator
the tank operator went in and knocked
against that bunker that you see on the
the later portions and knocked down some
some stones and killed the people inside
outrageous
the boom operator completely ignores the
testimony of the operator a marine corps
veteran who was trained in the marine
corps to operate this very vehicle who
very carefully goes inside and never
goes through look at the floor plan even
in mr rivas's book there's a room a hall
a room and then the bunker never goes
past that very first room never
penetrates beyond that first room in
order to inject the tear gas in there
and open up the various uh sides of the
wall and one thing you need to remember
on that too the testimony of all the
survivors that came out all but two two
did not but all but two of those
survivors came out through holes that
had been made in the walls by the fbi
tanks two came out windows but the rest
of them came out through those holes
that was part of the reasoning behind it
there was testimony as to what the
reasoning was why that operator used his
skill to go in there and open up that
particular area and it was to open up
the area it was to provide an escape
route uh this is the kind of
myth that we're concerned about this is
a kind of myth that that leroy and i
would like to be here uh we also
established for instance that that the
survivors that came out their clothes
smelled of accelerants they smelled of
of
diesel fuel they smelled of lantern fuel
they spelled of lighter fluid and the
laboratory later came back and confirmed
that they had done it there was more
suggestion or surmise that there's some
sinister purpose of the tank coming down
near where the bunker is if you'll see
some some later film there's a picture
of the tank down there with his blade
out
that ignores again the testimony of the
operator who testifies concerning why he
was there and what he was there for he
knew that he was in danger he knew that
if that building fell over in him he was
uh yes sir your time has expired if you
could kind of i'm sorry your honor
sorry mr chairman i didn't realize that
[Laughter]
we submitted our other matters in there
and and i think the most important thing
to remember is that leroy and i to the
extent that we can speak for anyone
speaks for the hundreds of law
enforcement persons state person local
and national whose lives have been
affected by this matter who are not the
beasts they're not out to encryp they're
not out to inflict any damage they're
not out to injure anyone they're your
brothers and your sisters and your
mothers and your fathers and your sons
and your daughters and let's not forget
that during the next year
thank you very much uh we have a a
problem here you've been hearing some
bells um we have two votes pending maybe
three and the process means that one
will be for 15 minutes which we're going
to immediately move out to do there may
be two five-minute votes after that
procedure is it will recess until five
minutes after that series of votes so if
you'll be patient i appreciate that we
look forward to uh
asking all the panel their questions
recess
thank you
for recess to five minutes after these
series of votes
[Music]
this is the first day of coverage of
waco hearings before the house
government oversight and judiciary
committees
we'll continue testimony in a moment
but first some program information
america online subscribers can
participate in a computer chat room with
republican senator thad cochran of
mississippi
thursday night at 8 pm eastern time
if you're connected to aol you'll find
the chat room using the keyword c-span
if there's a public affairs event in
your area you think we should cover
call the c-span events line
our telephone number is area code
202-626-7900
you can also fax us at area code
202-737-6226
or contact us by email
your message should include as much
information about the event as possible
the name and phone number of a contact
person would be appreciated
follow proceedings in the house and
senate with our 1995 congressional
directory it includes biographies of
members committee assignments and
information about c-span programs the
cost of the guide is 12.95 including
shipping and handling to order write
c-span publications 1616 main street
lynchburg virginia
24504 or call 1-800-520
we continue now with the first day of
waco hearings before the house
government oversight and judiciary
committee
a note 45 minutes into this portion
there is some graphic testimony
subcommittees please come to order
the
procedure that we're going to use here
on questions that
the subcommittee and committee chairs
and ranking minority members will each
have five minutes to ask questions
and the chair will uh begin
mr uh
rabbits did that pronounce that right as
rabbit cerebrus
um
let me just
just ask you um you've been researching
this project since
1993 two years
um
and what do you believe and this is a
real easy one but just in in 30 seconds
or less
what would you believe the most
important thing we can do
to pull in these hearings to to uh
that would come out of all these
hearings i think the most important
thing would be if you could declassify
or give to the public and the press
all of the documents that we haven't
been able to get at
for example all of the raiders gave
statements to the texas rangers
the federal prosecution has those
statements
nobody will turn them loose
um i have to admit we've had some
trouble also
i i understand y'all have so first of
all would be the documents that exist
they shouldn't be kept secret it's been
two years there's no longer any good
reason for that
thank you
uh mr yan
the uh
just a couple questions when you were
prosecuting the surviving the davidians
maya correct that
um in addition to what you have already
testified to that you charged 11 of them
with murder that's correct
and
11 with aiding and abetting murder a
conspiracy to murder and then and then
the actual aiding and embedding the
murder itself
and 10 were using or carrying a firearm
in the in the commission of violent
crime i i'm going to accept your word of
that chairman i i don't remember the
exact number on that but
yes sir okay and is it true that david
stated that they were acting in
self-defense
that was a charge that was given to the
jury but there was no evidence to
support that charge
there was no evidence that they were
afraid of atf as far as being physically
afraid that a particular atf was going
to fire them or anything like that the
court bent over backwards and gave them
a self-defense charge but but they
basically that was their that was their
basis i mean they said that they were
acting and it is true that they were
acting in self-defense that was one of
the was one of their defensive claims is
it true that no davidian was convicted
on accounts mentioned that they were not
on the murder and experienced murder
that's correct yes sir thank you very
much um
i want to just
to ask you that
during the days immediately after the
atf raid a shooting review is conducted
which
involved asking questions of all atf
agents involved and at some point that
review turns into questions that could
produce information that's helpful to
understand exactly what happened
the texas rangers state and i refer you
to treasury bates number 14137
that you mr yan wanted the review cut
off
my guess my question is why would you
of all people want to cut off a process
that was designed to get at the truth i
think that was a mistake uh mr chairman
i didn't come on board until april the
1st
and it's my understanding that that
there was a decision made to stop the
treasury review and let the rangers do
all the all the investigation and gather
their information but i think that was a
mistake on the report because i had no
no one consulted me about cutting off a
treasury review
uh so i think it might be a mistake now
if perhaps they talked to the us
attorney who was who was on the case
prior to april the first do you think
any you have any knowledge of any other
federal prosecutors uh cutting that off
no not direct knowledge no but say
perhaps they talked to mr ederer that's
the only thing i could think of okay
um
let me move on to another question um
see
on
we found a set we had thousands and
thousands of pieces of paper that to go
through and many much of it was very
well very unorganized
found a set of handwritten notes that
looks to me to be from someone at the
treasury department they read as follows
1 20 p.m per tony
ray yon advises us to tell ron noble not
to open the envelope from houston
chronicle
contents are
from illegal intercept lock-in safe and
keep
doj researching possible violation by
paper for printing and distributing
i couldn't help but be intrigued by what
this waco related note means could you
shed some light on what was in this
mysterious envelope and why ron noble
could not open it and why was it being
locked in the safe yes sir we we
subpoenaed and obtained from mr maloney
the tv uh cameraman or actually was the
other one his total tape on his total
tape they had a scanner there was
scanning uh cellular phones which is
probably an illegal interception of
those cellular phone telephone
conversations if we had permitted that
to be circulated around that would have
been in itself illegal in terms of
spreading it around even letting mr
noble listen to what
his agents were monitored saying that in
itself would be illegal so we we stopped
the spreading until we could edit out
those portions of the illegally seized
cellular phones that investigation was
referred to justice and i don't know
what they ever did in terms of of
whether or not that constituted a
illegal wiretap by the press or not i
don't know what the the final outcome of
that was if all this is the last one
there's a quick one if you knew all the
bad things about david koresh why was
why didn't you
uh arrest him in town well i i wasn't
there i didn't come on until april first
i think what you need to do is address
that question to mr aguilera who's going
to be here mr johnson who will
there's no obligation once the warrant
is issued there's really no obligation
to do it as a matter of judgment and and
we're willing to admit there were some
mistakes made in judgment in this
particular matter
thank you very much like the chair now
yields to my friend karen thurman the
ranking minority member from florida
good afternoon um mr rivas
you keep talking about these documents
can you give me a better sense since
you'd like us to ask a question on this
of what it is and what documents is that
you're still looking for i saw your
um interview on tv the other morning
that had suggested that now since then
you've gotten the tapes i guess since
the trials you were given tapes from the
fbi what other documents is it that
you're still requiring okay the the
tapes as you call them i got transcripts
of those tapes
and i got them through a process that i
think was irregular an attorney named
joe turney who had got them for
discovery
gave them to me
no one has yet been able to get a copy
of those from the fbi through freedom of
information act
though about two weeks ago the fbi put a
set in its washington office
and you can go in during working hours
and look at them
so
they've been declassified to the
washington dc press which doesn't help
us a lot in dallas
but in particular the documents i just
mentioned were these
after the february 28th raid the texas
rangers interviewed all of the writers
took a statement from each of them typed
it up
and
we have only seen about 20 of these
statements
from those writers who the prosecution
thought it might call as witnesses in
the trial
i tried to get the other 60 statements
for example from the texas rangers they
told me i'd have to sue to get them
um
let me think what else could could they
could there be a reason why
maybe mr yan is a counselor i'm i like
you i cannot do the reasons they've
given me
they say that there's a lawsuit
and that they don't want to complicate
that litigation
and my assessment of that is that if the
owner of the watergate building had sued
richard nixon
and we would have let him say
gee there's a lawsuit i can't give you
any documents
history would be much different than it
is today mr young would you like to
respond to that i know there's a billion
dollars worth of lawsuits filed against
the united states and there are
exceptions under the freedom of
information act
exceptions that are granted by this
congress to to exclude the discovery of
those items that would compromise
litigation pending litigation that's the
reason until the criminal trial was over
there was virtually no discovery
whatsoever since that time i know miss
reno has given instructions to make as
much as possible but again because of
the fiscal limitations on manpower and
duplication and copying and everything
there's a big backlog on
foia requests uh i was told that this
normal this delay what she's meeting is
just a normal delay because of all the
other people who have come in ahead of
him filing their requests and they have
to be processed you take out informants
names you take out the names of people
that were promised uh confidentiality
you take out uh privileged sources and
then you turn it over at the end and
that's just a normal process there's no
effort to conceal anything in fact mr
rivas if he had called me and asked me
uh some information he prints in there
that i was involved in the decision
making to to inject the cure gas and
that's totally false
if he had given me the courtesy of
calling me i would have told him no sir
i wasn't involved in the decision-making
to inject the tear gas uh so it's not a
question of trying to hide something
it's simply a question that we operate
under the rules that congress imposes on
i can tell you during the crime bill
everybody in the world wanted a copy of
the crime bill we couldn't get it to
everybody either so
we kept having problems
um mr rivas in on page 14 of your book
you talk about um the fact that the main
premises of your book is that the press
did not investigate the events at waco
and that only you really understand
these events could you kind of describe
for us how your findings differ from the
rest of the reports uh who are the
reporters who have covered this story
first of all i want to say thanks for
reading my book well you're welcome
all right that's my job it does
what happens to the press during that
time and i think most of its members
will admit this to you now
is that their budgets got spent during
the 51 days the search warrant for
example was sealed
for most if not all of that period
so the press couldn't even find out what
it was that david koresh was supposed to
have done it had to take the word of
spokesman for it
after those 51 days were over i went
down and for example ran into the
transcripts of all the telephone calls
from mount carmel
to
the fbi
and for a year i had those and i told
people i had them and nobody wanted them
the biggest surprise i encountered in
writing this book is that i had no
competitors
and naturally my conclusions differ or
my questions differ because i learned a
lot more than they did because they
abandoned the story when the building
burned down now
of course there were some who didn't
abandon quite as quickly as others but
in general this represents a major major
failure of the press in our country
mr one another question that has been
kind of surrounding this has been um
about whether koresh was having sex with
girls
as young as 12 and 13 years old what
evidence is there that quresh was having
sex with children
we were ready to present testimony of
for instance the midwife who had given
birth to some of the some of the young
girls
we we felt so strongly that they said it
was our
our plan to take his dna upon uh leaving
the compound and take the dna of the
children and prove it up uh we just
basically even i've even heard catherine
manson one of the ladies that was
mentioned the survivor that came out she
was interviewed on the waco paper and
she admitted uh one of the one of the
girls was 14 years old when she gave
birth to uh to one of david's children
so it was it was a kind of a a secret
but it wasn't a very closely held secret
from within within the members of the
message
thank you
now recognizes
chairman mccollum in florida
well thank you very much mr chairman mr
yan i want to ask a question of you
first with regard to the trial itself in
terms of testimony was there any
testimony at the trial about atf
officers carrying firearms while they
were in helicopters on the day of the
raid yes they were carrying firearms and
they had been cleared that the the rules
were that they could not have a round in
the chamber and that was the the rule
that the pilots operated under as they
flew toward the area
what uh was kathy schroeder's testimony
at trial relevant to the helicopters and
firing she was on the front side of the
building and she didn't have any any
personal knowledge any direct knowledge
that was her testimony at the trial
itself yes well
that's my if she was even asked uh that
would have been her answer i can't
remember now whether or not she was even
asked because she was she was at the
front side of the building during the
whole time of the of the
transaction well we just had a lot of
conflicting testimony about helicopters
as you know and i wanted to find out
what had come out of the trial mr revis
uh you have stated in your book uh and
in a couple of comments that you made
here quite a bit about the
aftermath of the siege i should say
aftermath of the the 28th of february
the siege and the fire itself you didn't
get to testify much about that today
but mr yan made a big point as i
gathered from his testimony that there
was a lot of planning going on and that
david koresh never intended to surrender
as i recall you've got some indication
that david koresh would have surrendered
right along i'm sure you sat there with
me listening to mr yan's testimony and i
wondered if you could respond to us what
your your investigation unearthed and
why if you do disagree with mr yan on
that point why you disagree
mr john said this morning that there was
never any testimony about koresh
planning to surrender and nothing in the
tapes or transcripts
in the transcripts on the
14th 15th 16th and 17th of april the
18th as well
there is discussion between steve
schneider david koresh and several fbi
negotiators
in which david says as soon as i get the
seals written i'm coming out this was a
big decision for him incidentally
because he believed his doctrine should
never be written down
until april the 14th
and the fbi negotiators say at one point
can we go to the bank with that and
koresh says yes you can
and in another point they say will you
send us the seals out as you finish them
and he says yes
my interpretation of those transcripts
is that koresh thought he had an
agreement to surrender when he was
finished writing those documents well
now the in the other side of that coin
is the impression being given maybe that
quresh was just simply lying all along
that he was just playing people along
outside i mean that's i hear that
throughout some of this from the atf
side and the fbi side of this is that is
that not your impression you know when a
man is dead we can convict him of
anything and accuse him of anything
uh
dave i believe that david was being
honest because always before he had said
my message cannot be written god does
not want it written the bible's already
written and that's all we need
all of a sudden on the at the end of
passover on the 14th of april
he decided that he had to write his
message i think he was persuaded by
tabor and arnold two theologians
uh but we can't know
we can know that he said that we can't
know now what would have happened
because we didn't wait to find out would
you care to give us your criticism if
there is any of the final day of the the
fire you said you didn't have time to
give that uh
and what led up to it i think the best
information on this point and it
supports what i say in my book is that
the methylene chloride that was injected
into mount carmel with the ferret rounds
that its vapors are flammable
there's a long article in the sunday
issue of the los angeles times by glenn
bunning that has more expert information
than my book had
it establishes methylene chloride is
dangerous you should not throw it
inside of buildings its manufacturer
says what about come along you had an
agent come along you said that after he
had his little period of time that
things really changed when the fbi took
over the negotiations can you tell us
about that it's his name was jim
cavanaugh i can now say that i'm away
from simon schuster's lawyers
all right
i think he did a good job and koresh and
schneider were greatly displeased when
he was pulled off
he did a good job because he let them
lecture him on theology and they thought
they were making a convert out of him
and after he was pulled off
they threw a fit because they felt he
had been pulled because he had listened
to them and during the time he was on
quite a few people were let out is that
right that's right thank you very much
thank you mr chairman
thank you
the chair now recognizes the ranking
minority member from new york mr schumer
thank you uh mr chairman first mr yan
have you read mr revis book
sorry i have not okay you wanna read i
read excerpts of it unfortunately
okay from the excerpts you have read and
the testimony you've heard today how
would you characterize the accuracy the
factual accuracy of mr revis's
beliefs and observations about what the
incident in wake up the ones i have
direct personal knowledge of i know he
didn't ask me about my knowledge and my
involvement my participation but he does
assert that i had a a personal interest
in the outcome of the trial because i
had done it
the other one is is for instance he
describes me as short i'm six feet two
inches tall maybe about texas ranger
standard that's short but an ordinary
person that's not defined as short i i i
have not had a chance to go through one
by one but like so many of these uh
not so many but but there are some
things that are grossly wrong some
things that are slightly wrong and some
things that are correct uh then
everybody couldn't have a series or at
least the parts you know a series of
inaccuracies yes sir thank you now
i uh
this is a uh
an ak-47 rifle that's converted into a
machine gun
let me ask you mr yan do you have any
doubt
any doubt
that there were illegally converted
machine guns like this in the davidian
compound none whatsoever in fact we
found two one in a car and one in the
ashes both of which still fired no doubt
at all and second from your knowledge as
a us attorney
do you believe that it is ever ever
appropriate
to answer a federal warrant no matter
how poorly drafted with the machine gun
i don't believe that i believe that
that's the purpose of going to court so
you can resolve it that's the purpose of
having excellent attorneys like these
defendants did eventually on the trial
so that you can't make that
determination thank you and it's my
understanding by the way and we'll bring
this out later that none of the
excellent attorneys and he had some of
the best in the southwest that none of
the excellent attorneys that uh
represented the people ever challenged
the legality of the warrant is that
correct the the warrant itself they did
not they challenged the knock and
announced provision there was a hearing
on that the court found that it had been
compliant but not the legality of the
war that's correct and would it if they
attorney to make that decision but but
these attorneys were good attorneys
thank you mr yan i have no further
questions
okay the uh
chairman klinger chairman hyde are not
here so we'll move on to the chairman
would it allow me in the rules if i
didn't use all my time to yield to one
of our members is that is that
we we if you do that we will then have
to use i just passed over two of our
members and no no no i don't mean extra
time i mean the remainder of my five
minutes
okay i mean just we're trying to be fair
but all right
we will we will try in the next round to
uh give mr uh miss
gene taylor's time thank you
chair now recognizes the full oversight
ranking minority member curtis collins
of illinois
mrs collins
thank you mr chairman
um
mr yan gun control opponents have made
the serious charges that four atf agents
killed in the raid were shot not by
david davidians but in fact by other atf
agents in what is called friendly fire
i'd like to ask you to describe the
evidence of exactly who shot the four
atf agents we we did a great deal of
research and work on that particular
matter ma'am because we figured the
friendly fire allegation would be one of
them in fact we found an instance in
which one of the wounded agents totally
removed from the deceased agents had in
fact probably been hit by one of his own
people during the course of the shooting
in that little room up there
every piece of particle or fragment that
was recovered from these uh deceased
agents was examined by our firearms
export and compared against the bullets
we took bullets off of every atf gun
that was out there whether they were
fired or not and compare them against
the fragments there was absolutely no
no comparison whatsoever that would
place it with atf moreover many of them
were killed by ak-47 uh fire and the
ak-47s were only uh handled by they are
head by the branch davidians that day
there were no no u.s ak-47s at mount
carmel
could you tell me what evidence you have
that david courage was actually abusing
children with the acquiescence of their
parents
uh
we had
a trial we had none we we were trying to
to introduce that evidence in the court
held that because koresh was dead
the probative value was outweighed by
the prejudice i understand there perhaps
will be the the best case we had may
testify at this hearing later on and i i
don't want to get in a position of
embarrassing a juvenile
by making some statement but we
the best we had i understand will be
testifying
well the nra and the committee
republican staff have attempted to x-ray
the 48 illegal weapons and apparently
they believe that some news tests
could prove that these were not illegal
weapons now could you describe the
methods that were used by the
prosecutions
to determine whether the weapons were in
fact illegal mr john we use special
agent james cattigan of the fbi and i
understand he's also scheduled to
testify he had to be one of the best
firearms experts i've ever dealt with i
think he had 12 to 15 years experience
what he did was go through the firearms
that were fortunate enough to be intact
and he disassembled them examined them
found out how they had been made he read
the literature we had the books that
they had purchased on how to convert
these weapons he examined the tools that
were used to uh to convert these weapons
and then he went back and made a
basically a firearm by firearm
examination of the superficial things
that he could see because these guns
were all burned and they were all
encrusted with ashes and everything else
so he could not disassemble him but he
went through and looked for the five or
six features that he found common on all
the working of automatic weapons that
were seized in mount carmel and that's
what he based his opinion on in fact he
was very conservative there were
probably some other weapons that that
someone else may have estimated to be
automatic but instead he limited himself
to the ones that he found all of those
particular portions before he made his
opinion and that was a total of 48.
i um mr chairman now the green light is
still on would i be permitted to yield
to mr uh to mister
oh okay i'll be glad to to yield to gene
what we did just so everybody
understands what we
we were trying no you're talking on my
time mr chairman
i'm going to try to give you something
if you want to accept it i'll accept it
okay this is this is really straight
stuff now um in the interest of being
fair we just had another huddle here uh
we missed our two chairmen weren't here
so they can't yield their time we went
back over and talked again mr schumer's
comment he does have a minute left that
he can yield you can take whatever what
you want to do with your time as well so
we're doing everything we can the best
of our ability to give you every every
edge we can possibly give you
yes first i want to thank you for that
fairness and second it would it be
permissible for my me at this point as
opposed to later to yield my additional
minute to mr taylor you can do anything
i yield my remaining time to mr taylor
as well thank you mr chairman
i want to
thank
my colleagues
mr revis i'm
somewhat shocked by your statements
implying in effect that mr crush was a
normal christian preacher
and that he was just going about his
normal business
uh as a gun dealer
do you know of any other christian
churches that buy and sell guns as a
business is this the
what billy graham or pat robinson or
even the pope of the catholic church
does
do you know of any other christian
religions that
compile a hit list as ms buns says in
her testimony of former cult members
that should be eliminated do you know of
any other christian religion that keeps
people for three months at a time
without their consent
again mr chairman as i said earlier i
don't think we can start on the day of
the raid i think we have to look at the
events that led up to the raid to get a
true picture of whether or not
the people who are paid by this
government to enforce the law the laws
that this congress passes
we're acting properly i'd like you to
answer that
uh i think you mischaracterized me
in the first place i don't know what a
normal christian preacher is
and i think if i did i'd have a lot of
denominations how about answering the
other specific questions okay but
secondly i don't how do you say i say
that david koresh was guilty of arms
violations insofar as i can see
and that he was guilty of statutory rape
and that there were grounds on which to
arrest him nothing i say in my book goes
contrary to that
all i was saying in my earlier testimony
was that he did not invent his religion
he inherited it
and changed it within a tradition he was
not a charles manson who cooked up a
religion
if i may does your book and i have not
had the opportunity to read it
you know i understand that the
presbyterians have something like a
parish council that chooses the new
preacher i'm a catholic the bishop sends
us our priests
tell us how mr koresh got rid of george
rodden
and if this is the normal routine within
the branch davidians for one preacher to
succeed another your time is up if you
if you could just kind of i mean that's
the question
before 1940 the davidian seventh-day
adventist association gracious
predecessors adopted a set of rules
which says god appoints our prophet
i'm not sure how you know who your
prophet is when god appoints him
but quresh's followers said god had
appointed him
and george rhoden's followers of which
there weren't many said george
had been appointed by god
and what happened ultimately was that
george didn't pay the back taxes on
mount carmel and david's followers did
so they took possession of mount carmel
now your references to a gun battle
that's correct uh where david and them
went to shoot a picture
at mount carmel and wound up in a
gunfight with george rhoden who was
wounded in the thumb
david and his people were tried all of
them but david were acquitted and the
jury hung in regards david is that the
normal procedure for that church for one
preacher to shoot at another
i know in that church no it had never
happened before and i don't guess it
would ever happen again time has expired
uh the
chair now recognizes the full judiciary
ranking member john conyers from
michigan
chairman
we've got a
some conflicting testimony here about
who
david koresh was
and
it's it's not at all clear to me
uh what kind of picture is emerging we
find that
uh conceitedly he's
probably committed crimes against minors
young girls
these violated gun laws
uh
we we have a
a
curious picture emerging here
and i'd just like to inquire of mr revis
who's been pretty helpful
um
did you state in your book
at page 122 that you thought that the
atf
was seeking to enforce unconstitutional
firearms laws
i think what you'll find in that chapter
of my book is that i found a scholar who
studied the constitutional history of
firearms laws and whose opinion is that
they may not be constitutional
i'm not a judge and i don't know i was
quite impressed to find out that that
argument could be made and thought
readers deserved a chance to to see it
well now that you've studied it and
written and promoted it what do you
think now
whether or not they're constitutional
aren't you worried about that yeah
whether they're constitutional
tell you what i mean is it autumn is it
is it okay for everybody to carry
automatic weapons
and uh and defend themselves on the
basis that they're unconstitutional
the law it's clearly not
thank you very much now did you state
that in your book anywhere did i state
what
what you just said
namely that that it is
not constitutional to carry automatic
weapons i said it was illegal yeah in
your book
sure here i just said well here i just
said well at page 120 i know what you
said
if the findings of these professors are
trustworthy the laws that the atf sought
to enforce at mount carmel on february
28th were unconstitutional
if the findings of these professors are
trustworthy that is a question to be
litigated in the courts
okay
page 293 the prosecution heaps of
evidence also included what appeared to
be
illegal homemade silences for rifles and
48 semi-automatic rifles that had been
converted to automatic fire
does that
concern you about being unconstitutional
that's a violation of law isn't it
that's certainly what i say
it's certainly what you say here
it's not what you said in the book no in
the book i was reviewing the work of a
professor who argues that these laws
aren't constant i get it i i understand
you've learned a lot since you wrote the
book that's what i'm i'm beginning to
understand
and uh i'm glad that we're kind of
getting this down
to some some little
finer points here i mean it's nice to
write a book
about what may or may not be
constitutional unconstitutional but yet
when you come here to testify
well there's no question now that you've
thought about it
this is not
so unconstitutional as as you would have
thought
just a moment i didn't i didn't i didn't
ask you a question there i was just
reviewing your your testimony mr han i'd
like to just invite you to tell us
a little bit about this warrant i mean
could there be any question about its
invalidity
about it sir uh
we looked it over there was there was a
lot of surplusage there's a lot of stuff
that perhaps should not have been in
there there's a lot of stuff that had
i've been the author i might not have uh
included in fact there were some that
was deleted before the final warrants
were served but i had no questions to
his validity and and the people that had
put it together were not newcomers to
this business they've been doing this
for quite a few years had they not
that's correct and i think you'll always
find
room for our lawyers to argue one way or
the other that's what they're paid for
and that's what they're trained to do
finally the dynamic entry question i
mean was there any way we could have
inspired if you could kind of just
finish let him respond
is there any way we could have avoided a
dynamic entry in this case you're asking
far beyond my capability sir that would
be something that i would have to defer
to the experts which would either be
the fbi hostage rescue swat type people
or the deas or the atf's we'll get to
them thank you very much mr revis did
you have a chance to respond to one of
mr kanye's questions i want to make sure
we're fair to everybody here
i hadn't asked him a question that he
didn't respond to i was making an
observation you agree
i do not agree okay
i don't agree with the witness
would you like to respond go ahead and
respond mr chairman j just a minute mr
chairman i'm just trying to be fair i i
want to be very fair but any questions
my witnesses don't answer i'll i'll get
to the bottom of it i don't need the
chairman to help me get the response
from questions i ask the witnesses thank
you very much and anybody else that
wants to ask him about it can do it on
their own time regularly according i
would just like to to ask my colleague
uh
in in the event if the witness was cut
off and didn't get a chance to respond i
just wanted to be fair and give the man
the chance to i was just pointing out to
you that he did not
fail to respond to any questions that i
asked i was satisfied with that
yes sir mr chairman i think it is
incumbent upon all of us to extend
courtesy to these witnesses and i don't
see what harm would result or ensue
if the gentleman were allowed to explain
perhaps a response he didn't get a
chance to do mr chairman since everybody
wants this question that i didn't answer
answered i'd be delighted to invite mr
revis to make any i thank my colleague
commissioner in the interest of fairness
and everything thank you very much
i think we have to distinguish between
illegality and constitutionality i'll
give you an example
one time i was convicted of vagrancy and
leading a profligate life in alabama
what i did was illegal
later it turned out that the law under
which i was convicted was ruled
unconstitutional
there's always that gap
you never know when a law is
constitutional you presume it is at the
point of arrest
things are afterwards tested
david koresh's possession of arms was
illegal
whether or not the arms laws are
constitutional will be at this point the
courts say they are tomorrow they may
say different because of the research i
cite in my book
thank you very much this completes the
first panel and i thank the witnesses
for coming
give thank you for your patience and all
of the votes and everything and uh we'll
look forward to uh
the next panel if they would move
forward thank you
i'll yield to bill mccollum
if i could i would thank the chairman
for the subcommittee on oversight for
yielding to me we are going to share
this podium today by pre-arranged
agreement
the committee will be in order and uh i
would like to by name introduce the
panel of the next group of witnesses who
are coming forward to be our testimony
for this this second round
the first witness is gerald goldstein mr
goldstein is president of the national
association of criminal defense lawyers
next to mr goldstein is robert de camp
president of the national district
attorney's association
the third witness
is henry mcmahon firearms dealer who did
business with david koresh the fourth
witness is david thibodeau who was a
resident at mount carmel throughout the
siege
the fifth witness is kerry jewell who
also was a resident at mount carmel
and our final witness on this panel is
louis barber a former lieutenant with
the mclennan county sheriff's office
now if each of you would stand i'm going
to have to swear you in at this point in
time according to our procedures you
raise your right hands
do you solemnly swear or affirm that the
testimony you're about to give will be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
please
the record will up you may be seated the
record will show that all answered in
the affirmative
at this point in time under the rules
that we've unanimously agreed to do in
this joint committee
i yield
15 minutes
to mr barr
mr barr thank you mr chairman
we have the
names in the proper locations there
well i think we do have a little uh
reversal let's see if we got it right
here
excuse me before we get before we get
before we get started is mr barber here
with us today did we miss him as a
witness
we asked him to come forward and
apparently he is not with us today is
that correct
well we apparently are missing mr barber
from this panel for whatever reason
who's the gentleman sitting there with
the gentleman sitting next to mr
thibodeaux and miss jewel uh tell us who
you are please sir
that's very good what happened to this
chairman i couldn't hear that mr uh
he is kerry's father would you turn the
microphone and put that in the record
please sir
my name is david
you need to turn it on there's a little
little flick right under there
to the forward there you go okay thank
you it's working now my name is david
jewell i'm kerry's father thank you very
much
apparently we are missing mr barber and
we don't have him here so if we get a
chance to bring him up on another panel
we will but
otherwise please mr barr proceed okay
uh thank you mr chairman
uh mr thibodeau if you could please uh
over here to your left
thank you appreciate your coming here uh
if you could please uh recount uh very
briefly
the extent of your
knowledge of the uh compound at mount
carmel how long were you there and in
what capacity please um i met correction
approximately 80 91
and um i had the opportunity after about
three or four months of getting to know
him and some of the people of going to
passover of 91 i believe it was
in waco
i was there for about two or three weeks
and then i went up north to maine
and then i went back to california where
david had a property there and i spent
some time there
i also had an apartment at the time and
i was between the two and then finally
they decided they were going to move
back to waco for a while
so i went with them at this point i was
becoming involved in the music
and uh the spiritual teachings and
decided to move
um i was there for some time and for the
next couple years was on and off between
california and
waco were you familiar with
mr koresha's
daily habits what he did
yeah
including on what occasions and under
what circumstances he would leave the
compound
um
pretty much i mean i lived with him on a
daily basis on and off i mean you know i
had certain things that i did i was
really concentrating on music and i
obviously would not be questioning him
when he would go to town and things but
there were times when you know i
would go various places with him
so i guess yes okay
was there any regularity uh to his uh
his leaving the compound did he leave
certain days certain days of the week
certain times or was it sporadic it was
sporadic i mean there would be times
when he would not leave at all when he
would just uh stand and give studies and
there would be other times when he would
leave
but it was
he he left frequently
would that include during the
uh two or three months prior to the raid
in february in other words uh during the
month of february and
january and then december of 1992 did he
leave the compound on uh
numerous occasions
right before the are you i'm sorry was
it two or three weeks before the raid or
two or three during the two or three
months before the the yes he did yes he
did okay do you recall or do you know
what was the
last time he left the compound i recall
that approximately two weeks before the
raid he was going through a period of
time where he wanted to get back into
health and back into shape
and so he would go out running and some
of the guys would go jogging with him
and he would go
up the driveway to where the doubly i
believe was the double e ranch road the
dirt road that was in front of the
building and he would jog directly in
front of the two houses that are across
the street one of course was the
surveillance house
all the way down to the stop sign maybe
about a mile or so i'm not really sure
what the measurements were and then back
and then usually you know some of the
guys that come on the property and you
know we do some jogging on the property
as well and i know
that he went to town
infrequently but still went to town on a
number of occasions
i guess one thing that i could try to
refer you to
is that i remember during the course of
the 51-day standoff
when um the fbi i believe was the fbi
initially said that he never left the
building you know we he never left we
couldn't possibly have gotten him i
remember the lego tribune herald
and some other
media came forward
because the number of people within the
community of waco had come forward
saying that they had seen him in their
places of business just days before the
raid i believe one was chelsea's bar and
grill
and that's the only one that really
stands out but i remember a couple of
businessmen from waco came forward
saying he was in my store just last week
or just the other day
when he would go jogging was this at
night or during the day during the day
would he make any effort to
hide the fact that he was leaving the
compound to go jogging no
when you when you go jogging with a
group of five or six guys i don't think
you can really conceal that okay
are you familiar mr thibodeau with the
affidavit in support of the
search warrant
uh in this in this case i i have read it
but i'm not that proficient with all the
technicalities in it
no i understand that but you have ready
you're generally familiar with it
generally very generally yes do you
recall it as being a rather lengthy
document
yes i do uh do you recall it as being a
document that had all sorts of stuff
just kind of thrown together in it yeah
it it's it's
to me it seemed to be kind of like a
a press report only in a legal document
i mean you know it talked about
obviously
um i mean from my understanding of the
law if you're going to go after someone
for what you consider to be illegal
activity that's what you would
concentrate on in a search and arrest
warrant and from my understanding is it
true you know they it went into the
wives and the different aspects that
have been covered today of
certain aspects of child abuse that's
trying to be proven so i i guess that
was kind of a regular i remember one
thing that kind of stood out and it only
stood out because it was pointed out to
me later is i believe if i'm correct it
talks about
an ak-47 having an upper and a lower
receiver
um i think anyone who's familiar with
that particular firearm knows that there
is no upper and lower receiver to an
ak-47 which would indicate that there
was a problem with the search warrant
specifically with that
one particular firearm
okay you saw i forget who was on the
other side uh make a big deal of holding
up a weapon a few moments ago
uh
actually i think i was outside i had to
go i had to leave
you missed quite a show uh there was a
you know a weapon uh held up uh uh
stating it was a machine gun or whatnot
which certainly raises questions about
what it's doing here
uh do you recall uh seeing seeing
machine guns
at the compound no i did see ak-47s and
i did see ar-15s and there were times
various times when different people
would go out and shoot on the firing
range there were times when people that
we knew from the community would come
out and fire at our firing range and you
know to me i'm from i'm from the east
i'm from up in maine and i was not
raised around firearms and
to me it was it wasn't i mean it wasn't
something that i was really into
but being there i did notice there was
kind of a different mentality i don't
know if it would be texas or whatnot but
it seemed like a lot of our neighbors
would come over you know
neighbors from in the community would
come over and and fire and it didn't
seem to be as big a thing as it did
where i was from so it became acceptable
okay
uh
is it possible that there that there
were machine guns there that you weren't
aware of
yes that's possible
there was also in this um rather lengthy
affidavit
discussion of a of a meth lab
uh which i believe
having been a prosecutor uh refers would
refer to methamphetamine which is a
controlled substance a mind-altering
drug
are you aware of any of any such uh
facility anywhere on the compound there
was absolutely no drugs at mount carmel
period other than alcohol once in a
great while
when it was when we worked particularly
hard and you know everyone feel that
they just needed to unwind but generally
anything like that was done there was a
sobriety there that was to be practiced
and anything that like that that was
done was on a very sporadic basis and
david crush was absolutely against drugs
david crush is actually possible that
there was a uh a laboratory a
manufacturing control that's when i was
there you hadn't known about
i've been all over that property and i
never saw anything that would even
that i would even think would be
i that's absolutely impossible okay
another one of the items that was
contained in the affidavit referred to
pineapple style hand grenades
those that i suppose you see in
magazines that people use for
paperweights uh uh have you seen those i
saw the casings for those but i didn't
see you know an actual grenade i mean i
see the casings yes
okay uh were these live grenades not to
my knowledge okay
i mean let me put it to you this way i
didn't i've never seen one exploded or
go off other than war movies and things
like that
but i just don't know
okay
do you know whether or not the compound
was ever visited by agents of the drug
enforcement administration investigating
allegations of a methamphetamine lab
no i don't um i know that there was some
activity that took place in 1987 a few
years before i was there
and it was revolving around with the
gentleman over here brought up the
george rhoden issue
and from what my understanding was and
this came from a couple different people
that that were within the community
there
was that when david came out on that
particular that particular incident that
was discussed earlier um he was shot at
by george rhoden and some of the guys
especially i think it was stan silva
and um and floyd houtman were shot at
and so
they were in an open field to protect
them to protect them david shot at
george hitting the tree in front of him
now what i found out later and again
this is
word of mouth was that there were things
that were found that could constitute
making a methamphetamine lab there was
certain chemicals and things that were
found
now the understanding that i have from a
couple different people with that was
that that was turned over to the
sheriff's department and when the whole
thing went to trial the evidence of any
methamphetamine somehow were not at the
trial they seemed to have disappeared
i don't know what all that means but
these are the stories that i heard from
a number of different people that were
around at that era of time
okay
would you uh
tell me what the the term mag bag
means if anything to you i knew mag bag
just to be a garage that was about two
to three miles away from where the
building was i know that there was a car
restoration company going there
two or three miles from the the living
quarters yes
that that's a rough estimate i'm pretty
bad with distances and numbers but it
was quite a ways
yeah yeah i why maybe not by texas yeah
by texas
exactly that's what i was thinking yes
it was quite i i it would have been a
long walk
and put it that way you know you
probably could have bike biked it in
about an hour okay and what what was the
mag bag
like i said it was a just a garage where
they restored cars custom camaros things
like this i know that peter hippsman and
michael schroeder were down there uh
pretty frequently they actually live
there and bob bob kendrick for a time
lived there as well and but it was peter
that did the majority of the work
actually painting and restoring the cars
and mike did the mechanical work okay
did the term refer to anything else as
far as you know for example a corporate
entity by that name
that's possible okay you're not aware of
that though no it's not my okay
uh mr goldstein if if i could ask you uh
if you have had the opportunity
to review the affidavit that i've been
taking a few moments here to
review with uh mr thibodeaux i have
um
thank you i
have uh could you please uh we've we've
heard testimony uh speculation earlier
about
its efficiency and whether or not it was
subject to a
successful challenge or not and
apparently it
it was withstood at least whatever
judicial scrutiny it was afforded
previously
what uh in your opinion uh as a as a
learned uh an attorney with with
experience in reviewing and i suppose
challenging
affidavits is your impression of this
affidavit
it like many other affidavits that
lawyers that practice in the criminal
courts from one
courthouse
to another across this country
is not
terribly atypical i will tell you that
it is chock full
of irrelevant highly inflammatory
material
that's not that unusual many of you are
good lawyers that's
what lawyers usually do is try and
convince somebody of something
it definitely has uh matters that fall
well beyond for example the
either expertise or jurisdiction of the
particular agency seeking the warrant
that is matters of child molestation
that obviously wouldn't blame anyone
that read it uh just like it probably
has the people that listen to this
hearing nevertheless they had little to
do with the underlying justification for
the entry
uh there are allegations that many of
these matters are misstated uh quite
frankly uh uh
one of the problems that we have is
quite if i could tell you gentlemen
anything about what we need to do is
that those of us who are in the trenches
trying these cases day in and day out
day out are gumming these law
enforcement agents to death we have been
deprived of any teeth
in the exclusionary rule in the
mechanism that we have the sole fourth
amendment protection that we have
uh to attempt to regulate these agencies
and efforts to uh dilute that protection
is frustrating any that's if you want to
know why nobody filed a motion to
suppress i would suggest that that
probably goes a long way for example
misstatements uh if there is an omission
critical omission that would have made a
difference to a magistrate if one of
these statements in the affidavit in
fact is an outright lie in order to get
a hearing in order to subpoena a single
witness in order to ask a single
question we've got to show by affidavit
or sworn testimony or otherwise that
there is a lie in the affidavit before
we even get a chance to have a hearing i
wish i had eight days of congressional
hearings on every warrant that i suspect
is
is flawed with misstatements uh i've
never had a suppression hearing that
lasted eight days much less this kind uh
of inquiry the fact that the warrant may
lack probable cause it's a pretty close
call this one might just might lack
probable cause but quite frankly to the
lawyers that were out there in the
trenches trying this case it didn't make
a hill of beans it wouldn't matter
because the good faith exception allows
the judge to admit evidence even though
the affidavit and the warrant totally
lack probable cause
that's where the problem and that's
where the solution can come not in
providing
more
authority to law enforcement uh not in
being concerned about this abuse on
today and yet passing measures that in
fact uh
apply the good faith exception that i
just described from lawrence and apply
it to warrantless searches senate bill 3
section 507 will do away with the
exclusionary rule altogether we'll have
no way of restricting uh and
discouraging officers from engaging in
these kinds of activities mr barr your
time is is up thank you mr chairman
before we proceed further i noticed mr
barber has joined us at the witness
table that you need to be sworn in mr
barber if you'd stand and raise your
right hand
do you uh solemnly swear affirm that the
testimony you're about to give will be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
let the record thank you may be seated
let the record reflect the witness
responded in the affirmative i now yield
15 minutes to miss fuhrman
thank you mr chairman
at this time i believe that all of you
have some testimony in front of you from
kerry jewell
i'm going to ask for part of my time for
her to have the opportunity to read in
to the record her particular testimony
and and then we can proceed from there
carrie welcome and thank you for being
here
you can begin
when my mother and i first joined david
koresh he was still vernon howell and
his group was living in a little
two-bedroom house in san bernardino
california i was five or six
we lived with a group off and on there
and in pomona california in palestine
and waco texas and in la verne
california
when we joined david was planning to
lead the group to israel to retake
jerusalem
he taught that there would be a big
battle between the forces of the world
and david and his people
the world would win and we would be
killed but we'd come back in a cloud and
smite the wicked and retake the world
the details would change as david
received more messages from god but
there was never a time when we didn't
expect to be killed by the feds who
david said were babylon
while we waited for this to happen we
built up an army for david so the battle
would be big one and all the world would
know the power of david and god
in the meantime david was very strict
about how we should live
he only spanked me twice though i knew
he spanked other people or had them
spanked he personally spanked me because
i was said i was going on a diet when i
was about eight years old he used the
big wooden boudoir they used for adults
not the wooden spoon they called little
helper
the second time david spanked me and the
other kids it involved getting candy
from vending machines against his
teachings
before spanking us that time he bought
an enormous lot of candy and made us eat
it until we were sick
it was common for david to sleep in a
bed with women and children sometimes i
fell asleep in his room after meeting or
maybe i'd fall asleep on his bed
watching mtv
i didn't even think about it because the
women and girls were all david's wives
or would be and many of the kids were
his too
even if he wasn't really our father we
were taught that he was our real father
i've slept together with him and my mom
and lisa ferris i've slept with him in
aisha garifus
aisha was older than i was she was
probably 13 when i was six or seven
she became one of david's wives when she
was 14 and had a baby for him
once she was pregnant i never saw her
she was kept hidden because she wasn't
an adult
david took me on a motorcycle trip with
some of the guys to mount baldy when i
was about seven
on that trip he took me for a ride down
a mountain ski trail on chairlift there
wasn't any snow but it seemed like we
could see the whole world
that was when david said to me
personally that one day i would be one
of his wives
we all knew about sex because david
talked about it a lot he made us watch
movies that showed sex and war like
platoon and hamburger hill over and over
again
i was scared by the rape scene but i
would have been more scared to try to
leave the room when he was there
we also watched miracle of life to see
how babies were born
david talked about having sex with his
sister-in-law michelle jones for the
first time she was young and scared
he said he got into bed with her and was
trying to pull down her underwear while
she was trying to keep it on he said her
heart was beating really fast he talked
about how he liked novelette sinclair
playing with his nipples and that janine
buns had the type of [ __ ] that really
held onto his dick those are completely
his words not mine
i was in the meeting at the white house
in california where he told judy snyder
to stand up and then ask the guys if any
of them lusted after her a few of them
nodded
he told her to pull her skirt up she
pulled it up a little way and he told
her to pull it higher he told her hire
several times before she got it up
enough
i hate to do that kyrie but we just
realized that your testimony has very
graphic material explicit material and
you have
very general audiences watching this and
i just think they should be warned about
that fact
it is testimony of record your father is
with you you've been asked by a member
of congress to read it but i think we
need to be aware that you have a very
wide television audience and this is not
in any way censored so i just is a fair
warning to the public generally i'll let
the time be added uh
if you
said your witness do you feel
comfortable
mr mr chairman uh i have actually
talked with kerry about this asking her
if she felt comfortable
and responding to this very same issue
that i might have raised here she does
she wants the story out there she feels
compelled to tell the story these are
the words and what she heard and saw
during the time that she was there i
agree that they are explicit but i think
that we also need to understand who we
were dealing with
i
excuse me i believe we have a witness
here of 14. i believe that it is this at
this point in time that the questions
have been asked and whatever and the
witness may proceed to give our
testimony i think we needed to put on
the record more for the home audience
than anybody else or whatever but
nonetheless you may proceed and i'll add
the additional minute or two that we've
taken up for this discussion kerry
please proceed thank you
he told her hire several times before
she got it up enough then he asked the
guys now do you lust after her lots of
them said yes loudly judy just seemed
shocked and embarrassed but like
everybody else she wanted to please
david
you couldn't really think about not
doing what he said
my mom and lisa and i went to texas for
passover in 1991. david took the three
of us to a motel there were two chairs
in the room one bed that we all slept in
my mom and lisa made soup in a crock pot
we were there for two or three days just
mostly hanging around the room david
preached to us i sat on the floor
playing with the shoelaces while he
talked
we watched ernest goes to camp the cops
came once and just sat outside after my
mom threw something in the trash they
checked the garbage
then they went away
my mom and lisa went to do a little
shopping i took a shower and then i was
brushing my hair sitting in the chair
and david took me told me to come and
sit down by him in the bed
i was wearing a long white t-shirt and
panties he kissed me and sat there
but then he laid me down he took his
penis and rubbed it on the outside of my
vagina while he was still kissing me
i had known this would happen sometimes
so i just laid there and sat stared at
the ceiling i didn't know how to kiss
him back anyway i was still kind of
freaked out
when he was finished he told me to go
take a shower
i walked to the bathroom with my panties
down around my ankles in the bathroom i
realized i was all wet and gooey on my
legs that freaked me out more i just
stayed in the shower for maybe an hour
when i came out david was in his jeans
and the bed was made he told me to come
here again
this time he read to me from the song of
solomon
i was 10 years old when this happened i
remember sitting in the gas station
wondering when it would do it again
i wasn't afraid but i was nervous
i knew i couldn't get pregnant because i
hadn't started having periods yet
this was soon before i left my mother
for what turned out to be the last time
i didn't tell her about what david had
done in the motel some time later she
asked
she said david's habit was to sleep with
one of his wives then leave them for a
long time i said yeah i know she said
what did he take you i just said yeah
she wasn't mad or anything
i asked my mom what would we do if we
ever left here she said we'll never
leave so i asked i never liked it there
but i wouldn't leave my mother so i
figured i'd be there with her till the
end
the end meant the great battle between
david and his people and the rest of the
world
we were always waiting for and preparing
for the feds to come in the people in
the group didn't have to train for war
but if they didn't choose you dave that
would ask them why not
dana okimoto and janet mcbean were in
nursing and janet said that maybe janine
who was also a nurse could could and
would provide cyanide so we could all
commit suicide if it came down to it it
was also accepted that the best way to
shoot yourself if necessary in this
battle with babylon was to put the gun
in your mouth back to the soft spot
above your throat before pulling the
trigger
when it was almost time for me to leave
michigan and go back home to my mom from
my last visit to michigan
as a davidian my dad told me he had a
court order for me to stay with him i
was shocked and scared
my mom and steve schneider were on the
phone to me telling me stuff like
remember little esther so i would remain
true to david she told me david had gone
had given beer to rachel sylvia who was
then 11 or 12.
soften her up my mom said i need to
hurry up and get back there i would lose
my place to rachel she told me it's time
to fight are you ready
[Music]
carrie thank you um
let me
ask you a couple of other
well let me give you a few minutes you
want to get a drink of water okay
could somebody give her a drink of water
please
uh
mr chairman since we have a vote going
on right now could it be a possibility
that we could go ahead and vote and let
her have some time and also be very
happy i'd be very happy to do that in
fact we'll add another minute or two
back to your time and give you thank you
ten minutes when you get back thank you
very much i inquire i thought the time
was up how much time is remaining well
she she has about eight minutes
remaining on her time the first clock
went up so there's about eight minutes
left on ms thurman's time at this point
in time apparently we have a second vote
after this this is the type of vote we
had previously we'll recess until five
minutes after the conclusion of the last
of this series of votes
this was the first day of waco hearings
before the house government oversight
and judiciary committees
we'll continue testimony in a moment but
first some program information
c-span saturday journal offers a look at
the morning newspaper headlines
interviews with journalists newsmakers
and legislators
as well as your comments and questions
and through july the c-span school bus
live from landmark sites around
washington dc
this saturday we visit the organization
of american states
saturday journal at 8 a.m eastern time
here's some of what's on our companion
network c-span 2.
the future of affirmative action
reaction to the president's speech today
at the national archives
right now remarks by members of the
congressional black caucus
that's followed by republican
congressman gary franks of connecticut
and republican senator phil graham of
texas
and then a briefing by house democratic
lawmakers including nita lowey of new
york and pat schroeder of colorado
and that's some of what can be seen
tonight on our companion network c-span
2.
we continue now with the waco
investigation
the first day of hearings before a house
joint subcommittee
sharing the hearing republican bill
zellath of new hampshire and republican
bill mccallum of florida
hey thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this joint hearing will come to order
when we took a recess we were in the
middle of mrs thurman's questioning
the sermon you have eight minutes left i
will turn the clock on it runs for five
of those eight and then we'll notify you
as you get your three minutes down
miss thurman
kerry
let me ask you a couple of questions now
dealing with some of the issues that
have surrounded this case
in february it's my understanding that
you were actually or went to waco um
actually before the february 28th is
that correct yeah
do you want to tell me what happened
when you talked to the was it the atf or
fbi that you actually talked to i don't
know would you like to just tell the
panel what happened while you were there
while i was there i went to a courthouse
the same courthouse that i was in when
george rhoden that whole thing with him
was going on it was that courthouse and
the only thing i really remember
talking with them that stands out in my
mind was uh they asked me about being
molested
and i told them everything that i told
you and
um
we
we my dad and i and the agent that was
with us drove around
um
like pretty much all of waco looking for
the hotel or motel that um i was
molested in
and we couldn't find it because i really
don't it was dark when we got there and
it was dark when we left so i really
didn't get a very good view of the
outside of the motel
but that was pretty much all that we did
when we were there okay
and then on february 28th when the raid
took place what did you tell your father
about what you thought might happen
there
i told him there was no way that anybody
was going to get out
they were
somehow they were all going to die
what makes you believe that
he taught it he told us from the
beginning
from the beginning
sometime we were all gonna die and i
didn't know when and i didn't know how
but i told my dad the day the raid
happened
none of us were getting or none of them
were going to get out
and then you went on donahue i
understand and i believe that was march
10th
and and were what kinds of questions
happened on there or
maybe what happened from there
they asked a lot about the star of david
that everyone wore they asked
what was the star david
it was just a
sign
that you were in the group i mean
that's all it was a lot of people there
have been a lot of rumors that it meant
that you were a wife and but the men
wore it too so
it couldn't have meant your wife i mean
but
it was just signifying that you believed
and that you were in it and
you know it wasn't anything really
about the wives because the men had them
so
um
donahue i
told
donahue and the audience that
that it was my beliefs that they were
going to commit suicide and
the cult expert that they had
told me i was
wrong and i told him
watch
and then carrie it's my understanding
that your father actually sent a letter
to president clinton and i believe it
was
march 28th
i believe have you had an opportunity to
to look at that letter
just briefly my dad wrote it
and in it it kind of based itself on the
situations that that i guess he and you
had talked about have you and your dad
had a lot of time to talk and converse
about what happened there
yeah
so that he kind of knew what was going
on it might be for our benefit if it's
okay if we just put that letter into the
record i'll be glad to
um have a copy of it i just responded
without objection this morning
um in that letter basically it talked
about um
the allegiance and the possibility of
them committing i guess suicide nobody
was going to get out of there but that
the government needed to do something at
this point or we could we could even
have a harder term kerry do you know
of any others
children of your age or maybe a little
older that were put into the same
situation that you were
michelle jones
um
aisha garefus
um
that karen doyle
there i i know there are more but this
is just like off the top of my head and
i can't
it's not coming to me and you had said
in your testimony that once i guess they
were pregnant they were removed from
the rest of the group is that not always
um actually aisha
was the only one that i
was around when she was pregnant so
because i don't know about michelle when
she had her babies
but when aisha was pregnant i never saw
her she was kept inside her house
do you know why
because it was passover and there were a
lot of people from all over coming
and
she didn't she wasn't supposed to be
seen pregnant because she was young
okay tell me about the suicide stuff a
little bit because you mentioned that at
the end about the cyanide and then and
the gun
how did you know about that i mean was
it taught to you did you just kind of
know it i mean
can you explain that maybe a little bit
to us
it wasn't taught
it was known i
ever since i was little i've been i've
had big ears and i like to learn i like
to observe
and
and i heard i i observed
and it was known i mean i just
didn't think up this stuff as a 14 year
old kid i have
you know
it was learned
not as your family yeah
i mean i found it interesting in talking
with you that you knew so many of the
the players in all of this when i talked
to you about the mailman mr jones i mean
you just kind of responded as if you
knew all about him
um
can you why do you think it's important
that you gave the testimony that you
gave today
these are your
i don't think it's right that
people are getting things out of this
that they shouldn't be
people
are hurting
and
they need to know the truth this is my
truth it might not be somebody else's
truth but this is what i saw and this is
what happened to me
people are getting too much out of this
that they don't deserve they have not
worked for any of it they don't
it's not for them
they're making too much out of this then
it should be
i i just thought people should know what
i saw
thank you carrie thank you
i'm through mr chairman well thank you
very much mr thurman you're right almost
on the money anyway without realizing it
i'm sure but thank you and thank you
carrie that was not an easy testimony
but we really do appreciate it
understand it and appreciate what you've
gone through it's very very difficult
mr schiff 15 minutes for you you're
right
thank you mr chairman before beginning
my questioning of this panel
i want to explain thank you i want to
explain before beginning my question to
this panel i'd like to explain what my
point of view is going to be in these
questions
um
david koresh has never been a hero to me
i think it's obvious that he broke laws
in my view if he had surrendered at some
point the greatest loss of life which
did occur may well not have occurred
but the difference between david koresh
and the department of alcohol tobacco
and firearms in the federal bureau of
investigation
is that david koresh was not working for
the federal government
in 1993 but the but the fbi and the atf
were all federal employees in 1993. now
the point is
that federal agencies like the federal
bureau of investigation and alcohol
tobacco and firearms have an
accountability to the government and to
the people at all times no matter what
kind of people that they are dealing
with so
in my judgment
mr koresha's personal practices however
despicable they obviously were have
nothing to do with a hearing on how the
department of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
handled a firearms violation case
and i want to say to kerry personally
that i that i'm very sorry that you were
not protected
from david koresh
i'm very sorry that you were not
protected during this hearing because it
could have been arranged that you
testify with no cameras going if we had
known what your testimony would have
been
but i can only say to you i'm very glad
you weren't in that compound uh in
february of 1993 and later when it
burned down
with that i'd like to ask a question of
mr mc
mcmahon if i may sir it is my
understanding
that you are a firearms dealer is that
right
could you tell briefly where that is and
for how long
well i started in a
guthrie's florida
right right at the scene though we're
talking about it
could you move the microphone up closer
please yes sir not able to hear you very
well thank you
for how long in waco texas i'm sorry two
and a half years
1991 to
1993. and you have a federal firearms
license i did yes sir at the time you
did yeah sure and did you do business
with uh david korish yes sure i did and
he purchase firearms from you yes sure
he did did you ever sell him any illegal
firearms illegal notion did he ever say
that he wanted illegal firearms
no sir did he ever say why he wanted
firearms in the first place
as an investment how can one use
firearms as an investment the guns that
he was buying would go up in value
no question
okay and do do you know other people who
do that
yeah sure it's not uncommon by itself
all right and um
uh did you have a visit specifically
from uh atf special agent aguilera uh in
june of 1992 uh related to mr kresh
uh july 92. live 1992. davey aguilera
and jimmy r skinner okay
and um
did
they they were investigating mr koresh
at that time is that right
that is apparent now it wasn't at that
time right
and uh but wasn't there a phone call
between you and mr koresh while the
special agent was there yes sir would
you briefly say what that conversation
was about
yeah sure
while atf was there
asking questions about david they were
asking questions
where did he get his money what's he
going to do with these guns why does he
need these guns that's these type of
questions and these aren't compliance
check questions and that's what he was
there to do is they asked compliant they
were there to do compliance
these aren't compliance check questions
and so i was concerned that i was going
to give them an answer that i shouldn't
so i called david up
and i told david they're here asking
these questions
and david said well if there's a problem
tell them to come out here and i said
well hang on i got this walked around
phone i walked back into my gun room
and there's davey aguilera sitting down
jimmy r spinner is spinning up to the
left
and i go i got
david koresh on the phone
and davey aguilera he goes he jumps up
and dog goes don't go don't go and i go
i i got him on the phone
and he goes
and so i looked at mr skinner and i said
uh
well do y'all need to go out there i
mean you know
he's still when you got a problem come
out there and he's going we do not need
to go out there at this time
so i looked at davey and i said
do you need to go out there there's
anything you need to ask you is there
anything you need to do
he said no
so i told dave that they did not need to
come out there and i hung up so the the
special agent was directly invited by
telephone to go out and see mr kresh
personally oh yes sir okay
all right let me turn to
mr goldstein and mr just champs
um there has already been substantial
discussion of the search warrant in this
case and if there's time i would like to
go back to that but before we do
i have a couple of other warrants that
were issued and warrants holding up
aren't as good a photo opportunity as an
ak-47 i know but they may be more
important to this case
there were also a warrant for arrest and
against mr david korish
a criminal complaint to go along with
that have you two gentlemen seen all
these documents mr goldstein
i am seeing the affidavits i have not
actually seen the warrant or the
complaint all right mr goldstein i have
been provided with a copy of the search
warrant i have not seen the affidavit
for the arrest warrant
well let me tell you the arrest warrant
says that uh it's arrest warrant to
united states of america versus vernon
way howell aka david koresh and it gives
the number of the western district of
texas
and it charges him with the following
crime and i'm reading now it charges him
with the
lawful possession of a destructive
device
have either of you ever heard of a crime
called the lawful possession of a
destructive device
i would suggest that would not be a
crime
[Music]
parliamentary inquiry here roman reigns
does a gentleman have a complete copy of
the um of the warrant because as far as
i know i do apparently he doesn't do so
if you two want to refer to it you can
but it's the gentleman's time i have a
copy that says
if
the letter n is there and it looks like
the u is not copied
so that it looks like it's unlawful
possession on the copy i have
that's fine
but other words there's a reading of
some of them that think this unlawful
possession is actually printed on that
all right well that's it parliamentary
obviously it meant to say unlawful
possession but let me go to the statute
number
it says in violation of 26 united states
code
section 5845
f
are either of you gentlemen familiar
with that particular section of the
united states code
i am not
i've read that statute all right are you
aware that that section does not create
a crime it creates a definition of a
destructive device
and the actual crime of possession of
that device illegally is 26 united
states code 5861 you are correct i
believe the citation is to the
definitional section of that statute
now my point is this assuming assuming i
don't have a miscopy
section there that i've read the section
of the code properly there
i'm making the point that isn't it
rather sloppy law enforcement work
to put the wrong section of a code into
a warrant for which somebody is about to
be arrested
uh mr goldstein either either one of you
first no question that sloppy uh i would
suggest that on day in and day out
courts
affirm
arrests of individuals
even though the citation to the code is
wrong
even in
convictions are even upheld when an
indictment contains the wrong side i
wasn't asking if it was legal i was
asking if it was sloppy certainly sloppy
all right mr des champs do you have well
i'd have to say that it's sloppy
although lots of times problems happen
with in transcription waves
secretaries and others and it happens
all the time as mr goldstein has said
well what i'm what i'm getting at is
i i that's the practically the first
document in this whole set of events and
i'm suggesting that that starting with
the documents and point by point
one can see that law enforcement uh at
various times uh uh may have been doing
a questionable job and i'd like to go
back to the search warrant
i would suggest that if they had spent
as much time worrying about the
warrant as they had been amassing
military type
equipment to
execute the warrant they probably would
have made those kinds of mistakes well
let's let's talk about the warrant a bit
because you didn't have time to complete
your statements when testifying before
uh starting with mr goldstein do you
have any specific observations of the
warrant that you think are substandard
i'm not raising the issue of is it
probable cause that's ultimately a legal
determination but is there anything that
you personally question
uh
in that warrant i think i have stated
that
uh there's a lot of surplus
there's a lot of inflammatory material
in the warrant that while it is terrible
to read just like it was terrible to
listen to has little to do with federal
law enforcement uh and it's certainly
outside of the scope of the jurisdiction
of the agency that was trying to get the
warrant i would point out let me stop
you right there and just emphasize that
there is some rather graphic sexual test
testimony in the affidavit for the
search warrant also yes there is but the
offense for which the search warrant is
being drafted is a firearms offense no
question and the atf wouldn't have any
jurisdiction to enforce uh the child
sexual laws or pornography laws or
deviate sexual activity laws in the
state of texas well you know mr john
said that if you arrested david korres
he was going to take dna samples for
some reason do you know for what federal
offense he was going to do that for as i
understood mr yon's testimony he said he
was going to turn that over to state
authorities but that's what i do know if
the state authorities asked for his
assistance i do not do you there's a
nice deputy sheriff sitting next to me
but i i've been asking all right let's
go back to the warrant then that's
something you've read
uh would you have some other specific
examples with respect to use of
informants uh currentness of the of the
information i'll let either of you pick
up wherever you where wherever you wish
on that i just want to stress
i'm not trying to make a a a legal
determination probable cause still
exists i'm trying to get at was do care
shown professionally in the drafting of
this document well let me respond to
that if i may congressman
the fact is officers who draw these
applications tend to put in more
information oftentimes than they
necessarily need to simply because they
want to make sure that they cover all
the bases and there isn't any doubt that
there are some irrelevant
prejudicial material in this application
but
i i think that it's
common for officers to put that in in
the hopes that they don't inadvertently
leave something out that they should
have put it better to have too much than
not enough how could sexual information
possibly if left out have anything to do
with the firearms charge it could it's
irrelevant even some of the firearms
information for example there's a quote
that's referred to at least at least
once i think twice
of of a child who was who had been
living in the compound who said
i hope to grow up because then i can
practice with long guns like adults
do either of you know of a federal
offense in practicing with long guns by
adults it's not just that it's
irrelevant it's inflammatory it was it
wasn't mistakenly put in there someone
intentionally put that in there in the
hopes that that would move a a judge the
person that issues the warrant the
problem we all have is that the state of
the law right now is that a judge will
take even if you had an outright lie
that you could prove that they had
perjured themselves on the affidavit the
judge would simply excise that out and
you'd redact it is what it's redaction
and that's the problem that defense
lawyers out there and citizens who want
to enforce these rights which are the
way that we actually protect ourselves
from unlawful government abuse all right
let me let me point out the the
affidavit did mention since it went into
child abuse
that a that a child case worker from the
state of texas human services department
went out to the compound um that person
was allowed in the compound wasn't
restrained or shot in any way was that
your understanding of the affidavit that
that is mine and i i would question
both uh
the resort to this kind of amassed
military-like force when it does appear
that there were a number of other
opportunities but this is hindsight and
second we have two things to start off
we have the fact that a texas government
official went out there and went out and
returned unmolested and we have at least
a telephone invitation directly to
alcohol tobacco and firearms to go out
and it does appear that david koresh had
been out
during that period of time and perhaps
could have been apprehended without this
although that doesn't relate to the
search of the premises right um speak
speaking further on that
was there anything in this affidavit for
the search warrant indicated that
exigent circumstances existed so that uh
there had to be a no knock entry did
either of you see that no but i can tell
you this much before
interesting enough justice thomas's
unanimous opinion wilson versus arkansas
you probably couldn't have found a
defense lawyer out there that would have
thought that the knock and announce
provisions of the uh fourth amendment
had any teeth in them
quite frankly there is nothing in there
you see them even try to argue exigent
circumstances
uh in the in this affidavit other than
the argument that
weaponry always presents some danger
there is nothing either addressed
specifically to action circumstances nor
is there a request for authorization to
enter without knocking an announcement
just to conclude then whenever there's
firearms there's potential danger right
mr goldstein in a search no question all
right but in every other search or most
other searches there's not uh dozens if
not a hundred militarily trained atf
agents staging the raid either right no
question it does appear that they did
not do much in the way of availing
themselves of less intrusive uh
opportunities and it looks like they
spent all of their time
amassing
military type equipment to engage in
this raid and perhaps even lied to state
and federal officers and officials to
obtain that equipment
thank you no further questions mr
chairman thank you very much mr chef mr
schumer you're recognized for 15 minutes
uh
thank you and i didn't intend to get off
on this mr goldstein where what military
type equipment were used in the raid
we're talking about i don't know of a
single
single instance the helicopters and
other uh uh
aircraft that would not normally be
assigned to the police department i
would suggest that they are not military
in the sense that they are unique to
military here's what concerns me and i'm
not the police the nypd i don't know out
in texas all have helicopters they don't
borrow them from the national guard what
is that what what does that have to do
with well because it goes to what we're
talking the callousness or the are the
concerns i think many of us have to
irregularity yeah other than helicopters
was there any other military equipment
used
if you're suggesting that
i'm just asking a yes or no question yes
i think that we don't need what was it
okay i think the
the military style but he said lots of
oh military style attire yes i think
that i have a construction i finish this
line of questioning i i uh that's fine
military style attire i think the ninja
masks the the black do you know is that
standard atf procedure i think it is
becoming more and more standard in not
only atf but law enforcement even down
to our local law enforcement it's one of
the things that i think defense lawyers
are concerned about i'm not interested
in your general views on what type of
attire police and atf ought to work i
think everything okay
that's enough i have a series of
questions here uh i just you hadn't read
the affidavit and yet you were
commenting on what happened there and
led to the led people to a conclusion
that was all sorts of military types of
things and now we find out it's the
typical atf uniforms and a helicopter my
question is now to mr barber
um and what i'd like to establish here
uh with you um uh lieutenant barber
and is uh that
the atf just didn't pick this place out
of the clear blue
um that
and first let me just uh introduce you
to the panel that you are a uh member of
the uh you were a member of the mclennan
county sheriff's office
uh at the uh during this time is that
correct yes that's correct okay when did
you first become aware
of the problems at the branch davidian
compound
the first notification i had had nothing
to if you can just pull the microphone
closer thank you the first notification
that our department got involved with
actually came through the immigration
naturalization service when was that
1990
and this had to do with the possibility
of
illegal aliens being out there having
overstayed their visas etc was there any
knowledge about the 1987 shootout
involving george rhoden with your
department oh yes
uh i was one of the arresting officers
that took
vernon and his people into custody that
day i see and and just in a thumbnail
sketch tell us what happened at that
shootout as best you know
i was the third vehicle to arrive
and uh
at that time they had everyone in
custody
and i was a weapons officer fire
department
i made the weapon safe cleared them
and the people were transported downtown
and then i conducted an inventory of the
weapons
and uh all the ammunition that they had
right and koresh in that was charged uh
with serious crimes i believe including
attempted murder yes i believe so and
ending the hung jury yes sir in his case
an acquittal on the other
correct okay now after that time did you
receive complaints about activities at
the branch davidian compound in
particular did you receive complaints
about automatic weapons
yes sir uh there were some people who
lived close by said that they thought
that they had heard automatic weapons
fire there
and wanted us to check on it and i said
well we can't post someone out there
and that's when neighbors complaining
and hearing automatic weapon fire
incidentally we had asked and in general
the process has been fair but we had
asked that that gentleman be a witness
and we're not allowed that witness why
i'm not sure
um the one who actually
heard the automatic weckman's buyer
because he was a neighbor of mr koresh
um
okay how about did you uh
did a ups agent talk to you about other
things that were delivered to the
compound could you tell us a little
about that uh first of all he talked to
our chief deputy uh captain dan wienberg
uh concerning the grenades that has been
telling us quite a bit what is what what
was this with grenades uh seems like a
box
of mark ii type pineapple grenades if
you will
the box had broken open somewhere in
shipment with ups
and that was reported to the captain
and he asked me if i had any knowledge
of it i said no he said well you're also
our bomb technician i want you to work
with uh ups on this
and uh
just see what they're doing with them so
ups came to you and said we've seen this
uh tell us if there's a problem yes sir
they came to the sheriff's department
did you were also aware of not only uh
shipments of these grenade cases which
we've heard the only possible use
is for paperweights uh from the other
side although i have never seen one used
as a paperweight my limited experience
um and hear about shipments of uh
materials that might be used in those
grenades to make them explosive
yes sir could you tell us a little about
that
one of the shipments uh consisted of
aluminum powder
aluminum powder often used in grenades
well no sir not necessarily it had to be
mixed with other compounds magnesium and
magnesium and potassium nitrate right
okay
um let me ask you this
why did you you were the one i presume
who called atf and asked them to get
involved is that correct the captain
called first and then i was put over as
liaison with atf okay so the captain of
the mclennan county sheriff's department
called atf yes sir atf just to
underscore did not come in on their own
they were called by local law
enforcement they were called in and
asked to come in
right do you often call atf on matters
uh in your county
when we determined the uh extent of the
shipments that were coming in from all
over the united states that was beyond
our capabilities did you regard this as
unusual and fairly serious and is that
why you called atf apprehensive you were
apprehensive and let me ask you this
question sir um
were were the people in waco worried
about the compound what was the general
talk in the community
at that time there was none
not that i'm aware of uh i don't live
too terribly far from the compound
and uh the people out there just said
well you know the people a little bit
different but that was it right so what
brought your apprehension were the
shipments of various weapons grenades
components in conjunction with the prior
occurrence in 1987 right and again
it was the local
government not the federal government
that called atf
to the problem atf did not originate
that's correct okay thank you very much
mr barber we appreciate you coming a
long way out here my next uh
bunch of uh questions now is uh to mr
ray
mr deschamps am i pronouncing your name
right pronounce it deshaw
deshawn
well
don't pronounce it you're from missoula
montana i'm from brooklyn
i apologize for the
for the uh discrepancy and pronunciation
but you are the president of the
national district attorney's association
as well as the d.a from missoula county
montana that's correct
okay
uh as a as a district attorney for
missoula county i presume you've
prepared or reviewed a large number of
warrant applications yes and thinking
about this i think i've prepared
probably five thousand arrest warrants
and a couple thousand search warrants
okay and have you reviewed the search
and arrest warrants uh as well as the
accompanying affidavits in this
situation
and let me ask you based on your many
years of experience the 5 000 warrants
uh that you have uh issued do you
believe there was the sufficient
probable cause for the magistrate in
this case magistrate green to have
issued the warrants to search the branch
davidian compound and to arrest david
absolutely explain absolutely this
wasn't a this wasn't one of those little
borderline cases despite the huge amount
of extraneous material and despite
certain erroneous materials sloppy
material as mr uh goldstein described it
in relation to uh
uh mr schiff's questioning is that
correct that's correct this was not a
borderline probable cause simply means
enough evidence to to persuade a neutral
and attached magistrate that the item
sought are probably there and i think
any reasonable person reading this
would say beyond any question the items
thought were probably there right now we
heard mr goldstein say that the
standards are probably too loose or
whatever else and i'm sure there would
be many more on my side who would
generally agree with that than on the
other side but the law the status of the
law would be quite clear that this would
be
uh that this would clearly be within the
ambit of the law this search warrant yes
no doubt about that no doubt at all okay
mr goldstein i just i want to continue
on this but my third point here is that
at the criminal trial of the branch
davidians who survived
some of the they had excellent attorneys
and they didn't even
pardon some of the best some of the best
you're familiar with people like jack
zimmerman dick degaran and tim evans i
grew up with them know them some of them
in the room as we speak well welcome
wherever you are um
and these are excellent attorneys first
right okay now i just wanted clear for
the record that at that trial which
would have been the logical place
to challenge
these warrants that there was no such
challenge
absolutely right i'm not asking you the
question mr goldstein you're the witness
from the other side i want to ask our
witness mr uh although you've been
pretty good for our side i don't deny
that uh
but in any case um
mr
i'm sorry deschamp
de champ
don't worry about it okay
yeah what's his first one
what's his first name
rob if i can call you robert you can
call me chuck
okay um
wouldn't you find it if there was some
colorable doubt and there were excellent
attorneys involved in the case wouldn't
you find it strange that they would not
bring this issue up at uh the initial
trial i would find it strange generally
speaking they were going to throw
everything but the kitchen sink in there
hoping that uh
if there's even a chance
that they've got to raise it to deserve
it for appeal right and so the fact that
these excellent outstanding attorneys in
in the words of mr goldstein who has
known some of them since he was a child
didn't bring this up would probably be
far more dispositive of what is a good
search warrant than you would think the
author of a book
or an expert on religion or a non-lawyer
would that be pretty good uh guess i
would say yes okay
um
and finally
and we'll hear more about that later but
again i won't just want to underscore to
everybody a huge issue is the warrants
now one final point
and that is
that it is undispute indisputable
that
some 48 illegal
automatic machine guns
you may not call them i noticed in the
dialogue mr barr didn't want to refer to
them as machine guns although an
automatic weapon can be but let's just
call them automatic weapons and grenades
were found there so it actually proved
miss robert that the
presumptions of mr aguilera
that the probable
cause that he sought
proved to be true in retrospect is that
right absolutely not way off the deep
end for sure no not just one weapon
found not just one hand grenade but many
many weapons and many many hand grenades
that's true and let me just ask you this
that the elements of the case
not only all the various i heard
somebody uh mr revis the learned
attorney
um
uh talk about well the hacksaw analogy
but you also had a history of violence
you also had neighbors who had heard
both
rapid automatic weapons fire including
somebody who's a former marine who knew
what automatic weapons fire was you had
a an apocalyptic theory plus a huge
amount of weapons that brought
uh lieutenant barber and the mclennan
sheriff's department to do the unusual
step of calling in the atf
all of that together seems a pretty good
case
i would think so in in in prospect and
in retrospect 48 weapons
many hand grenades were found
so
would you take that case i certainly
would yeah i mean
it seems to me
that
this issue there are some issues and
we'll get into some of those down the
road maybe open to some dispute
but i think
and it seems pretty clear to me that on
the issue of the warrant
both in reality 48 weapons many hand
grenades both
and in prospect
lots of various evidence it seems pretty
clear
that nobody did anything wrong at all
let alone in a conspiratorial way to get
somebody fair enough mr robert i i think
it's fair enough and i guess in view of
events of recent times yeah we had a we
had a couple hundred pounds of high
explosives in there that i think
couldn't hardly be ignored in fact
anything else i can think of situations
where if the prosecuting authority
whether it be atf mclann and sheriff or
anybody else had all this evidence and
didn't look for a warrant there'd be
outcries from everybody so
final question to you
robert
and that is
is it even if
even if
the warrant were illegally executed even
if atf could have found a better way to
do it
and we'll get into that on the next
panel so remember folks this is a search
warrant
you don't and just maybe robert you
could just corroborate this from your
experience when you want to search a
place you don't usually go serve
somebody or arrest them off the premises
since you don't want them to
don't want the place to have destroyed
the evidence you don't right isn't that
correct the proper procedure when you do
a search warrant is to serve it at the
place you're searching absolutely in
fact i think the law requires that you
leave it right
not when someone's jogging or getting
ice cream or visiting another place you
serve the place that's right and the
proper response of a citizen
no matter how angry at the federal
government no matter what religious
theory they might ascribe to
no matter how
sloppy
the search warrant is is what robert is
it to accept the warrant
accept it then challenge it in court
later and you agree with that mr
goldstein i presume
i would agree and i think there's a
reason why good lawyers would not
challenge this warrant okay and i would
say it certainly is not the correct
thing to do
is to either threaten or shoot
at those who seek to serve that warrant
is that correct that's correct in fact
it's highly illegal to do that thank you
robert thank you mr trump your time is
up and now we better our five minute
period of questioning uh on the right
side over here the first five minute
questionnaire is mr blute you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and i
want to thank all of the witnesses for
their testimony they've been here a long
time and we appreciate it and
i would like to uh get into something
with mr thibodeaux because i know it's
our understanding that you can't be here
later in the in the hearings to deal
with the actual day of the raid after
the 21st i can be here anytime you need
me well but if we're not going to be
here friday is that correct
yeah that's correct okay
well since you can't be here friday i
would like to get into the record if i
could because you're one of the
witnesses who was actually there
the day of the february raid were you
not yes you were there
could you
take some minutes in describing what
happened that day what you saw happen
starting in the morning
in the morning of that day i was in the
cafeteria area of the building and
eating breakfast
and
i
after breakfast i took a walk down the
hall
and i got down to the hall and david
koresh was sitting there with robert
rodriguez
uh who we know to be the undercover
agent now
robert rodriguez was sitting there
talking with dave and he had been over
quite a bit i would say on
eight or nine separate occasions
so i didn't really think too much about
this
now the the night before this the day
before this the lego tribune herald had
started to print the sinful messiah
series a seven part series
so obviously there was concern over that
and you know david
did kind of view that as the beginning
of the end but obviously we didn't know
how soon this was going to take place
um
just really quick if i may say david's
hope was still that the music would go
forward he wanted to get his message out
through the music and he was hoping that
this that if this were an undercover
agent he always gave the gentleman the
benefit of the doubt um he would see
where crush is coming from from another
side from the scriptural side and
perhaps
go to his superiors and try to talk to
them about this other aspect did you
have some sense that this person was an
undercover agent yourself yes i did you
had heard that in the compound
not so much heard it well wayne martin
was really suspicious and he had to he
he checked him out
uh the thing that was kind of the
giveaway for me i mean here are these
guys there's four or five of them living
over in a two-room apartment
uh you know they have forty thousand
dollar automobile serengeti sunglasses
rolex watches they're coming over
claiming to be college students
you know i guess the plot kind of
thickens when when they say that they're
going to tstc which is a technical
college you know you'd go for
maintenance things like that and i asked
robert at one point you know just
casually because i spoke to robert on a
number of occasions i said you know
robert what um what what classes are you
taking he said philosophy
and i basically thought that that was
pretty funny you know
but anyway wayne martin did i guess he
checked some license plates and found
that they were registered
to a dallas somewhere that was dallas
you houston i'm not sure exactly but the
story just really didn't check out
and you know wayne wayne martin was
really paranoid over it i remember him
like it was a common suspicion in the
compound that rodriguez was not what he
said he was yes from early on yes okay
david
continue on that day okay david's whole
attitude with that was well
you know even if he is working with the
government even he's with the national
guard it doesn't matter you know i have
a truth here that is being presented
it's going to be presented and hopefully
this person will will see something that
the other people from
you know not having the experience of
one-on-one with david you cannot see so
that was the hope
that day i saw them talking i didn't
think much of it and i went back
let me just speed you up to the time of
where were you when the raid began i was
in the cafeteria
i started to hear the helicopters coming
from the back of the building it's very
faint
koresh came down the stairs
my recollection is that koresh was not
armed there were some people around
quresh there was i would say quite a few
five or six
and there was a lot of doors slamming
throughout the building at this point it
just seemed like a lot of action was
taking place at once and david held his
hand up at this point there were people
coming in from
the other area of the building i wish i
have a diagram
but they were coming in from where the
um
where the dormitories were for the men
they came into the cafeteria david held
his hand up and he said okay they're
coming they're on their way
this was after the helicopter noise this
is we can hear the helicopter and it's
getting louder and louder he said when
did you first see the helicopter did you
see the helicopter i did not see the
helicopters personally
uh but they were very loud they were
very clear and and we've heard testimony
have to finish here but that the uh
helicopters came a significant period of
time before the raiding party is that
your sense of what happened my sense of
what happened from where i was after
david kresh made that statement he said
don't do anything stupid we want to talk
to these people we want to work it out
that's what we're all about here at
mount carmel and i'll never forget those
words because i was really scared and
when i heard that you know it was like
okay david's going to try to talk to him
maybe this can still be avoided he went
to the front door now from where i was
in the cafeteria it sounded to me like
the shots were emulating from the front
okay now i talked to rennes abraham
later and a couple of the other
survivors runners particularly testimony
was very strong i said you know reddit
this is considerably after hours later
maybe even a couple days later time
really was kind of like a tunnel vision
type thing but i talked to renaissance
said you know i said you know redness uh
what did you think of all that firing
just starting at the front door and rena
said it didn't i said what do you mean
he said i was outside
and i saw the helicopters coming in and
i saw fire coming from the helicopters
into the tower area and it initiated
with the helicopters firing i see you
didn't see that yourself no i did not
people there told you that on that day
yes and i said renaissance are you sure
because it didn't go with my experience
from what i heard it sounded to me like
the front door and he said i am positive
which indicates to me that it was
simultaneous that you had the group at
the front and the group at the back and
the only way that that could have
occurred is if it all occurred together
mr chairman i think this is very
important testimony mr thibodeau has a
statement outlining uh what he thinks
and what he saw happen on that day which
i think is very important that i hope we
can get into the record thank you
certainly any a written testimony mr
thibodeau would like to make will be
admitted to the record without objection
uh
yes mr jim are we dealing with hearsay
evidence here and i'm not an attorney
but when someone is using second-hand
testimony parliamentary inquiry is taken
we in court uh proceedings you might be
able to not have hearsay in it but in
congressional hearings hearsay is
admissible there is nothing that
prohibits that mr chairman to continue
my inquiry will the record
clearly indicate
that this is second hand testimony well
it obviously does you just me thank you
very much
mr scott
try it for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
um mr goldstein i want to get away from
the particulars of this case for a
second and go into some generalities
and ask you to explain how the um
in your written testimony you go into
the fourth amendment and i'd like you to
say for a
minute or so how the exclusionary rule
protects innocent people from police
misconduct
the exclusionary rule was is a
judicially crafted rule
that in effect
precludes from the introduction into
evidence
any items or evidence that was obtained
by the police illegally
i think the general citizenry out there
thinks that
liberal courts are unleashing violent
criminals on the citizenry to beat up on
them in actual fact less than one half
of one percent
of the citizens charged in this country
ever benefit from a motion to suppress
but the theory is that by excluding
illegally obtained evidence evidence
that law officers obtain in violation of
the supreme law of the land
that that will deter them from engaging
in that illegal conduct because they
won't want to go out and obtain evidence
illegally if they know they can't use it
the important the importance is that
while it only benefits one half of one
percent of those charged and many of
them may be innocent
everyone benefits from it because the
general
discouragement of illegal police
activity protects you and me and the
innocent citizens out there whose homes
are not intruded upon so it has a it
protects 100 percent
of the innocent citizens and only
benefits a small infinitesimal
percentage of those who may in fact be
guilty if you have an allegation of
police misconduct or illegal
activity on the part of the police and
obtaining evidence
prior to 1984 where in the leon case
what part of the judicial proceeding
would you argue the case that it was
that the evidence was illegally obtained
it would be in a pre-trial motion mr
scott
through a motion to suppress what's
interesting is uh
mr taylor's point out hearsay evidence
would be admissible at a suppression
hearing uh it wouldn't matter that there
wasn't probable cause uh because in fact
according to leon after 1984 the
officers before 1984 prior to that time
you would be in fact the
instances like this uh
these kinds of issues would be viable
prior to 1984.
after leon and the good faith exception
uh how has it how is your ability to
challenge police misconduct been
compromised
that's what i wanted to answer to mr
schumer no
good defense lawyer with his head
screwed on right is going to file a
motion to suppress where there's a
warrant simply because the officers are
entitled to rely upon the warrant even
if it's totally lacking in probable
cause and even if there's a lie because
in order to meet the standard of frank's
versus delaware which is a hard standard
to prove you're going to have to prove
in fact by sworn testimony that there's
a lie before you can even call a witness
before you'll get a hearing before you
can ask a single question so what what
i'm gonna ask is nobody wants to hear
this apparently is if we're gonna have
anything out of this hearing that's
going to regulate and control illegal
police practices what we need to do is
put some teeth back in the fourth
amendment and give the citizenry some
means of protecting themselves let me
get to the particulars of this case uh
robert
uh
if you could show now i think in this
case there's plenty of evidence to
support the uh the search you've got the
usps testimony you've got statements
from arms dealers what was what had gone
in got statements from neighbors you've
got plenty there but if you could show
that this warrant had been obtained by
irrelevant inflammatory and unreliable
evidence
what could a
innocent person
if we're going to discourage searches of
innocent people
how could any of the defendants in this
case have brought up a challenge to the
evidence
frankly i'm not sure that they
i i'm not sure that they well they could
have brought up a motion to suppress
they certainly could have asked for a
frank's hearing to show that there was
if if there are lies in there and i
don't see any but suppose there were
that would be their
one remedy they have i have to disagree
with mr goldstein it isn't an automatic
silver platter that you get the
judicially issued warrant if the officer
himself knows
there's plenty of recent case on this
point if the doctor knows it
but the searching officer didn't know
about all the irregularities how would
they be able to bring this up in a
hearing through through frank's hearing
to show that there were inappropriate
illegal uh
lies
falsehoods that led to the probable
cause which in order to get that you're
going to have to be able to demonstrate
that by sworn affidavit how do you get
that if you haven't been able to call or
ask a question about it
thank you mr chairman
god thank you mr bryant for five minutes
get the same extra minute mr chairman
before my five-minute starts i would ask
unanimous consent to submit an opening
statement to the record
it is granted without objection thank
you
as a former united states attorney i had
a very positive experience with law
enforcement in my area with atf and the
fbi
but i have uh some very grave concerns
about the environment that existed in
waco
in february of 1993 that apparently
compelled
this raid to occur
that day
and as such i wanted to ask just a few
questions and maybe bounce around a
little bit and tie up some loose ends
uh mr thibodeaux
are you familiar with a mark bro
yes uh does mr bro have any uh
physical impairment
yes uh he has a significant sight
impairment uh
my understanding is legally blind
okay
uh i bring up mr bro because as a part
of the basis for this search warrant the
agent
affirms under oath that he interviewed
mr bro in los angeles and that mr bro
indicated he
actually shot weapons and and performed
guard duty uh with a loaded weapon he
also used to tell stories about um
swimming for sharks and you know being
he used to tell some whoppers let me put
it that way according to steve schneider
and some of the other people that i used
to speak to about mr bros experience in
the past
you know nothing bad or you know just
that's he was a kind of a storyteller
yeah it was the impression i had thank
you
uh again as a as a former prosecutor i
don't mean to
concede and i certainly don't that mr
koresha's actions were proper in his
reaction uh to the service of the sworn
i think he had an obligation
to respond lawfully and challenged in
the courts i disagree totally with that
action but i as i said before i'm
concerned about other issues that from
the other side
mr mcmahon
mr kresh did go to gun shows and deal in
firearms and uh
grenades and paper weights and so forth
is that correct
i never seen any hand grenades but i
seen upper receivers knives
accessories magazines
i mean he had a you know he went to gun
shows and he advertised it i mean here's
one of his business cards i mean i'm
sure y'all seen all these
i'd like to put that in the record if i
could sure but when i say hand grenades
i mean empty shells that are used on
vest and are you familiar with that
practice of putting them on best or use
them as paper weights yes i am that's a
uh
i'm i'm really surprised that the
that uh mr schumer didn't say that
before i mean everybody's saying the
pull pin complaint department
you know pin number one
but uh
that is a common practice at gun shows
yes sir
uh deputy barbour i understand you're
retired now from the
county sheriff's office
yes so that's great uh and you were uh
familiar with the koresh people
uh to a degree yes and were you
consulted uh
by the atf before this raid occurred on
february 28 1993 yes i was uh were you
familiar with the fact that they were as
a part of the davidians out there
uh i what i understand be a number of
elderly people and a number of obviously
we know at least 20 children
did you know they were out there yes i
did
did you make this fact known to the atf
or did they already know that i feel
they already knew that
uh
let me ask you if i could are you
familiar at all with uh were you
familiar with the fact that mr karesh
was uh was dealing in guns at gun shows
i had not seen him at a gun show uh
there in waco i had seen paul potter
is it normally the practice of atf to
also monitor and attend these various
gun shows as just as a practice
i can't tell you what their practices
are
mr goldstein let me follow up i
understood before that you had expressed
an opinion that because of what you
perceive as the misapplication
of law to the facts of this case and and
the staleness and i don't think our
fellow prosecutor talked about the
stillness of this information
uh the age of it
and because of uh perhaps the lack of
credibility on some of these witnesses
who who talked to the agent that you had
some great concerns about the validity
of that search warrant
it is true mr brian i am concerned
anytime there's that kind of lapse of
time between the date of the information
and the date that the warren is actually
sought to be executed because i think
there's always a danger there that even
if it existed it won't be there when
they go
i was concerned could i cut you off just
a minute and ask one quick question back
to mr barbour do you know what occurred
in in february that that compelled the
atf to go in
that day on february the 28th even when
the element of surprise was was lost why
they had to go in at that time
no sir i do not i do know that the uh
raid as it's being referred to was
scheduled for the following monday
i was aware of that
and they moved it forward a week and
they moved it forward one day
okay right right sunday thank you
according to my list bizlocker and
you're next up for five minutes
thank you mr chairman uh first i'd like
to um
to thank kerry for being here today and
for
uh telling her how proud i am of her to
be here and speak up and it's not easy
for anybody even a grown-up to come and
testify and i think you're a
pretty special young lady and you're
doing something important for your
country
i
in reading and listening to you you know
that there were other
some other girls
your written statement mentions a little
esther that your mother had mentioned
and also rachel were you aware that
other little girls were being molested
by mr koresh
did you know about that
and
you probably don't know about this
although maybe you do and i'll ask a
question there was a doctor of perry who
i think we'll get into that later in the
panel
who in
march
contacted the fbi and talked about some
of the other little girls who had been
involved and had been abused by mr
caution they reported
to him information about wirings and
explosions and things of that nature did
you ever hear about
guns or weapons or explosions or did you
know anything about that
um
[Music]
yeah guns uh
i never saw any explosions
i remember one time i was in david's
room
above the kitchen this was before they
rebuilt the whole compound but it was
above the kitchen
and
he pulled out this gun that
had to have been
i don't know it was it was huge it was
huge i mean i of course was like eight
so it probably was a little bit bigger
but
it was huge
it the
just the bullets itself where it had to
bend like this big
with
nails that came like this on each side
of the bullet to keep it together
just like
yeah on a chain like
rows and rows of them and they were just
coiled up in his drawers
yeah like rambo
um it was
it was incredible it was just and he was
proud of it it was his toy it was his
little it was his new toy that he had
just gotten and he was showing it off
now in february you and your dad went
and spoke to
the
federal agents and what did you tell
them do you remember what you said to
them
i or maybe i misunderstood when you
answered karen thurman earlier
did you um in february go and speak to
the
federal agents either the fbi or etf do
you remember what you talked to about
about being molested
that's about what i remember
about the children there who the
children's father was
just
that it was mostly about the children
now
this is um
the the deputy sheriff said the first
call that they got
uh
had to do with the immigration service
do you know anything about marriages or
uh that could have been arranged by mr
korish to avoid the immigration law
arranged
can you tell us anything which names
well i don't know if we need names but
can you tell us what you knew and how
you knew it
like i said before i
listened
and remembered um
there i could name right now at least
five marriages that were arranged so
that people could stay in the country
all right at least five
now you uh thank god we're not in the
compound on the on the day of the raid
but you mentioned in your statement that
you were on the phone
uh frequently with your mom and she was
uh
pointing out that you would lose your
place to rachel and that sort of thing
the impression that you got from talking
to your mother and what you saw when
when you were available to see things
how does that jibe with the statement
that mr thibodeaux made that
gives a more
serene picture that things would be
settled uh peaceably what was your
impression of what was going to happen
and why did you think as you stated
earlier that it would end with no one
coming out and with suicides
because it was always
there was always some sort of
violence not inside the compound
but the whole time you were there you
were prepared to die the whole time one
time my mom picked me up from the
library i was probably nine and she said
are you ready to go and i said where and
she said to israel we're going to
jerusalem and i said
okay
i wasn't going to leave her
but she said okay i just wanted to see
if you were ready to go
and
you were always ready
for something
always had a little
scared something inside of you
finally uh there were the first panel of
witnesses talked about this the
whole issue is a matter of religious
freedom were you ever
given a religious rationale for
the molestation that was ongoing with
the little girls in the complex was
there a reason given
the only thing i remember was that he
would say
that
king david
from
the bible
would sleep with young virgins to keep
him warm
and something about psalms 45 i think it
was
something in there
justified all of what all of the
molestation i don't know there could
have been something else he found that
justified it but that was what i
remember
because thank you karen thank you for
your bravery thank you thank you your
time is up miss lofgren i note from the
minorities list that we had incorrectly
let you have that time at that moment
miss slaughter was supposed to get it
but i'm told we're going to correct that
because mr schumer is going to yield him
a slaughter in a minute but where we are
at the stage of these proceedings is the
time where we have the ranking members
and the chairman have their opportunity
to question or to yield to somebody for
asking questions and i'm going to take
my five minutes at this point in time
and then i will yield to mr schumer who
i guess will yield to the slaughter i
want to ask mr thibodeau a question you
were there the day of the raid and you
were there all the way through the fire
at the very end were you not yes sir can
you tell us anything about how the fire
began
here's a couple this is how i look at it
and i put this in the report okay
um
at around 12 o'clock after being cs gas
the entire day after having a black
leather jacket on seeing little white
spots all over it that were absorbed
into the jacket
finally
i heard someone yell from the upstairs
can i pre-requisite this for something
that happened at 10 30 that i think is
very important
at 10 30 that day i was listening to the
radio and our news report came on and
the news report was saying the branch
davidian compound in waco texas is being
assaulted and janet reno was okay to
tear gas plan due to the credit of the
fbi they have not fired back when the
davidians on the inside and return 80 to
200 gunshots against the cevs
all i want to say is i was in a fairly
central i mean i was in the chapel area
and i had heard shots fired accidentally
throughout the course of the 51 days and
you could hear them throughout the
building and i did not hear any shots
that morning fired
and
i was overwhelmed with with joy at this
point after being gassed that my that my
friends were not firing at these tanks
because obviously that
the fbi were saying if you fire us we're
going we're going we're going to fire
back and not just cs canisters or fair
rounds so i remember being overwhelmed
that my friends were not stupid enough
to fire at a tank because a 2-2-3 round
wasn't going to penetrate it anyway what
about the fire
okay what i was saying is to me that
appeared like a setup a setup for a
massacre and it greatly disturbed me at
that point i'd lost all hope at 12
o'clock someone yelled from the upstairs
that there was a fire
the front i could not get to the front
because of what the tanks had come in
the stairwell that i that was closest to
the front so i went to the stairwell in
the back
at this point and i have some pictures
available
the back of the gym was thoroughly
destroyed tank went in and actually
leveled the back of the gym area the the
if you're facing the gym the right half
of it so i went halfway up the stairwell
and i could see the door but i couldn't
get to it because there was this huge
beam in from in in front of me and
debris everywhere however david koresh's
room was on this side i could put my
elbow up on the floor of the second
story i climbed up took me quite some
time to climb over the debris without
getting cut i went to his room i went to
his room and then to an adjacent room
which was an office space i get in that
room
there was a catwalk that was leading
over the rafters of the church area
say from here to here which is the front
of the building this is the front of the
building
i walked to the front
and i got
we were still in the process of building
mount carmel i got to a blanket i opened
the blanket up a big gust of smoke came
at me when that dissipated i want to
stick my head inside there because i'm
thinking the kids i'm thinking serenity
c jones i was thinking of isaiah and
joseph some of these kids that i've come
to know and love getting them into the
bus an underground bus that was buried
because i was under the impression that
that was the plan
i get up there
i open it
after the smoke dissipates i go to stick
my head in and a wall of flame shoots
down the hallway in front of my face
down to the other end of the building it
was the loudest sound i've ever heard in
my life i'm a drummer
and it was very it was incredibly loud i
could not hear anything else other than
this flame well do you know how the fire
started do you had anybody tell you or
do you know personally how the fire
started no
was there any plan for the fire to be
started that you heard
you know we've heard tapes all right i
want to go to you very quickly mr barber
uh box of grenades that came from ups
those were dud grenades not live armed
ones is that not correct yes so they
were practice grenades uh
methamphetamine lab do you ever know
anything about a methamphetamine lab
about the compound
uh there was a rumor of one prior to
three or four years prior to this yes
this has been back in probably uh 87 but
not current with the raid or current
with the time mag argulia or the atf
we're going after these folks right no
all right i want to ask a question mr
mcmahon very briefly uh in the book that
mr rivas has written revis has written
he talks about you're having a
relationship with david koresh to sell
guns or through the compound to have a
have a
refitting of guns or putting together a
certain type of weapons that y'all have
made an arrangement or an accommodation
to sell them weapons over time
do you know anything about that do you
know what i'm talking about i think what
he's referring to is uh
there was this deal that we did i bought
the frames and he bought the upper
receivers
and david put them together and then i
turned around and sold them
there was a total of five or six guns
that i had sold that way was this an
ongoing arrangement or was this a
something that just happened once uh
and it didn't happen again it just
started when atf came and did a
compliance check and i explained to them
exactly what was going on and they said
they had a problem with the eight size
tax they said the excise tax had to be
paid and i'm going i don't know anything
about the state size tax
and
uh after they left
we uh stopped doing it we didn't do it
anymore i only saw those five or six
guns and i was only time
all right well i thank you for those
comments now i'm going to turn to mr
schumer i've had my five minutes i
gather you're going to yield yours to ms
slaughter but you get the privilege of
doing that
it's my pleasure to yield my five
minutes to my friend colleague and able
legislator miss slaughter of upstate new
york you're recognized for five minutes
thank you very much
uh are you married
no
are you involved in a personal
relationship or have you been with mr
karesh's sister-in-law michelle
the personal relationship that you're
referring to is i had a a large hand in
taking care of serenity c jones and her
other twin daughters you live together
no we did not live together lived in the
same building so yeah in a sense we live
together
uh is she the same michelle jones that
mr korres referred to as his favorite
wife and had she had been with him since
she was 12 years old i have no knowledge
of him referring to michelle as his
favorite wife and being since 12 years
old she has i believe three children yes
how old are they
three and the other ones were twins
approximately one are they children of
mr coraz yes
and he admitted that yes all right uh mr
tibro did you live at mount carmel yes i
did
uh and were you you were there then on
the day february 28th yes and the
testimony that we have indicates that
there was a 45 minute notice
that the atf was coming is that correct
well i believe that some people had
a majority of prior notice that there
was some kind of prior notice but not
everybody did my example of that would
be winston blake who was found with a
piece of french toast in his hand laying
on the ground well tell me who where did
this prior notice come from
prior i believe that it came from david
jones who was the mailman the david
jones the mailman told you that the atf
was coming in 45 minutes to serve a
search warrant he did not tell me
personally apparently he went up to the
front the foyer area where david was
with a group of people and told koresh
and you were there with mr koresh no i
was in the back i was in the cafeteria
area you were nowhere around mr koresh
at the time he was around the front door
i was not
um was mr jones a member of the branch
davidians
well
see again i always consider myself a
student of the seven seals branch
davidian is something that i really
heard in february 28th when the atf
rated so but mr jones was a member of
your group let me put it that way uh was
that known to authorities that mr jones
was a member of your group
i would think that it would be i mean
he's the mailman in the community and he
spends a lot of time out there he lived
out there for some time he did have a
private residence do you have any idea
where mr jones got his information that
the atf was coming to serve a search
warrant from what i have read and been
told is it was from the a news media
truck that was at the other end of the
property down at the end of the at the
end of the doubly ranch road i believe
it to be a news media truck told mr
jones if the atf was on its way that's
that's well the story that i heard and
you know i i this really got
david didn't really talk too much about
it to me personally but the story that i
got from the news media and i will say
that i take everything i hear from the
media with a grain of
i was salt to sleep on the kitchen floor
night after night without any food until
he was too weak to eat no i had not
heard anything about that and i really
doubt the validity of that story
and would you know anything about cyrus
at that point being taken to a garage in
pomona i believe and kept in a garage
overnight there are witnesses who say
they took him there he was told by his
father that there were huge rats in this
building and he was made to stay there
alone terrified and scared okay of
course
what you're referring to is the film
that came out i called no i haven't seen
any film there was a film these were
testimonies from from witnesses who
including a man who himself took young
cyrus at the age of three out to spend
overnight in a garage i came on i came
onto the scene in 1991.
i believe these things if they happened
at all happened prior to me coming onto
the scene but i have never heard any
talk about this occurring and when i
stopped this atf propaganda film ma'am
is it your testimony is mr t is it your
testimony mr tibido that he did not
spank children as young as eight months
until their bottoms bled no he did not
to the bottom's blood he did spank his
children when they were disobedient but
eight months old the mothers did i don't
know about eight-month-old children
being spanked mothers have testified to
that as you know kerry do you know
anything about that where babies packed
in that compound
little babies
did you know cyrus yep is what i said
about cyrus is that true that's your
recollection i don't know
how small were the babies when they were
spanked and did you ever see any of
those spankings
eight months old
and these babies were spanked with what
a wooden paddle called help her help her
and uh what reason would drive mr koresh
to spank an eight-month-old child
uh
i saw him spank i don't know if he was
eight months old at the time but i saw
him spank wisdom who was robin bunz's
son
countless amounts of times because
wisdom didn't like him and wisdom would
run away
and he would call him back over and
spank him and then wisdom would run away
again and he would call him over and
spank him again and then he would tell
robin to go spank him in wisdom he would
sit wisdom on his lap and wisdom would
be sniffling and crying and
then he'd run away again and get spanked
have you ever known of any occasion
where mr koresh defined uh kept a child
from having food answer that question
that your time is up it is but if you
would answer that for me do you know how
he if he punished by denying food for
more than one day or several days at a
time
i don't know about that no thank you
very much
mr zelloff for five minutes
uh carrie thank you for being here i
know it's been a long and difficult uh
day uh i just on the record you you were
invited um
as the
democratic minority
witness and uh it was you you asked to
be here by subpoena is that correct yeah
and you needed to subpoena because it
was needed so that your father could be
with you
very much
um
mr goldstein is it is it possible or
unprobable
cause is it
is it possible that that it becomes
stale and is a stale if it's six or
seven months old
and would a warrant be valid if
probable cause was still
there are very few cases that actually
deal with the issue of staleness uh but
there is a lot of rhetoric a lot of
dicta in cases that suggest that
staleness is certainly relevant to
probable cause and it goes to whether or
not you would have a reasonable belief
that whatever you have that causes you
to believe items of evidence will be
located at a particular situation will
still be there when you attempt to
obtain the warrant and execute it
thank you
the warrant authorized the search of the
entire premises of the 77-acre compound
all buildings were included in the scope
of the search
this included all personal belongings of
some 90 men women and children besides
the person named in the search warrant
given the crimes alleged to have
occurred is the warrant so over brought
as to be unconstitutional there are
always those concerns and i think this
is one of the one if there's something
healthy that comes out of these hearings
it would be that a an evaluation of what
we expect goes on during motions to
suppress in criminal trials is not in
fact what does uh the truth of the
matter is that a warrant should be if
the fourth amendment talks about a
particular item in a particularized
place one would want particularity it
would keep them for example where people
were living for example in a college
dormitory from searching the entire
building because of probable cause to
believe one errant student had violated
the law on the other hand i can tell you
this from common experience and i think
you could talk to prosecutors and
defense lawyers who would agree with me
the idea that we will
prevail on motions to suppress because
the probable cause is stale or because
the warrant is too broad because it
allows the search of an entire building
where
the distinction between rooms and
residences is difficult uh to pinpoint
is foolhardy quite frankly that's one of
the reasons why none of these good
lawyers raised the issue
it's simply in practice we don't have
any teeth in terms of being able to
enforce these kinds of restrictions that
i think as your question points out are
needed we need to restrict law
enforcement in terms of time we need to
restrict them in terms of place that's
not asking too much and they're able to
enforce the laws i think adequately with
those guns thank you mr goldstein mr
tibito tell us about finding winston
blake
dead when
the raid initially occurred and the
shooting started
i got down on the ground i went into the
dorm area i had mentioned earlier which
i had a diagram to show you
but i went down the hallway
of the dorm to uh
the end
actually the first room i went into was
the weight room and i waited there for i
would say between five and ten minutes
time is pretty irrelevant when you're
being shot at
then uh jimmy riddle and oliver garfis
jr ran down the hall in front of me they
went to the underground bus area they
opened up the door and they went down
into it and that's when i followed suit
behind them
i got downstairs
and uh oliver garfield jr myself and
jimmy riddle were down there
jimmy went down the hallway into the
tornado shelter that was being built he
started to walk around in the mud and
the agents could hear him from upstairs
and they were yelling obscenities at him
telling him to come out screaming at the
top they're at the top of their lungs
obscenities i think that jimmy wanted to
make sure they weren't going to come in
and and take us out that way
anyway to make a long story short
after a period of
i would say
20 30 minutes
the we went back upstairs just as the
ceasefire was being established jimmy
riddle and oliver garfish jr ran up the
hallway i was crawling still because
there was some sporadic fire i came to
the first room that was to my left and
water was pouring out of the bottom of
this room and again there was no door on
there there was a blanket on there i
opened up the blanket and i looked in
and it was the area of the building
where there's three water tanks on the
outside
the middle water tank had been punctured
a number of times as well as the glass
the first thing i focused on was the
glass that was shot out my eyes were
still adjusting from being in a dark
place
i noticed the water pouring out of the
bullet holes onto the floor i followed
one of the streams down and there was
there was a body there
i couldn't tell who it was at first
after a period of time my eyes focused
on the body and i could see that it was
a large lump i made it out to be winston
blake i remember he had a red jacket on
and it was winston and the water was
pouring down onto him and there was a
there was a pile of blood by his head he
was not moving i pretty much knew that
winston was dead and was not going to
move i shut the curtain i went up the
hallway trying to hold my breakfast in
that morning last question mr thibodeaux
on this uh
this this is a hanger now this is this
happens to be a paper weight
uh is this similar to some of the things
that you may have seen inside this this
little paper weight here this hand
grenade
yeah it looks similar as is it possible
that this hand grenade could be a
paperweight
yeah it is possible okay i say that in
the extent that if you put a sign on
there that says complete department pull
pin then then obviously it's a
paperweight it depends on what is inside
the handle
this this paper was positive it could
have been active is not a hand grenade
or used for the intended purpose of a
hand grenade
no it's possible either way sir that
this this could be a paper weight that
is not dangerous it's just used to hold
papers down yes mr zell if you're your
time thank you very much
uh mrs thurman
thank you mr chairman at this time i
would like to uh
yield my time to the distinguished
gentleman from mississippi mr taylor
mr jewel like some other
members of this body i was
a bit disturbed by some of the graphic
things your daughter had to say
but having said that
i think it is also very fair that you be
given an opportunity to tell this body
about your experiences in going to court
in michigan
to prevent your daughter from being held
in custody
by david koresh the events that again
why don't you tell this committee some
of the things that you know that were
going on that the michigan court agreed
with
when they decided to keep your daughter
from ever being in the presence of david
koresh
i wasn't expecting to speak today so
this catches me a bit off guard
i don't believe that he's been sworn in
but i'd be very glad to do that mr
taylor i won't do it on your time if
you'd noting mine if you'd raise your
right hand please do you solemnly swear
or affirm that the testimony you're
about to give will be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth i
do then uh the record will reflect the
answer was affirmative it may be seated
mr taylor you still have four
three-quarters minutes or something like
that
in the process
parliamentary inquiry please statement
will other people be added without
notice
and can other people bring in witnesses
normally that would not be the case but
i believe under these circumstances with
the father of the young woman here it is
extraordinary i just like to know that
no not normally we would not we've got a
schedule we prep them we publish them
it's a good a good inquiry but you're
correct mr chairman yes i mean mr joel i
hate to to interrupt
but the point i'm trying to make is the
same point i made at the beginning of
this hearing
i think if you operate in a vacuum
leading to the date of february 28th
you can jump to the wrong conclusion as
to what the role of this nation and
those people hired by this nation to
enforce this nation's laws have taken
place
do you who are the most familiar
with what happened to your daughter and
what you tried to prevent from
continuing to happen to your daughter
don't you think that this body needs to
know what went on at that compound prior
to february 28th absolutely sir
this may turn into mr barber as a local
law enforcement agent who turned and
asked the atf to augment the efforts of
your agency
do you feel like the law was being
broken on a regular basis at that
compound
prior to your calling in the atf to help
out your agency
we had a lot of accusations and
suspicions but we did not have probable
cause on anything at that time
then mr ballroom may ask why did you
contact the atf
my primary concern was hand grenades
okay mr jewel if i may return to you
would you please inform this committee
of some of the things that you brought
to the michigan court's attention when
that court ruled that your daughter
could no longer be brought in the
presence of david koresh
honor about the morning of halloween in
uh
i believe it was 1991.
and again i'm speaking somewhat
impromptu here so my dates may be
somewhat shuffled but
i received a call very early in the
morning and it was from mr mark bro
whose name was raised earlier
he identified himself to me and he said
mr jewell i have
nothing i can give you that would make
you have a reason to believe me
but i hope you will he said do you know
a sherry jewel because he wasn't even
sure that he had contacted the right
person
i said yes he's my former wife and your
daughter is kiri i said yes he said sir
i
i have reason to believe that your
daughter is in danger
and at that point he had my full
attention
and he began
to tell me
about the fact that he was a former
member and that he in fact had been
placed fairly highly in the hierarchy of
david koresh's organization he began to
tell me who david koresh was and what he
was and
what he was intending to do not just
with my daughter i learned at that point
that david koresh intended to take my
then
nine-year-old daughter as his
maybe ten-year-old daughter as his wife
but that he also had plans to
destroy the earth and i must say that i
feel a little uneasy using that phrase
in the
chambers of the united states congress
because it seems so preposterous
but if you believe it
it's not preposterous
the david koresh that i came to know of
and who i spoke with twice on the
telephone
was a man of absolutely unparalleled
evil intent
it was his plan
to bring about any circumstances
necessary
that would
start a war between he and his followers
and the rest of the world
over a period of years prior to my
conversation with david
with mark bro excuse me
i
had had
information that would come to me slowly
and in little bits and pieces from
from my former wife sherry jewell who
died in that fire and from my daughter
about
what it was they were studying and what
they believed and the things that were
going to happen and i heard about
wars that they were going to be involved
in that would
would cause literal rivers of blood
and i heard about
friends supposedly
being told
that if they didn't come and join the
group
that they would be killed
i have sworn affidavits in in the
possession of my attorney
that refer to the remarks that mrs
slaughter was making earlier about
babies being beaten at the age of eight
months old until their buttocks bled and
i don't refer to one affidavit i refer
to several
i have testimony about women being held
captive for months at a time
and being
systematically raped and demoralized to
the point
where
they would then consent to the will of
david koresh and or his henchmen
david koresh
perhaps
truly believed that he was the
incarnation of some deity or some power
but it was not heavenly
mr taylor your your time has expired mr
chairman if i may
i have two requests that i think are
very pertinent
number one since mr jewell's time was
very limited i would request that the
testimony involved in the trial in
michigan
where he sought custody of his child and
to prevent his child from falling into
the hands of david creche that be
included in this testimony
for the sake of brevity if you can make
it uh provided it will be done without
objection secondly mr chairman i have an
opening statement
that i would like to include in
direction without objection it's so
included mr hyde you are recognized for
five minutes
i thank you and i'm pleased to yield my
five minutes to mr schiff
i thank the chairman of the committee
for yielding
i'd like to take a moment uh
mr chairman to put in focus
a couple of important issues here first
of all
just as
the alcohol tobacco and firearms
investigation and raid never involved mr
koresh's personal practices however
outrageous they were
with with girls the age of kerry jewel
they never involved an allegation of
child abuse in spanking young infants
which of course would be equally
outrageous if in fact it occurred
the alcohol tobacco and firearms search
warrant and arrest warrant
dealt exclusively with firearms
violations
and i would ask my colleagues who are
listening and here today
to decide if the other information that
is constantly dumped into the middle of
this hearing is relevant to the issues
we must ultimately arrive at here
second of all i'd like to focus on the
search warrant i'm not going to ask
further academic questions about the
search warrant
but i want to make the point that i
think it's relevancy to this hearing has
been missed
in my mind its relevancy to this hearing
is not whether it legally established
probable cause i think it's possible
that it did
but i think there are other aspects of
the search warrant which are which are
more relevant to what we're studying
today which is the activities of federal
law enforcement agencies in this
situation
and those other aspects were our first
it was put together as a number of
witnesses have testified in a
prejudicial and inflammatory manner
and second
by the fact that no matter whose copy of
the name of the offense is correct it
clearly misstates the u.s code statute
number for the offense charged and i
think makes other technical mistakes in
the law which means to me it was put
together in a sloppy fashion now you put
together inflammatory with sloppy that
translates to me
that that atf was in a hurry to make a
big splash with something
and i think that if that's true and we
have seven and a half more days to
determine that i think if that's true
uh that is substandard performance and
we'll hear from them and they'll have a
chance to explain now with that i'd like
to use the balance of my five five
minutes to ask a few further questions
uh deputy barber during the course of
this uh investigation i assume you met a
number of atf personnel that's correct
did did you meet any of their public
relations people who came to the scene
before the raid
uh yes i believe
one um
i think her first name was sharon
wheeler right you know that she's in po
i believe she's in public relations for
atf
yes i knew that and you know and they
brought her there before the raid
i believe
i met her the day of the raid
day of the day of yes you know when she
arrived no i don't all right
um let me turn now to uh mr mcmahon mr
mcmahon when you did business with mr
koresh
in firearms where did you do business
i sold him some guns from my home i my
licensed premise was my home from your
your license premises was your home yes
and you didn't live on the branch
davidian compound no sure so he came to
your home sometimes and sometimes i'd go
out there and see him but he'd be
willing to come to your home sure did he
come to your home regularly
i mean maybe once to every three or four
months or so but okay
um let me turn to mr thibodeau uh mr
thibodeau um
um at the time the the raid first took
place february 28th the atf is arriving
uh mr koresh knew the atf before that mr
koresh knew the atf was coming
in your opinion before
well did did mr korish know the raid was
going to occur before it occurred i
think that when david jones came in with
that information yes he knew and how
long was that before the raid
um i'm not really sure it's been said 45
minutes
all right and david jones was a mailman
who belonged to the branch davidian sect
yeah he he lived there off and on he had
a property outside but he was frequently
coming his whole family was there do you
know where he got the information from
as i said uh previously it was it
appeared to be from a news truck that
was at the end of the and this is from
what i heard in the press a news truck
that was at the end of the uh
the um the road and they were asking
directions is this so we anywhere near
the branch davidian
compound or the house or whatever i
don't know what they said to him i i
know you're not directly the witness
here but as far as you know
mr uh jones was asked for directions to
the branch davidian compound from a news
truck
no the news truck was asking him yeah i
think he pulled over seeing the news
truck and said hey you know what's going
on and being a mailman they
automatically assumed oh this guy's all
right well you know we're looking for
the maybe you could help us i believe it
was that kind of thing could you tell us
where the branch davidian do you know
who told the news truck that there was
something that was going to be
newsworthy happening there very soon
i i don't know for certain it would
sound to me like that would be the atf
and since you won't be here for the
testimony about the raid one last
question from the best of your
recollection would you say again
from which direction uh front back
up or down do you believe the first
shots were fired from i personally
believe
from the front but it didn't take long
after the front began to the back so i
would think it was pretty close to
simultaneously and may i make a
statement please okay brief because i'm
okay in the past i've been we've all
been put through the ringer on this
whole thing okay and time and time again
i've seen things like the donny who
shows and some of these shows and it's
never a fair form and i kind of feel
cheated here today because i have some
specific things that i'd like to address
a lot of these points that were made can
be addressed in counterpoints and i've
not been allowed to give that testimony
and i don't think anybody else any other
survivors have been allowed yet and i
really truly hope we have that
opportunity to to address some of these
points that have been made are you able
to return to this hearing at some point
mr tiffany yes i am absolutely i'd i'd
let you work that out with the chairman
then you'll be able to your time is up
mr ship and we may be able to give you
some of that opportunity here the panel
is uh going to be recessed because we
have a vote uh we are going to take a
recess this joint committee mr conyers
will have his five minutes next if mr
klinger comes back his uh perhaps
between the two of them there will be
that opportunity if there's not
then we'll have to or mrs collins might
come back if not why we will have to
find another alternative thank you very
much we'll be in recess until after this
vote
you're watching the first day of waco
hearings before the house joint
oversight and judiciary committee
we'll return in a moment but first some
program information
our companion network c-span 2 welcomes
over 3 800 new subscribers at tci cable
in boine city michigan
tci joins cable companies all across the
country adding cspan 2 to their systems
our companion network's public affairs
programs and live coverage of the us
senate can now be viewed by 39 million
cable television subscribers
thursday morning live at seven eastern
time our washington journal
the c-span school bus will be at the
pentagon
guests for our newspaper roundtable
republican congresswoman tilly fowler
and democratic representative ike
skelton
live thursday morning here on c-span
c-span a public service created by
america's cable television companies
[Music]
we continue now with the waco
investigation
the first day of hearings before a house
joint subcommittee
chairing the hearing republican bill
zelif of new hampshire and republican
bill mccullum of florida
[Music]
the subcommittee is called order
we have
just a couple more questions of some
witness a couple more questioners who
are here we really have three more
one chairman and two ranking members of
chairman of the full oversight committee
i was prepared to go to mr conyers and i
will uh next but
miss collins has agreed and i think mr
conyers if you would mr barber has to
run out i don't know if either of you
have questions of mr barber
but he's got to catch a plane
uh mr i have a question mr klinger is
going to yield to me to ask
out of a comedy to this uh if you don't
you don't have any questions mr barber
no i know nobody does and i would ask
with your with unanimous consent then
that mr klinger could have some portion
a minute of his time to yield to me and
i'll ask mr bartlett he's delighted to
yield to the chairman thank you very
much mr barber i just want to clarify
something completely for the record i
ask you some questions and then some
more were followed up at the end uh here
by some other people today about the
grenades and about drug labs and all of
that
my understanding is that from your
testimony that the reason you primarily
turned over maybe the only reason i
think you said you turned over the case
or called up atf was because of these
grenades that the ups folks had had
gotten or found or whatever in the mail
system is that correct i just want to
corroborate that it was a combination of
the grenade bodies and the explosives
materials that they were receiving but
the bottom line is those grenade bodies
as i understand it were bodies they
there was some evidence there were other
material there but the bodies themselves
were not live grenades is that correct
they were not live grenades uh the first
time i saw them no what other material
were you concerned about besides the
grenades besides these grenade bodies we
call it it was the potassium nitrate and
the powdered metals now where had you
been aware of those from what was your
source for that information graduating
from the bomb technician school at
regular no no i mean how did you know
they were getting that stuff
uh that was also uh obtained from ups
that material was obtained from the ups
the documentation was but you didn't
have any of the you had some of the
grenade
bodies but you didn't have any of the
chemicals i did not have any of those
yeah you're just listening to ups fellas
talk about delivering stuff out there
and i would actually get a copy of the
receipt okay
last question and again just to clarify
it you told me earlier that several
years before the raid there was some
evidence of a methamphetamine lab but
there was nothing current at that time
there was no
current evidence within the last year or
so to your knowledge of any other drug
activity
production of drugs or any of that sort
of thing on the compound problem was
there a proper was there no sir not to
my knowledge all right i don't have any
other questions into mr barber and if uh
i'm going to
yield back to mr klinger to reserve the
balance of his time which i think is
three and a half minutes at this point
and um i would yield then to mr conyers
is ready for his five minutes to uh to
mr conyers mr barbara you're excused
hope you catch your plane
thank you very much for coming and being
with us
mr conyers
thank you mr chairman
and i uh compliment you as i have
about the fairness in which you
conducted the hearing and mr zimmer as
well
and i'm hoping that uh we can resolve
the outstanding question of the
subpoenas
uh this evening after we've concluded
our activity
um
let me just ask
mr
thibodeaux
uh a yes or no answer as to whether
uh the nra or anyone
on its behalf has connect has contacted
you in connection with this hearing
no in any way not in arena all right mr
mac mahone may i ask you that same
question please
yes sir those were the only people that
wish to hear the truth
you say yes you have been contacted i
was contacted like
uh right after the
array and fire this was
a while back no i meant in connection
with the hearing that we're having today
oh um
yes sir i haven't done that sure
and uh
can you give us a little idea of
when you were contacted
well i mean was it uh yesterday
um
have i talked to him yesterday yeah i
did talk to them yesterday i talked to
him and was the monday before
the day before yes the day before no
sure i was i didn't get the letter to
come here till yesterday i see
and uh what was the the nature of the
discussion between you and then
um
just what will i be doing there what's
going on i mean i've i didn't testify in
front of a trial or anything it's the
first time i've been in front of anybody
i understand and now let me ask you this
who was it that you talked to there
um
i talked to jim warner
mr warner a fellow by the name of mr
warner right
right the deputy general counsel uh i
believe you he sounded like a lawyer
okay let's let's move on we'll we'll get
more i'd like to ask you to amplify that
but we don't have time in the period of
five minutes
what what uh
i need to
bring to this part of our
hearing
is that
just recently
in the
gop contract with america and
specifically h.r 666
we voted out a bill with nearly
unanimous republican support
that didn't require
that uh
we have exceptions
to the exclusionary rule good faith
exceptions
we said that we went a lot further than
that they did not me
and said that uh we would throw the
whole warrant requirement out of the
window
if this part of the contract on america
becomes law because we would have an
expedited
exemption
to the whole exclusionary rule we
pointed out that this was eroding the
whole constitution
and now i am so pleased
to find that
the same people that voted to further
erode the cons the exclusionary rule of
which mr goldstein has
very uh adequately complained of
are now very worried that
there aren't teeth in it there there
wasn't enough it was very shoddy and now
we have this
incredible conflict
the bill that
the crime bill we passed out says
warrants aren't even needed for searches
it says there's no need for a magistrate
to determine whether there's probable
cause it gives total discretion of
probable cause to the law enforcement
authorities as long as they believed
that there was probable cause then no
warrant would be required at all that's
the law coming down the pipe
now mr deshaun
before drawing up
his affidavit agent aguilera
had spoken with several former compound
residents who told him there were
machine guns at the compound he also
spoke with firearm dealers who told him
they delivered kits that could be
converted uh
convert semi-automatic guns into
automatic weapons he spoke with a ups
employee who saw a hand grenade fall out
of a package before being delivered to
the compound
he spoke with lieutenant barber who told
him that a rancher living near the
compound had heard machine gun fire
after the raid machine guns and hand
grenades were found is there any case
law anywhere that would say that such a
factual predicate could in under any
circumstances be insufficient for
probable cause in order to obtain a
warrant
i'm certainly not aware of any such case
law
is gone
well i want to thank
all of the witnesses and i'm hopeful
that mr jewell who had not completed his
testimony
with mr taylor
would be given an opportunity
to do so
because
i wanted to hopefully ask him mr
chairman
who i praised for such imminent fairness
that did mr koresh personally tell you
that if the authorities ever came after
him he'd shoot them well it may be that
we can let mr jewel answer a question
like that after we're done if mr
thibodeau is also given a couple of
minutes who wants to say something too
so but let's see what happens in our
time we've got a whole nother you don't
think that's a very important question
well i think it's an important question
i think what maybe mr tibbett i want to
say is important too but we've got to be
judicious mr klinger has three and a
half minutes left
uh and i yield to it i thank the
chairman for yielding and i apologize
for not having been here to listen to
the testimony and i just have one
question and i'm going to yield the
balance of my time to
uh the vice chairman of the committee
who's been here for the entire testimony
mr schiff but my question would be to mr
mac mcmahon and i think you indicated
that you had been and had had
conversations with the representative
the nra
i have and and uh my question is simply
this was there an attempt made to
influence or uh con direct your
testimony were you in any way uh
influenced in the way you were supposed
to testify here today no sure they did
not i
i thank you very much at this point i
would like to yield the balance of my
time to mr ship
thank gentlemen for you mr thibodeau
you indicated that there were several
points that you thought could be and
should be refuted
on what subject
about what okay the sub the first
subject that i think needs to be brought
out is the fact that in 1992
not the federal government but the state
authorities came and investigated the
children and they went through the signs
of the physical the mental and the
sexual abuse
and they couldn't find any and they
dropped their case a state didn't a
state official actually come out to the
compound yes that is correct
was the state official uh fired on by
anyone absolutely not uh was the state
official he came up with a shift in
prison so that uh
he or she i believe she in this case
couldn't leave
no
she's free to come and go okay thank you
go ahead yeah and as a matter of fact
when asked about the underground bus
david crash took her down there and
showed it to her
so i mean from what my understanding was
he pretty much opened the place up to
her but anyway they found no signs of
the abuse that's been discussed
and
they dropped their case the next day in
the waco tribune herald
the health people said that these were
the nicest most well-behaved children
we've ever had the pleasure to work with
and you know i think if we're going to
check out the child abuse issue that's a
pretty powerful statement for a health
worker to make for kids that are that
are abused readily as we have heard and
also i just want to say that the child
abused issue
in my judgment has absolutely nothing to
do with this hearing i agree with it was
not a matter that was being investigated
by federal law enforcement doesn't mean
it's not an important issue but since uh
it's been brought up time and time again
i thank you at least for putting in the
other side go go ahead please yeah one
more thing the sheriff's department also
came out with them and the next day in
the press david spent a lot of time
talking with the people from the
sheriff's department because of what
happened in 1987 with george rhoden he
felt he was missed fairly treated but he
spent a long time talking to him invited
them out later on to go fishing and or
whatnot who wouldn't they who i'm sorry
he invited the sheriff's department some
of the sheriff's department officials i
do not know the names but who invited
crush did himself when they came out
with the health workers and they said
the next day in the wake of tribune
herald that the only problem with people
out there at mount carmel is that
they're misunderstood you know i mean
these are quotes from the from the legal
representation of mclennan county and i
think it's pretty much well documented
that david crush knew jack harwell the
sheriff on a first name basis and i
think that they the atf definitely
should have gone through jack and come
out
with the sheriff to to knock on the door
and not by the way the search warrant if
i just may say this really quick that
was a knock search warrant supposed to
go to the door knock on the door and
present it i don't understand how you
can serve a knock search warrant with
helicopters coming into the back three
different groups of atf agents one going
up the side to throw in flash bang
grenades to get the evidence while
another team goes and and and shoots the
dogs while yet another team is going to
the front door to serve the warrant
that's that's spontaneous it's happening
at once and that is not and you can get
a no knock search warrant sir if my
understanding is correct they did not
have one and i don't understand why they
would choose a dynamic entry with having
a knock search warrant well let me go
back to the sheriff's department are you
saying the sheriff's officials were
invited out to the compound yes you
actually saw them there no they never
came out later david always made the
invitation open to them to come out if
they wanted to fish on our ponds we had
a stock bass pawn right so he wasn't
hesitant by about having law enforcement
agents there no and you know there was
one more
interesting incident i just thought of
when when the initial reports came in
about all these uh automatic weapons
steve schneider actually went into the
sheriff's department and put a hell a
hellfire trigger switch uh on on the
desk and said this is legal i believe
under the atf that's probably what you
heard out there now you know i'm not
saying that's right or wrong sir all i'm
saying is that all the way along koresh
tried to work with law enforcement and i
know this from experience chris always
tried to work with people
your time has expired i i thank the
chair
at this time i will yield five minutes
to miss collins
uh mr chairman before this clock starts
running i need to uh ask for some
verification and i'll tell you what it
is i have a split second yes or no
answer that i'd like then i'd like to
yiel another
15 seconds to mr conyers and then two
minutes to mr uh jean green in two
minutes to
sheila jackson lee uh i don't have a
time watch here and and you're going to
take the time we'll take care of it
we'll do our best
i just want to make sure because i know
those lights go off real good yeah we'll
we'll do our best maybe we'll do this by
hand
we'll do our own stopwatch over here you
get going now i'll yield to you now your
time the clock starts running right now
okay
thank you mr chairman i yield to mr
thank you ms collins uh first of all uh
mr mac mahone would you give us uh
by tonight uh some statement about your
contact with the nra that we were
discussing please
yes or no
no i'm not that wasn't a question i was
asking him to do that
okay
i don't know understand why
are you saying are you ordering me too
are you saying do it or are you saying
yes i would like you to do it please
i'll consider
okay i think the time i think the time
is right
let me quickly ask mr thibodeau on
turning point last thursday night on abc
uh you testified that you saw koresh
when the
the raid occurred you saw mr karesh hold
out his hand
and said let's talk about this
okay do you remember that testimony yes
did you remember that test and today you
said you were nowhere near the door with
him that you were way at the back of the
room because what i said with that
testimony sir mr conyers what i said
with that testimony is i said that i
that i heard from three separate
eyewitnesses who were at the front door
that told me the same thing that that is
exactly what occurred you didn't see no
i made i made that clear that i was not
at the front door but that eyewitness
testimony told me time uh mr jewell
um
can you tell me uh
from from from your own knowledge
what
perhaps mr karesh told you he would do
if authorities ever came after him i
will try to make this as short an answer
as i possibly can but over a period of
years
in
trying to
maintain contact with my daughter i have
called the compound and
twice
got mr koresh on the phone and i was
engaged in a conversation with him
mr quresh and i shared
a common religious
ancestry in that we were both raised
seventh adventists we had that in common
and as seventh adventists we understood
that in the time of the end that god's
people would be persecuted and perhaps
put to death
he told me during the course of that
conversation that that was true however
when they came after him and his people
they were going to fight back and kill
anybody that they had to
thank you very much i yield to mr green
gene greene
let me i don't know if we still have the
grenade paperweight that that was shown
earlier and and maybe it's just because
i'm from texas and i've seen them before
in in
you know
army surplus stores and and uh but i
don't have a case of them
and uh and
mr mayheim if you could tell me
the we heard testimony from mr barber
about
ups saying that there were cases of
those uh paperweights that were
delivered that was one of the reasons
for the uh his concern in calling in atf
um in your experience as a firearms
dealer do you know of it at that
location if they were using those
uh
hollow grenades to pack explosives in i
never seen any hollow grenades i never
seen them out there i have seen those
type of grenades at gun shows as a
paperweight but i have never seen any ad
david okay so you didn't saw none of
them do you know of any of them that
have ever been used to
uh pack explosives in and then use them
as a grenade
by the branch the video no no you know
if that's available is that that
possible
i guess it's possible i mean i'm not
qualified to answer that
i reclaimed my time my yield remaining
time to sheila jackson lee
thank you very much and i imagine i have
to talk like the uh speeding bullet i
hate to use that terminology let me say
how proud i am of kerry i have a 15 year
old and i'm just you've stood here so
long mr jewell if you can help me um
you've
said very clearly you're not a
theologian you're not a pastor but we
talk about uh this is for the american
people and people hear the word religion
and they hear the fact that we should in
this country respect it
help me understand from what your
daughter went through would you say that
he had gone beyond
and that we had reached now a point uh
of a cult
what is your sense of it and i have a
quick question from mr mcmahon and you
see how fast i'm going the one thing
that i think god expects of us is that
we use our own minds to develop
ourselves and become everything that we
can be
that differs from what it is my
understanding that david koresh
encouraged his followers to do in that
he encouraged them to listen only to him
and he could change his mind anytime he
wanted to and his word was still law i
think for the american people that's
important because you've mentioned a
certain religion and i would not want it
to be indicted for what really was a
true cult and took away the minds of
people mr mcmahon did you visit mr
karash in the compound
at david's house yes ma'am i that and
you just mentioned was that his home
yes ma'am were there women and children
there yes ma'am were there some children
under five
uh i would think so karen spent most of
time with the kids and done deal no
ma'am not that i know we'll say that
could you describe maybe the amount of
weapons that were in the home there or
maybe much of you sold him um i just
turned the list into uh just give me a
name just give me a i sold him two i
sold him around 223 guns pardon me i
sold him around 223 guns would that be
the average amount of weapons you find
in normal american families homes would
you have any way of estimating that
no way i've estimated i mean they have
estimated it to be
like three guns per person and that is
below their average and if they're yeah
however it is a home children the wives
and you said 223 that you sold and of
course that doesn't account for what
else he might have had let me um move
and thank you very much for that but
that was his i think i've been very
liberal about it have you been and i've
got so many more questions well i i know
chairman
thank you for being so liberal with your
time you have certainly been very fair
and have extended time i greatly
appreciate it well you're you're quite
welcome and it's been a pleasure today i
think i pretty well well mr chairman i
hope that uh our earlier question about
uh being able to ask questions will be
considered thank you we're doing our
best here uh i think that we have pretty
well completed all the formal questions
we're supposed to have if we let this
continue we'll never get to another
panel and as i have questions i'd like
to ask actually but nonetheless i
i think it can be submitted in writing
and any of you want to submit them
please do and somebody asked earlier
about statements before i release this
panel and turn the gavel over to mr
zelip i want to make sure everybody
understands without objection anybody's
statement any of the witnesses in any of
the panel member statements may be
submitted for the record mr thibodeaux
you had wanted to make a statement on
the record yeah we don't have time no
one's got to make i submit them in
writing you may submit it in writing
absolutely you may submit it in writing
and we've done the best through mr
schiff we could to give you some verbal
time with that
in mind uh miss thurman and of course
that would be offered to all of the
we just made witnesses statement all of
the witnesses have a right to submit a
statement statement in writing if they
desire to hold the record open for well
the record's certainly going to be open
through the period at least at the time
of the hearings which are over a period
of the next couple of weeks right
certainly through the end of this month
i would suggest they'll be open mr
chairman yes mr micah just a
question of parliamentary inquiry up i
have a copy of miss jewell's uh
notes or statements i wasn't in when she
testified and i wondered if
if this statement had been made a part
of the record
and also
mr chairman uh when this was
uh presented well
if i may just say if you were not here
the record will reflect that mr thurman
was asking the question she asked miss
jewell to read the entire statement and
she read it verbatim so it has been read
into the record but when was it given to
the committee um i believe the committee
received it this morning
this afternoon
she was speaking
well it was before that she spoke but
during this morning because i i didn't
see that our side had this this morning
we uh i know they were at the at the
desks here this morning well for those
elementary inquiries i want to thank
this particular panel you've been very
gracious you've spent your time some of
you've had some pretty tough questions
to answer but we thank you very much for
coming and now i'm going to turn the
gavel back over to my co-chairman mr
zeliph and for the last panel of the day
thank you
okay i'd like to thank this panel and
have the next panel come forward
and sworn in
so he's right here
[Music]
while you are proceeding to the witness
table
okay
in the order that i call everybody and
introduce you and be on your right my
left i'll start out with davey aguilera
is it
david
on my on your far right my left
is a bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms special agent
chuck cereben is the former bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms special
agent in charge in houston
earl dunigan is the former bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms special
agent in charge in houston
bill johnson is the assistant u.s
attorney in waco texas
dan hartnett
is the former bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms deputy director for
enforcement
ed owen
is a firearms expert for the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
h jeffrey moulton jr was the project
director of the treasury department
review team
dr bruce perry is an associate professor
of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at
baylor medical college
thank you gentlemen
you raise your right hand
do you swear do you solemnly swear the
testimony you're about to give these
subcommittees the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth i do
thank you but the records show that the
answer was
okay
i know that uh each of you come with a
uh
each of you comes with a very special
story we appreciate your your being here
uh some of you appear on future panels
during these hearings to address
different concerns
today by previous agreement we will try
to focus on the investigation and the
warrants portion and we'll begin with
questions
the chair now recognizes the vice chair
of our national security subcommittee
and my friend robert ehrlich of maryland
for the
thank you mr chairman
um
i thank you all for appearing before us
today before i begin my formal remarks i
would just like to make a couple points
all right we have changed we changed the
order and i apologize uh would you be
willing to hold on
sure um what i'd like to do is have uh
our colleague mr barr 15 minutes first
thank you mr chairman
uh mr johnson is it johnson or johnston
it's actually johnson with a t that's
that's what i thought um
you have a law degree
yes sir uh and you serve as a united
assistant united states attorney a
prosecutor yes sir i do okay uh
i have a law degree and i served as a
u.s attorney so we have two things in
common i suspect
we have something else in common and
that is uh neither of us are are
particularly enamored of mr david koresh
am i correct and that we share that in
common
based on what i know he did some bad
things
based on what i know he did also
and i think that that is something that
we do have in common let me if i could
mr johnston
ask you a few questions define
very succinctly for me dynamic entry
i hadn't heard that term of dynamic
entry uh neither had i
i i suppose it means uh some
active movement in a search warrant well
let me kind of back up then uh do you
know what the the term dynamic entry
means
uh
i could give you a definition that i
think it means
okay
shall i please uh
a a search warrant or a uh did you pull
that like yes
yes sir
uh police activity uh in connection with
a search warrant
that involves uh
uh
an injury uh where their persons are not
invited in other words as opposed to
like where police call ahead of time and
are invited in or do some low
low profile
entry it would be more in the nature of
a
moving search warrant like you might see
on television where agents
are running instead of walking and so
forth
was was the the entry in this case a
dynamic entry
i wasn't there but based on what i've
seen on television
in keeping with the definition i've just
given i think it was okay were you you
were not at the scene no sir okay
uh and did you have any discussions uh
at any time prior to
the
dynamic entry or whatever it was on
february 28th of last of 19 1993
with atf concerning a dynamic entry
not concerning that term
they discussed
they mentioned almost in passing that
they were going to do something i
learned in the nature of having agents
in cattle trailers
i didn't know the details of the
of the raid plan
okay are you familiar with
testimony in a previous court case
concerning efforts by a defense attorney
to
question raise questions with a witness
as to whether or not you had in told
them that
your office or you would not
approve a a search warrant or an
affidavit in support of a search warrant
unless it contemplated a dynamic entry i
have and it's a gross mixed
characterization of anything i've seen
you're familiar with with that sorry i
heard it during the trial yes sir okay
uh would it be fair to say uh mr
johnston that
the purpose of an investigation in
support of a potential prosecution
involves
an effort to see the justices done
absolutely
would you share with me a concern that
federal employees
whether they're involved in law
enforcement or non-law enforcement
activities
if they violate the law or engage in
wrongdoing that they should be
prosecuted and brought to justice
absolutely and would you also agree with
me that
an effort to do so through an internal
that is within the government
investigation
ought to be a search for the truth
i think any investigation ought to be a
search for the truth or it's not much of
an investigation certainly one involving
allegations of wrongdoing on the part of
officials sworn to uphold the law yes
sir okay
with that in mind then i would ask you
would it be appropriate
in a investigation of alleged wrongdoing
by federal officials
that the government
deliberately and explicitly
direct that evidence not be gathered
that evident that witnesses not be
interviewed
that no record of
interviews be kept
that the passage of time hopefully will
cause witnesses memories to dim
would that be a fair search for the
truth or would that be more in the
nature of
damage control or a cover-up
well what you're describing doesn't
sound like
and i don't if you're asking that in the
hypothetical with reference to this case
so it's it's it's not hypothetical and
i'm going to show you some documents
that establish it's not hypothetical
if i could have a clerk
uh
if you would please uh mr johnson these
are three documents which were contained
in the
documents made available
to this body
by virtue of the subpoenas
one is a memo from a robert mcnamara to
john simpson and others
treasury department dated 14 april 1993
subject preliminary investigative plan
it says that this is law enforcement
sensitive and it involves an
investigation of atf
and it states on page two
quote doj does not want treasury to
conduct any interviews or have
discussions with any of the participants
who may be potential witnesses
then later in that same
subparagraph it talks about
while we may be able to wait for some of
them witnesses
to have testified in the criminal trial
the passage of time will dim memories
then later on
it states at the very bottom of page two
the prosecutors are concerned that
anything negative even preliminary
could be grist for the defense mill
and
that document goes
on
another of the documents that you have
before you is a
another treasury department
document this one from ron noble
assistant secretary for enforcement
dated september 17 1993
and it reflects
an interview
that took place on march 1 1993
and i quote atf initiates a shooting
review
and then it goes on
troy tells review they immediately
determined that these stories did not
add up
that is interviews with rodriguez
mastin
tanaki kavanaugh
sarabin
then it says johnston at this point
advised hartnett to stop the atf
shooting review
because atf was creating brady material
because panacky had not yet been
interviewed johnston authorized that
interview but no notes were created
a third document which you have before
you
is another department of justice
document dated april 9 1993 again from
robert mcnamara
to ron noble
while the subject matter at the
beginning of that document has to do
with waco press release
in the middle of it it says justice
prosecutors in washington and in waco
said that any words which would which
could be interpreted as being critical
of atf
must be avoided since it would play into
the defense attorney's hands and aid the
defense attorneys in making atf the
issue
and then that document
goes on there are some other
documents that i have before me
and i'll make these available these are
not as clear
as these typewritten documents
they are
notes that again were furnished to us
pursuant to subpoena
and if i could have a clerk
deliver those mr johnston please
one
reads as follows and this is document
number zero zero zero one four one three
seven
it says
t rangers perhaps
for texas rangers ray yan does not want
them
kolnacki phil
ray interviewed because john does not
want any more exculpatory statements
generated
the other one i think that we've already
dealt with in previous testimony had to
do with mr yan advising
ron noble not to open an envelope
and the final one here
involves again and i apologize for the
lack of clarity but we have to deal with
what we have
it again involves some handwritten notes
the first word at the top of the page
looks like leroy
and it says
statements from agents
agts i presume that means agents
should they go to usa which i presume is
united states attorney for us
do they want us to create new and then
there's a blank
and then it concludes by saying
asking questions to which would require
us to create new documents
parenthetically it says exculpatory
these documents
to me mr johnston raised very troubling
questions about
what was going on here we heard at the
very beginning today
an article here in the paper
talking about damage control and this is
dated today july 19th
and i have some very serious concerns
here that
this started a long time ago i'm
and i have a background as a prosecutor
and and i would presume that
these sorts of memos and i know you
didn't generate them at least i don't it
doesn't appear that you did
they came from
another lawyer at the department of
justice mr mcnamara i believe and i
don't know who wrote the handwritten
notes
but these are documents that were
furnished by the government presumably
generated by the government as part of
an investigation to determine i suppose
among other things
what went wrong
and
what agents might have done wrong i mean
we know that were things done wrong i
mean agents were terminated because of
that because of misstatements because of
misleading uh activities
uh
was this i mean what what's going on
here okay i cannot speak to uh the
references uh
to ray and leroy yon they were here
and it appears there are references to
them and exculpatory matters
uh
i
i was not concerned about sculptory
matters the truth is the truth i can
speak to the
note that has my name in it which talks
about hardness in the shooting review
the
typical protocol with atf my
understanding is is after an incident a
shooting incident occurs
a shooting review team is created
sometimes out of washington sometimes
elsewhere they normally go down and
interview the agents
they
i don't know if it's normally recorded
or not but at least notes are taken
uh that process started
uh there were at least a couple of uh
there were some interviews i don't know
how many
this was in uh
early march i believe it was fairly soon
after the incident
atf began
well immediately received a great deal
of criticism
for what they had done
and
it became obvious at least to me
that atf probably should not investigate
atf as far as the criminal case goes
and uh i don't have the authority to
direct atf to do something but i did
talk to i think mr hartnett i'm not sure
he can stay whether or not
and told him that
in line with our hope or that point may
be a fact
the texas rangers have agreed to
investigate this case
let them investigate it please
because for atf to interrogate atf
with the built-in bias and suspicion
that already existed i thought
was
would be
not healthy
i had no reason to think atf would in
their own interviews cover something up
but there were a lot of people that did
and the texas rangers i believe would be
an
objective a qualified body to
investigate it and yes sir i asked the
rangers to do the investigation all in
all now for eight atf to have come in
and had a shooting review team member
interview someone and have the ranger
come in three minutes behind and do the
same thing i thought was
very important
the rangers i believed could ask
questions get straight answers
and develop
the truth of what happened and it may i
add in terms of the timing of it there's
some
i feel you've
alleged on someone's part maybe mine
that i want people's memories to dim in
fact i asked the rangers to i asked the
waco police department the night just
happened to begin interviewing atf
agents before the memories of them waco
police detectives i could name two or
three at my request went to the
hillcrest hospital in waco and taped
interviews with agents while they were
still on
uh codeine
and so forth and the rangers i asked to
as quickly as they could get
interviewing and they did sir and they
were all audio taped on all made
available and there were some scope
the reference to sorry memories being
dimmed was uh containing this memo by
mr mcnamara uh and it would be nice i've
met mr matt so ask him some of these
questions but in terms of your
prosecutorial background
uh which from everything i can tell is
is exemplary
uh
why why would why would the federal
government uh
first of all be committing things like
this to writing
but uh more importantly
why would they be deliberately
directing that in terms of an internal
investigation to uncover
potential wrongdoing
why would they be explicitly directing
that evidence not be accumulated
that interviews not be conducted that
when they are perhaps there there are
not any notes taken
uh i mean why would that happen and let
me also say i know as a prosecutor brady
material can sometimes be a pain in the
neck to deal with
uh that's what happened here in court
but we have mechanisms for it but
it seems to me that the government was
trying to cover something up here well
well i sure wasn't in fact i was trying
to avoid
the question of a cover-up if atf had
done this investigation themselves as i
say i have no reason to think they would
have coached their own agents or would
have
suggested answers to their agents but i
thought it would have been a real easy
thing to criticize and
quite objectively because atf was under
attack so strongly they may have bonded
together in interviews i don't know i
don't think they would have done it
intentionally but it was extremely
important to have objectivity
my desire for the rangers to do it was
to seek the truth
in the
most unintimidating circumstance
possible in other words so the rangers
could ask atf agents one-on-one which
they did
audio taped everything that happened
and i felt the rangers the atf agents
would be comfortable talking to the
rangers whereas they may not be
comfortable talking to atf supervisors
in his treasure review i mean uh
hey
i'm sorry
okay
i'll try to quickly finish the answer
sir mr chairman
because there was conflict within atf by
this time
a lot of agents at the staging area felt
they
elementary surprise been lost there was
a lot of conflict
the shooting review teams are often
comprised of people involved in
supervisory capacities there was
conflict between line agents and
supervisors and i felt to
give it the best chance of being a
truthful interview of each agent the
rangers should do it sir
and as to
brady i'm not afraid of brady as
exculpatory matters i'm not afraid of
exculpatory matters and was not
well
that that
your your sentiments do not seem
reflective at all in the in these
documents i certainly didn't create them
sir they certainly will be looked into
further i i thank the chairman and i
thank mr johnson
thank you
i think uh
i think what we're gonna
anybody know how long this vote's gonna
be how many votes
one fifteen minute vote
okay we're gonna recess for 15 minutes
uh we have a vote and we'll be right
back thank you
we'll continue with the waco
investigation in a moment
but first some program information
information about c-span and public
affairs is available on your personal
computer through america online get our
daily program schedule read the text of
pending bills in congress and learn
about c-span in the classroom to find
out more about america online call
1-800-827-6364
extension 8665 if you're already an aol
subscriber find the c-span area by
typing the keyword c-span
sunday night the latest developments on
the road to the white house our weekly
look ahead to the 96 presidential
election brings you candidate forums
speeches and campaign events
road to the white house sunday at 7 00
and 10 p.m eastern and pacific time on
c-span the political network of record
we now continue with the waco
investigation
the first day of hearings before a house
joint subcommittee
chairing the hearing republican bill
zellath of new hampshire and republican
bill mccollum of florida
committees will come to order
the chair recognizes mr schumer from new
york for 15 minutes thank you mr
chairman i want to thank all the
witnesses for being here uh
i have a whole series of questions but i
would like to make one point first i'm
sorry most of my colleagues on the other
side aren't here we've heard a lot of
talk about faulty warrants
search warrants
and you know that it might the uh some i
might not have been dotted some tea
might not have been crossed
if i'm not mistaken these are the same
folks
my colleagues to the right here
who voted
to eliminate the need for search
warrants with the good faith exception
to the exclusionary rule
now i think that's you know i i didn't
support that i can see an argument but
it does strike me as a little
little strange that
just a few months ago
people voted that there should be good
faith
no one doubts the good faith of the
people here and yet here we're making
huge fuss about warrants not being
perfect uh
it's the topsy-turvy nature of this
hearing altogether i might it's my
belief that uh as i said in my opening
statement
that this idea of moral equivalence
that well here we have koresh and here
we have atf and fbi and they're sort of
the same they've each made some mistakes
maybe atf is the villain or fbi is the
villain and koresh is a misunderstood
guy
is going to lead the other side into
trouble throughout these hearings if
that's their view and it seems to me
that is in many ways
now i'd like to ask first mr aguilera
some questions i want to focus on the
warrant
first of all mr aguilera how many
warrants have you put together uh in
your career as a uh atf uh investigator
approximately approximately 30 or more
30 have any ever been thrown out no sir
so you've had a hundred percent record
in putting together decent warrants yes
warrants at least that met
the uh tests that courts impose yes sir
thank you
um
and let me ask you this
uh what made you initiate the
investigation of the possible
manufacture of machine guns and
explosives uh devices by koresh and
other members of the davidians in the
compound in waco and from whom did you
receive the information
to this is the vernacular question i
received the information from lieutenant
gene gene barber from the mclennan
council shouldn't come out of your head
or something higher up in washington or
anything like that this came from local
law enforcement yes sir and they don't
call you very often to do something like
this do they no sir this was because of
the extreme nature of uh
what mr koresh was doing that's correct
okay in your experiences do people
generally order uh cases and cases of
grenade casings and then order uh the
metal parts and the uh what's it called
nitrate
no that makes aluminum nitrate i guess
hydrogen nitrate or ammonium nitrogen
potassium nitrate thank you uh do they
do that i mean do they do that unless
usually they have some kind of bad
purpose in mind how many to no sir no
you don't need just to clarify for the
record you don't need ammonium nitrate
uh magnesium or aluminum powder to help
a paperweight
no sir no the casing alone might suffice
for the paperweight i thought so um
let me uh
even mr zelif is smiling at that
question um
mr barr is not here i wanted him to hear
it too
uh
but in any case
okay
let me uh
i'm on a roll right well it's not hard
to be on a roll when the facts are on
your side uh
in any case let me um
uh ask you other than arms dealers we
saw one of the arms dealers who else did
you interview and in an effort to find
out if the davidians possessed or were
manufacturing illegal weapons and what
did you learn
i i interviewed numerous uh
former dividend members right and uh i
obtained
i'm interested in the neighbor tell us a
little about the neighbor since we had
wanted him to come testify mr cervenka
if i'm pronouncing his name mr cervanco
cervenka he's not allowed so we'll have
to rely on your testimony yes sir i
initially received the information from
gene barber who was told by mr cervanka
that
he
had heard machine gun fire throughout
the evenings
and uh thereafter
i personally interviewed mr cervanka
who told me the same thing
okay thank you mr aguilera at least i
think the case has been made
overwhelmingly that you met the
appropriate standard in this warrant and
uh that we're getting some crocodile
tears about it my next uh questions come
from mr johnston who i must say has a
reputation of being a fine prosecutor
how many years have you been a
prosecutor
a little over ten years eight years in
the face how many search warrants have
you reviewed
several hundred okay did you feel that
special agent aguilera had done a decent
a good job on the investigation of
violations in the firearms lord davidian
when you saw the warrant
i felt he done a very good job and the
affidavit itself while he gave the
information and drafted it it was worked
on by assistant u.s attorneys including
me and there's been a lot of talk today
about the sexual abuse being in the
affidavit yes i'm going to ask you that
that was my call and why did you put it
in there
for a number of reasons primarily
a woman named joyce sparks had given
information we've heard about her she
was interviewed by a member of the waco
committee team named miss hagen
there was quite a bit of information i
think a page or more about joyce sparks
and the information she'd received
in and of itself it wasn't it didn't say
they had machine guns but it
demonstrated that they had
apparently had
weapons
they had there was some threatening
discussion by koresh too
involving ms sparks further there was
evidence of a buried school bus that may
act as a shooting range at any rate
to
explain to the magistrate
why miss sparks was there
i
made the decision to include in there
why she was there she was there to
investigate albus allegations of sexual
abuse of children
uh
and
the allegations of sexual abuse in
in my mind were referenced generally in
the affidavit had i had i wanted to
had i wanted to i don't mean to hurry up
but my ten minutes ago i got a lot of
other had i wanted to prejudice the
affidavit and the warrant i would have
put it i knew kerry joel's story before
the affidavit was was drafted and i
would have put in all the details the
gory details about how he
what he did to her i didn't want to
prejudice a magistrate but i did want to
put the context of miss sparks visit
it was put in there to show why she was
there and that she was there
legitimately there was evidence of
sexual abuse she wasn't she didn't drop
out of the sky she had a good reason and
of course and i think we haven't been i
mean it's been pretty clear the
warrant's okay so i'm not going to
bother you with many more questions just
reiterating the fact defense lawyers
very capable didn't challenge and
furthermore we found and i'll get to
that with mr owen we actually found
violations of law you did on the
compound but just one other quick answer
you also found some other things i think
some of those are the books that you
have next to you would you just briefly
if you could mr johnson explain
what the or let me ask you and then you
can corroborate as i understand it those
books explain how to make bombs and
things like that and they were found on
the compound well these books were
ordered and sent to uh
the davidians
they along with and of themselves they
might just be interesting reading but
they go with the materials they had this
one which they had these are introduced
at trial congressman improvements
landmines improvised land mines their
employment and destructive capabilities
right cia field expedient methods for
explosive preparation okay etc etc we'll
submit for the record all of the names
anyway
those weren't being used as paperweights
were they uh when you arrived when you
saw them they
the things they had fit into the talk in
the books thank you
okay mr owen uh and again i apologize
all of these witnesses have put lots of
their lives into this case and it's sort
of unfair to rush through but i have so
many points i want to make i have to and
mr johnston i think you've done a
an excellent job on this case and we
very much appreciate it mr owen um
would it be fair to say and don't be
modest uh that you're an expert on
firearms
yes sir i've been recognizing it as an
expert okay um here is my question did
you you were on the scene you identified
guns from the compound could you tell us
briefly about that
i was assigned to assist both the fbi
and the texas rangers at the evidence
collection point this is how many days
after the uh this was
the day this search began it was
several days after the fire got it uh
could you identify any of those weapons
uh that you actually saw at the compound
uh yes sir in fact the representative of
the texas rangers
has they happened to have them here good
could we uh
could we see could could could one of
the rangers please uh
show us one of the
illegal weapons that were
found at the uh compound the actual
weapon is here and
you're from the ranger sir we thank you
for your help sergeant sergeant jim
miller of the rangers thank you sergeant
okay could you just hold that up
yes
now uh mr owen do you have to go over
there and examine them or is it
sufficient for you to see from here are
those weapons that could you name what
they were could you hold that one up
please sir
stand up please i i need to see it a
little bit closer go over please
and could the other gentleman just stand
up so the committee can get some idea
okay now that one's obviously charred
can you just tell us what these were and
if you found them at the compound
this is a converted ar-15 type rifle
manufactured by the converted beans
being made into an automatic gives me
every indication it's been modified into
the presence
of a pivot pin hole that mounts an m16
automatic sear
the barrel has been modified
by drilling holes through the sides of
it
a
copper wool pad is wrapped around the
barrel with an outer
casing this is very typical of sound
suppressor or silence or construction
thank you
and the other one just briefly is at the
center just let me ask you and you can
answer is that a weapon
illegal that you found at the compound
this is an ak-47 type rifle that has
been converted
to permit full automatic making it
illegal yes sir thank you
and mr aguilera um
[Music]
this is what you were afraid that you
might find i guess when you put the
warrant together yes sir thank you my
final questions are for dr perry
who
um
dr perry you interviewed the 21 children
released from the compound during the
standoff based on your team's interviews
what type of lifestyle were the children
exposed to and how healthy was this did
the children understand who their
families were i'm going to let you
finish up so i want to ask these quickly
we worked extensively we didn't just
interview them we basically lived with
these kids for two months we
had a large team of experts
much with much more expertise than the
religious and social
apologists who have tried to
make
this sound like it was a benign
religious community
i know of no religious
sect that practices
grooming children from the age of four
and five to be sex objects of the leader
um we basically you know files the name
of calling it a relationship it actually
is i think for many people who
are practicing christians it was it's
very offensive to suggest that
engaging in sex with children is a
legitimate part of our uh belief system
and how about discipline what did you
find
the kids were inappropriately and
excessively disciplined physical
discipline that was clearly abusive we
found a whole variety of other practices
which i've described in
my statement and the appendices which i
would like to have entered into the
record please without it there's uh the
other thing that we found
was and i and i think that we can't
really be any more our conclusions were
very independent of
uh the very compelling
story of kerry jewell right we received
we we came to a very
similar understanding of the belief
system the apocalyptic views right the
the sense that there was a willingness
to engage in an abstract suicide
completely independent of any
information from curie two other
questions my colleague miss slaughter in
asking
both kiri and uh mr tebido questions
asked two things about paddling so that
the bottoms were black and blue a very
very young children i think eight or
nine months was mentioned did you find
that to be the case we kids reported
that
and we found two of the children and all
the children actually very openly spoke
about being paddled with the helper
two of the children had physical lesions
at the time of release
after they shoot out
where they had
initially they would not disclose what
that was later on they told us that was
from being paddled with the helper right
and second the instance that was
mentioned about putting a child i think
it was in a garage without we we heard
that story from the children we also
heard many other instances of uh
withholding food
of uh physical isolation of a whole
variety of innovations and you heard
this directly from this directly from
the children so maybe mr thibodeau
didn't talk to enough people there but
one thing that's very important to
remember is that the men in the compound
were kept and lived separately from the
women and children so mr thibodeau's
ability to make comments about the lives
of the children i think is quite limited
well thank you mr perry um i heard even
you did a comparison of the children's
heartbeats
um yes we did we we were one of the
things that has been commented on in
these hearings and by many people who do
not understand what happens to
traumatized kids is that just because
they are compliant and they behave well
that there's the assumption that they
are mentally healthy uh i think that
there's no way to predict in this room
because everybody has been essentially
compliant which one of us has been is
depressed which person has had is
mourning the loss of a loved one and so
forth children are no different than
adults in their ability to hide their
inner
feelings
when we examine these children and
looked at their baseline heart rates
over the entire period of the two months
that they between the original shootout
and the fire we found that they were
abnormally elevated and this elevation
was consistent with an internal sense of
extreme distress
which was uh we believe was an
inconvenience
you're very generous yeah i was just
wondering if the children could be
characterized as traumatized absolutely
thank you okay
uh mr ehrlich from maryland for 15
minutes thank you mr chairman uh
i want to thank everybody for appearing
here today
before i begin my questions i'd like to
make a few points i think they're
important to make
the purpose of my questions is not to
choose sides certainly it's it's not to
hold up anything
i'm banned on photo ops it's certainly
my not my intent to put anyone on trial
with respect to their careers
nor is it my intent to put anything on
trial
including the nra including the contract
with america i'm just keeping a list
today
uh the batf the militias the assault
weapons ban gun control generally
it's not even my intent to put david
koresha in trial i'm convinced david
koresh was a bad guy he had sex with
kids he's a real bad guy
i'm just a freshman from maryland
and i represent a couple hundred
thousand people
and
a fair percentage of those people have
some legitimate questions about the way
this whole thing was handled that's
where i'm coming from
i know it's washington it's fun to spend
i'm interested in some facts i have some
very specific questions for you all and
i really appreciate your answers today
my first question uh
and you and uh
mr johnson you touched on this uh with
respect to a question from mr barr
and i wanted to develop it further i
believe you were asked whether or not
you uh had stated
that during planning meetings with atf
you would not support
the search warrant for the davidian
center unless the dynamic entry was
utilized i believe you
disagreed with that
testimony i believe that testimony came
from the trial can you elaborate further
please yes i i disagree with it it
wasn't testimony trial it was an
allegation by a defense attorney
and it was something that came up in
court having to do with
is out of the presence of the jury at
any rate it's been an allegation there
have been a number of allegations
against me uh
like that the other day someone said
that i suggest they call an air strikes
on the compound and i put a hundred
shame and uh that's just as untrue of
course but at any rate i don't know
about it till the hunt
at any rate
i was not involved in planning meetings
with atf as to the raid only into the
preparation of the search warrant
i did not tell them what kind of raid to
do i didn't know exactly what kind of
raid they were going to do i did know it
involved cattle trailers and i did know
that it was uh some kind of a ruse they
were going to try to pull you know pull
in the
skies of cattle trailers but i didn't
know all the details and that wasn't my
function
and
thank you for that i i asked a very
specific question i got a very specific
answer and i appreciate it very much
uh secondly with respect to
the whole military involvement mr
schumer developed this line of
questioning
you would all agree i believe that
aircraft from the national guard
flash bangs used to flash bangs the mp
five rifles etc they're not specific to
military type missions would that be
generally agreed upon
anybody want to answer that
yes sir that's correct they're not
specific to military application now sir
you would agree however that the use of
bradley fighting vehicles would be
specific to a military mission correct
my knowledge of the bradley is a
military vehicle it's a combat vehicle
and sir at some point in time atf made a
request that was subsequently withdrawn
with respect to i believe either seven
or ten every i've read different
versions of it a request for seven or
ten bradley fighting vehicles with
respect to a proposed raid is that
correct
i have absolutely no no knowledge of
that does anyone on the panel have any
knowledge of that
i think there was an original request
in our early planning for
what we were going to do we were talking
about doing a siege and at that time
there was a request that that went
forward
sir let me let me just follow up mr
servant yes
it's my understanding that there's no
formal standard in law
um
by which the military defines a a drug
nexus it's my understanding that
pursuant to law
and regulations
promulgated by department of defense or
the army
that there needs to be a drug nexus
uh allegation prior to military
involvement is that correct
it's my understanding that
and you'll have to ask the military
which will be on later that at the time
that there was a nexus request now they
can supply certain things
if there's a nexus then it depends on
who would pay for it
right because if you get the military if
you prove the nexus you get the military
and it's free correct
the military involvement is free
that is correct okay
now
i guess
with respect to mr schumer's line of
questioning i'm confused because i
understood the answers he received from
the subsequent panel
about
although he did not get into the bradley
fighting vehicles the bottom line to his
line of questioning was no military
involvement period
yet i read in today's
washington post that ron noble assistant
secretary of the treasury
made this statement
the kind of support that the atf
received from the military in this case
was the kind of support you'd want them
to receive
lives were saved because of the
assistance they received from the
military
now i realize mr noble's not here but
does anyone possibly know what what
assistance he's referring to
yes sir i believe the assistance he's
referring to there is probably uh the
medical training emergency medical
training that was provided by special
forces to
uh two atf agents to atf medics in
advance of the raid we did document in
the report acts of
of sheer uh heroism by the medics at atf
at the raid they were trained by army
medics in uh
in uh battlefield like uh uh life-saving
techniques and laser lives were safe as
a result of that
sir your answer
is that that quote to your understanding
i realize he's not here you're only
suggesting a possible answer only refer
to the military training i'm sorry the
medical training and not training with
respect to training for the actual raid
on the compound i obviously can't answer
as to what mr noble had in mind when he
when he made that quote the life-saving
assistance provided by the military that
i'm familiar with is the medical
emergency medical assistance that was
provided to atf medics
thank you
uh let me switch my line of inquiry here
um
it appears from everything that that
we've been informed uh uh concerning
this
raid that atf at some point lost the
element of secrecy
uh koresh himself visited the uh this is
mr tiburo's
uh testimony from the earlier panel
visited his next door neighbors and
stated that he believed the quote
unquote college students were too old
and had new cars were probably fbi
agents
koresh complained to the local sheriff
ups delivery man was an uncover
undercover police officer
he did not appreciate being investigated
the davidians visited their new
neighbors they were not uh treated as
new neighbors would be expected to have
been treated etc uh
my question really is
was there
any thought prior to conducting this
raid
that the element of secrecy had been
lost
the second part of that question is if
the answer is yes
why
was the warrant attempted to be served
according to the procedure which
occurred
i'll let anyone answer that question sir
i'd like to have the opportunity to
answer that question and i certainly
think it's appropriate if the
representative from atf does as well
those were really the central questions
that uh we addressed in the treasury
review uh two years ago and and a good
portion of our report was devoted to uh
examining those questions and offering
answers can i just i will come back to
you okay i will come back to you and i
understand your role here
i would like
the atf agents present to answer the
question
with respect to the element of surprise
yes sir
on
february the 1st
a decision was made and i'm sad to say i
was part of that decision
to
entrust the news media at the waco
tribune herald
with certain information about our
investigation
and that was because they continued
to make contact with folks in the u.s
attorney's office and
other law enforcement agencies
with the threat to break
a series of articles
about the branch davidians that they had
been working on for a long period of
time
we met with a barbara elmore
who i believe was a managing editor at
that time
when i say we
mr ceremony and i
and
we asked if we could speak with her off
the record and she agreed
we explained to her that we had a very
sensitive investigation going on
and that an untimely breaking of the
news
about the branch davidians
would
certainly
hamper the success of of a any search
warrant that might come about
and could
and probably would
put the safety if not the lives of both
federal agents and those occupants of
the compound
into jeopardy
ms elmore said
in response
that she wasn't going to make any
promises that she would talk to
her
supervisors at paper and would let us
know at a later time
not to belabor this or take it too far
but on
the wednesday prior to
the warrant being executed
in the afternoon at about three o'clock
mr hanowski met
with members of the waco news media
newspaper specifically at their offices
and as he
began his
statement of appreciation for their
cooperation he was immediately
interrupted
by one of the
supervisors there
and was told
that he wanted
the newsman said i want it clearly
understood
that this newspaper is not cooperating
with law enforcement
in any shape or form
our search was planned for march the
first
we were notified after that meeting with
mr hornowski in the news media
that they intended to break their lead
article
on
february the 28th
sunday
we
set in motion
activities
to back the date of the warrant
execution up to sunday
hoping that
we could at least execute the warrant on
the same day that the lead article came
out
and then we were notified
after having made those arrangements
that the
newspaper decided they would break their
lead article on saturday which they did
when
the raid team arrived at the compound
there was news media personnel
all over the area
already
one of whom
had been contacted by david jones
and he the newsman tells david jones you
better get out of here atf's fixing to
raise his place
now when we talk about element of
surprise
is is the element of surprise lost when
the first article comes out
or is the element of surprise lost and
we were unaware that the news person had
told david jones that until afterwards
it searched if i cut you off for a
second i realized i'm running for a time
is it your testimony that the press
awaited
you all when you arrived at the compound
to conduct the raid yes sir did that
give you any hint that the element of
secrecy may have been compromised
we did not recognize them as the press
as we were coming as the raid team was
coming in they didn't recognize them as
the press at the time okay sir let me
ask you this question besides the formal
besides
the formal avenue of the press
did any of the other
testimony produced here today or
any other facts come to your attention
that would have raised a
question in your mind as to whether the
element of secrecy had been compromised
at any point prior to the raid
if when we talk about the element of
secrecy as opposed to the element of
surprise the element of secret secrecy
um
about our raid
we didn't feel was compromised at that
point okay so your testimony is
that you all believed and i'm just
trying to get your viewpoint here yes
sir prior to that rate
10 seconds prior to the beginning of
that raid you did not feel as though the
element of secrecy or surprise
had been compromised is that correct no
that's not correct sir ten seconds prior
to the raid
i feel like the secrecy
was lost at that point okay your time
has expired
thank you i'll have an opportunity to
follow thank you mr chairman we're going
to have to recess i believe there are
two votes
you'll be patient we appreciate that and
we'll be back five minutes after the
second vote
we'll continue with the waco
investigation in a moment but first some
program information
sunday night on book notes
in 1979 newt gingrich was a freshman on
capitol hill
this weekend the house speaker talks
about the people in his political career
joe gaylord is a remarkable
student of american politics who was the
iowa state republican party executive
director then he came to the republican
national committee and was the state the
national director for state legislatures
in 1980 when we picked up 700 seats then
he went to the congressional campaign
committee and ultimately became the
director of it
and was in charge of designing the 84 86
and 88 campaigns and then became a
consultant he is one of my closest
personal friends and he is a
man whose judgment i regard as
extraordinarily good overall i mean just
has a remarkable ability uh to to know
what not to do and to know where the
land mines are in american politics
in uh june of last year he wrote a paper
that described 231 seats 224 by winning
and seven by switching we ended up at
230 by winning and now two by switching
so we're one ahead of his goal uh we
then executed that paper and in
september and i think it's september
17th or 18th in the book
we got on an airplane and we're going to
have a planning meeting and i said are
we planning for speaker or for minority
leader and he just said very bluntly you
better be planning for speaker because
that's what you're going to be
speaker of the house newt gingrich in
his book to renew america on the next
book notes sunday night at eight eastern
and pacific time
we now continue with the waco
investigation
the first day of hearings before house
joint subcommittee
chairing the hearing republican bill
zelloff of new hampshire and republican
bill mccallum of florida
sub committees will come to order
uh the gentleman from oklahoma mr
brewster has 15 minutes
thank you mr chairman
as one who happens to believe that uh
atf and fbi do an awful lot right
uh probably 90 95 percent of your cases
uh are never heard of by the media or by
the average american
my main interest in this is trying to
figure out uh
what went wrong in the deal
i think that
some of my colleagues here are
attempting to play a role i can assure
you i'm playing no role i want to know
as much as i can about the information
and hopefully we can do some things
differently next time so we don't ever
again have a repeat
of of waco
uh
mr dunnigan do i understand that
you contacted the national guard
concerning
possible use of helicopters
because there was a methamphetamine lab
on the premises
no sir um my first contact with
the national guard was for
uh aerial photography work
uh my initial memorandum made no mention
of a drug nexus i even instructed
one of the agents that made personal
contact with those representatives jose
viegra
to
make sure that he told them that at that
point we had no drug
information um
at a time later
we had learned
uh in fact it was within a couple of
days after that
the date of that particular memorandum
we learned that at some time in the past
that a
disassembled methamphetamine laboratory
had been seen by one of the branch
davidians who left
who was away from the compound
and
that
a statement was made by
vernon howe
that
he had called the sheriff's office and
had abandoned that
methamphetamine lab
facility to them
um
the
there was a the person telling us the
story said
they never saw that abandonment take
place we checked with the sheriff's
office they had never received a
methamphetamine lab
from anyone from the compound and that's
how that came about
okay
who was first contacted by the deputy
sheriff you mr aguilera
yes sir i was is it common to be
contacted by a deputy sheriff as opposed
to the sheriff or undersheriff
well actually sir
the information was given to me on paper
by special agent charles meyer out of
the austin office
okay who in turn received the
information from lieutenant barber
but is it common do any of you have you
ever been contacted by a deputy sheriff
as opposed to the sheriff
sure
yes sir it is common
we i guess
i'm thinking back to oklahoma where we
had a sheriff that a deputy attempted to
frame with the fbi a couple of years ago
uh
at any rate
were all of you involved are any of you
involved in the decision on dynamic
entry
you're the top ranking man mr hartnett
are you not
yes sir i was advised
you were involved in the decision on
dynamic injury
i approve the plan which
the term dynamic entry i really don't
know a a good definition for it nor do i
but the raid plan yes sir i am the
person who approved it
what about the rest of you did you have
any involvement in making helping make
the decision on the way that uh we
addressed the problem there
you talked as far as the dynamic entry
or
yes it well there was really a panel of
several
um sacks which are special agents in
charge several assistant special agents
in charge
several of our srt team leaders
which
discuss the various options or whatever
and came to the conclusion to do the
dynamic entry
i have to be one who's convinced myself
at least that mr karesh was a bad guy
i am convinced that he had altered some
weapons
from the testimony we've heard certainly
have to believe there were some child
abuse cases and some others
but it's hard for me to understand
how you arrived at the decision of
dynamic entry
isn't it true that mr karesh went to
town on a fairly regular basis
he'd been there on several occasions one
thing that has been
misunderstood i think for for the last
couple years is
during this investigation
we determined that at the compound
machine guns were being manufactured in
explosive devices
our goal through this investigation was
to
execute a search warrant on that house
to obtain those illegal weapons other
people were involved in the manufacture
and possession of those
the arresting
of karish was just a side issue if we
arrested him we still had to do the
search warrant on the house
as you know it turned out there was
machine guns in hand and that was our
goal we knew that machine guns were
being manufactured we had to get in into
there one way or another if we arrested
him off we still had to do the search
warrant so a lot of people have felt you
know the whole thing was to arrest david
crease that was not our goal
but was there anyone else anywhere in
the group that had the charisma the
leadership ability of a david koresh to
convince people who were engineers and
lawyers to follow him and some of the
crazy things that were done here
i mean there were several professional
people in there but he was very
charismatic and and they followed him so
is there any reason to believe that had
you arrested him it would have not been
fairly easy to do the rest of it
well there's two things that could
happen i mean they could if if we
arrested him he could have turned into a
martyr and then they would say they've
taken our leader here we have all these
machine guns and hand grenades he's
taught him for years you know the time
has come
and you could have lost a whole bunch of
people yes
yeah if i may mr rooser um
another point i'd like to make out here
is that uh
koresh was observed outside of the
compound on two occasions uh one was i
believe january 17th of 93 and the other
february 24th
of 93
which is what three days four days
before the rate
no sir
that was 17th uh
this was maybe weeks before the raid
the ravens are 28 the 28th february 28th
i'm sorry i thought you said february
24th i'm sorry february 24th yes sir so
that's four days before yes sir
and um i'm sorry i made a mistake here
but
we didn't actually obtain the warrant
and the warrant wasn't issued until
february 25th
but you started planning this clear back
about six months ago right and uh
actually the planning of the way i read
it started in december on the dynamic
entry the rate on the on the facility
we started planning it in december
but at that time we were planning for a
siege we were not planning to do a
dynamic entry
at what point did you determine to do
the dynamic entry
it was in january
and you brought
special response teams in right
well their team leaders came in and
that's why i said we had these meetings
for months that we went through and
basically you know we weighed the
options of the assault versus the siege
you know and we've got a lot of new
information that that kind of put us
over the hump but if we did a siege i
mean one thing as you've heard some of
the testimony today mass suicide
as we talked to everybody davey was on
the interviews we had our srt team
leaders go there was a big fear of
everybody that there would be mass
suicide
secondly
you know if we tried to do a siege we
knew that there was machine guns in
there we knew that there's hand grenades
that have a long time to prepare in
other words by doing a dynamic entry
they wouldn't have time to prepare we
knew that they had
supplies of food and water that could
last for a long time we knew it was a
long time
i think they had mres for three months
and you know what their own water well
we knew it would be a disruption to the
community
you know if you did that it'd be a
long-term financial commitment you know
krish is in control if you do a siege
you know he calls the shots you know we
were concerned about the sexual abuse
that this was going on that would
continue on we were concerned about the
destruction of evidence
you know that if they made those machine
guns if they made those hand grenades
and we said hey we're here as you know
to do a search warrant come out and they
don't come out they could take them
apart as quickly as
they put them in yeah and as it turned
out every one of these things happened
and that was one of the reasons we
switched from the siege to the miss
thurman when you have special response
teams uh in it generally in response to
people being heavily armed
they're very highly trained to end
individuals and we use them
as safety both for the people and for
and for the agents because they are
higher are they alarm themselves
pardon sir are the special response
teams well armed themselves yes there
they are what do you what's their
ordinary armament they'd have a not you
know their nine millimeter standard gun
and then an mp5 or you know maybe a
shotgun depending on where they were
going or what the specific you know so
what we've heard then about some of the
agents only having nine millimeter
sidearms is not correct
no
some of them only had nine millimeter
yeah i mean they have they have the
option each operation they kind of plan
out what they think they'll need or or
whatever some some that day we knew you
know obviously that there was women and
children and there was some expression
by some of the undercover agents that
we may have to get in a fist fight with
some people or whatever so some of them
were actually concerned that that they
didn't take a second gun that they
actually had there because if they got
into a fight they didn't want to be
trying to hold one gun or whatever if
if you're going into a well-armed
situation why would you not arm them
completely
to the best of uh anything possible
i mean that there were so many things to
consider here there was women and
children you know we knew that they were
they were separated we had you know
teams to fight it in different areas to
take care of that but you know you need
to have
you know
the weapons that that you need but we
didn't feel they would be armed at that
time or where where we would you know if
uh
if you staged this at three in the
morning
why would met have been a better time
for surprise than 10 in the morning the
men and women were separated 24 hours a
day
it wasn't a lot of light
inside the compound and normally we do
execute our warrants first thing in the
morning we're talking about eight or ten
agents going into a room
or a house or maybe there's four or five
people we estimated that there were 75
people in there we knew there was a
hundred plus members but they always you
know came and left and there wasn't a
solid number
we're sending 75 agents into a building
and you get inside going in different
directions it's dark one one round goes
off
and you know we had a real concern that
the women and children or whatever we
wouldn't see who shot where or whatever
and could turn into a tragic incident so
the more i listen the more i can't
understand why david koresh was not
arrested outside
uh you used flashbang grenades at the at
the start of it correct
the only um
there was no plan to just use them
when
upstairs which people have seen the
video on tv where there's the two rooms
where they're going into one of those
rooms was david karissa's bedroom the
other room was
his armory where they had the machine
guns the hand grenades in there they
were going to look to see if anybody's
in there before they can throw it they
have to make sure there's nothing
flammable where then they throw it in
and it's really just a distraction
device i mean it makes a loud noise and
it's a flash and the purpose of it it's
not to harm anybody or whatever but just
to stun them for a second so you can get
in and safely it's for their protection
and for the agent's protection it's not
an offensive
type of weapon ms hartnett uh there's a
rumor and surely it's unfounded
that the publicity person or public
relations person for atf had released
some kind of a press
uh communication the night before to
media around the country that something
big was going to come down in texas
yes and we heard that and and
the
person i believe her name was sharon
wheeler she's testified before
committees and and
she just did not give any information
out about waco texas at all
she was in um
she was in dallas
and she called um
called a reporter to ask if he was going
to be in or called two reporters i'm not
quite sure i don't recall but and said
are you going to be in we're going to
have something coming up in the next day
or two as i recall that's how it came
out she never mentioned waco why did she
do that
she wanted to be able to get a hold of
them
if there was a story and they recovered
these arms now these this all came up
after the fact that we heard this and it
came out at hearings before wouldn't it
be ample time after they were recovered
oh yes i mean
but what came out it didn't come out the
way
you know she was accused of calling him
and saying there's going to be that good
but when you've had four
federal employees killed
20 wounded
and a large number of civilians
that were killed in the process
i've got to think you're looking forward
to making some changes in the way that
you would do things in the future have
those changes been made to make sure
that a waco never happens again i'm
retired now
and uh you don't have to worry about
that anymore well i still worry about it
i understand i still worry about it i
worry about it every day of my life
uh
i think there are changes i see things
that that that happened at waco that
that we should have done differently
i think those agents are
within atf are some of the best equip
best trained most professional law
enforcement people in this country and
always have been and and i think always
will be
i think that their dedication you know
going in there that day they felt they
were well prepared and they felt they
were doing the right thing
and
we need to correct the things that went
wrong there and there were things that
went wrong particularly on the
helicopters uh it just occurred to me
that we're flying that day were they
national guard or were they army
national guard
did the governor give them permission to
use them or who had done that
how they come out of that j
joint
joint task 46
they were texas air national guard
yes sir
under the governor's direction
that's correct
so the governor had given permission to
use them yes sir
okay you mentioned too about the the
training of uh of your forces and i
understand they are well trained yet do
i understand that the army spent three
days uh or more
working with them as well
at fort hood
we had asked to use the facility down
there so that everyone knew where they
were going in the plan and the uh
the military actually gave advice on
things that they saw that they felt that
we should change or whatever
but
it was not
that we asked them
come and give us training it was we were
borrowing their facility
to use that to have a mock type
situation
so that there could be some training and
everybody be familiar where everybody
else was going during the raid
and you had approximately 100 uh batf
personnel there i think pretty close to
it
yes sir
it was like 80 actually down there fort
hood so you were expecting
problems bringing that large force in is
that correct
i i don't think we were we were
preparing for any event there was
in the plan
things that that took
it was so spread out the compound and so
large that we wanted to make sure that
we could separate and get those guns
separated before anybody could get to
them uh we wanted to make sure that we
would get the men before they go when
the element of surprise was lost who
made the decision to continue
the commander in charge of the raid and
that was well i don't know if the
commander knew that he lost the element
of surprise and that is chuck's here
did you know about the loss of the
illness surprise truck
first of all far is the the element
surprise it's it's been an issue that's
been also
popped around in the newspaper or
whatever for for years and there appears
that at some level there was an order
given
or someone told somebody you know not to
go if you lost the element surprise
let me see if i can understand this in
my mind
somebody goes up to the door knocks on
the door with a search warrant in their
hand
is there someone else standing there
with a weapon as well
in this particular incident yeah
i was not at the front door so i can't
but somebody
some atf agent goes to the front door
and knocks on it with a search warrant
in hand and says we're here to rest
david koresh
and search the building am i correct
right well they would say to execute a
search warrant believe this and there's
another guy standing here with a weapon
as the guy by himself
that i don't know i think sir at least
what i've been told is that that's who
uh
would like to
be kind of condensing and i will bring
it together quickly
i have been told that as our people came
up in front of the compound and were
disembarking that david korish was
standing in front of his front door
and outside outside
by the door and that two different
agents i believe it was two
called federal agents with a search
warrant
he stepped back inside and the agent who
was there in the front door or by the
front door was wounded the fire just
came right out and and shot the agents
now mr johnston was there at the trial
and heard all the testimony and and
could probably
but those agents were armed themselves
as well yes they were okay
thank you thank you
uh gentlemen from north carolina mr
heinemann for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to continue this line of
questioning but i see here that
uh
day two covers the planning of the raid
so i will i will restrict myself to the
intelligence gathering
prior to that
that meeting where the raid was planned
um i did read this book by mr noble
the uh the report of department of
treasury on the on the waco incident
and of course he'll be here on the fifth
fourth or fifth day to answer questions
but in that book
on page nine that indicates that the
treasury
department stated that they chose not to
try to lure
david koresh away from the compound
because intelligence reports
he really ventures off compound grounds
that's found on page nine
and certainly today we've we've heard
conflicting testimony from
from someone mr thibodeau from in the
compound
uh and i'd like to uh i'd like to
address to mr sarvin
or perhaps
the agent himself
as to when that when that house that
observation house was set up outside the
compound
the uh the house was started up in
january and some of the conflicting
reports
as far as what you're hearing on how
many times he he was off the
surveillance at the beginning was for 24
hours and then then it broke down to
where they were just basically doing it
from sunlight to
to late at night um
obviously there were several vehicles in
there that the surveillance house
actually i believe only saw him one time
leave as far as the agents observing him
leave there was cars going and come
obviously he could have been in a car
that they that they didn't see it
um there was also conversation with with
the undercover agent
that um
you know he
doesn't go off the compound he said he
was getting paranoid about law
enforcement or whatever so the
combination of the information we had at
the time was that we only observed him
the one time and what he had told the
undercover agent you know we didn't feel
that he was going off the off the couch
who was in charge of that house
but there were several agents there uh
dale littleton was actually just to
supervise the uh the undercover agent
and then
he was under earl and then earl would
report to me and then dale would also
call me with information directly well
where did that where did that flow of
information terminate did that stay with
you in the waco area or did it go no it
would you know after their reports would
be put on an atf form
3270.2 which it would come through earl
then it would come to me and this was
distributed to
all the sacs all the asa x all these
different srt team members so they got
all the information and then time that
we um had a plan as far as meeting in a
group of 15 or 20 to discuss both the
case and what what we were going to do
tactically dale would come and represent
the you know all the undercover agents
and give us a briefing on what was going
on what use did you make of the local
agencies either the texas rangers or the
sheriff's department relative to
intelligence
i spoke to
dps intelligence
and obtained information information
that i already had and secured
i requested information through
headquarters
most of the information that i had
or that they had i had already had them
provided with
so there wasn't much they could give me
other than what i had hey let me let me
at this point i pretty much
touched on what i want to touch on the
previous gentleman of course the owl
took some of what i was going to ask but
at this time i'd like to heal the
balance of my time to mr bar to continue
his line of questioning
i appreciate the gentleman from north
carolina
mr johnston following up uh just briefly
on our line of questioning earlier
and my concern over
uh destruction of evidence or
non-production of of evidence
uh there apparently was a was a
settlement uh agreement in the uh
winowski case
are you familiar with that
uh uh and the reason i'm asking is par
apparently the settlement documents
provided uh for destruction
of uh certain discovery files and i'm
wondering if you're aware of that
uh
wenoski had a uh i guess civil service
claim
is that right
i know nothing about that at all i guess
that's something that treasury handled
would that would that be unusual if
there is a
case handled not by the civil service
but by its successor agency the merit
system protection board
and as part of a settlement
in this case reinstatement with back pay
that
documents uh would be destroyed
including in this case apparently or
perhaps
documents uh relating to possible
wrongdoing would that be something that
would concern you as a as a government
attorney
if you're saying destroyed as in all in
all destroyed no copies well then that's
obviously concerning because you don't
have any and there's no evidence so i
don't
i guess i've never heard of that process
i hadn't either but then again i haven't
heard of the documents that i that i
showed you earlier but that that would
concern you as a prosecutor yes sir okay
thank you i appreciate the gentleman
from north carolina
gentleman's time has expired
the chair recognizes mr ehrlich the vice
chair of the subcommittee for five
minutes
i'd like to direct uh i have five
minutes so i'd appreciate
i'll try to frame my questions concisely
i appreciate concise answers mr aguilera
did any person in the supervisory chain
above you
ever ask you to gather information
with respect to the issue of arresting
koresh outside the compound
the
information i i didn't they didn't
request for me they obtained the
information to try and arrest uh courage
outside no no sir
okay
now earlier today mr mcmahon testified
that you specifically declined an offer
from quresh over the telephone
the heat wherein he allegedly said come
visit
i'll show you the guns
is that a true statement in fact that's
true that's a true statement uh however
the only reason i didn't want to talk to
koresh was because i had prior knowledge
and information
that koresh had dealings with mcmahon
and i wanted to further check his
records in order for me to find out
whether or not koresh was dealing
without a license
so you thought that offer was premature
at the time that's why you declined yes
sir yes sir it would have
been non-productive for my case for my
investigation
thank you
mr ceremony
my question to you sir is did you ever
have occasion
to draft a memo
wherein you suggest that koresh be
arrested outside the compound
i don't remember drafting a memo i do
know that we did consider it and and
tried two or three options to try to do
that but i don't remember drafting a
memo so your recollection is you did not
actually
draft the memo but
is it your record i don't put words in
your mouth is your recollection that you
you remember observing or what we
consider the memo we we considered and
actually tried to do a couple things
where we could arrest them off
but i don't remember or recall preparing
any memo
and there came a point in time where
that option was rejected correct
we actually
one of them was to go through the health
and human services where they would call
him off
and say you know we want to talk to you
or whatever and
we went and talked to them and they said
well he doesn't show up for three or
four days and we couldn't plan when and
which i tried to explain earlier no
matter where
or when we arrested karish we still had
to do a search warrant on the compound
and we knew that would involve a lot of
people so you know like with the health
and huma they declined it at the end but
had we done that you know we couldn't
have sat around with with a hundred
agents for five days till he showed up
because we still had to execute the
search warrant on his house
sir is it fair to say that at some point
in time you change your mind with with
respect to
the uh appropriateness of arresting
koresh outside the compound
yeah i would say
when i'm talking of of our decision so
there's a group here of about 15 or 20
people that would discuss this you know
at various times on what and yes we did
did change he was from the undercover
and we had as davey got information some
of the people that had left the compound
still had people on the compound or
whatever and and the sense was that you
know he was getting you know very
paranoid and not trusting his own people
or whatever
thank you
mr hardin
uh two questions real briefly
is it your testimony sir that the
element of surprise was lost prior to
the raid on february 28th
i have of course heard the element of
surprise since the day after the raid is
there
prior to that time i never heard the
term element of surprise
the
whether or not that
and mr hanowski of course is was the
sack in houston
and i've asked him
many times since the raid
did you feel the raid was compromised
when you went in
and he has said no to this day
and i believe him
thank you sir sir earlier you testified
that
mistakes were made in the remaining time
that we have
and i realize it's very easy has been
repeated many times here tonight it's
very easy being a monday morning
quarterback
what would you have done differently
in retrospect
there was a when the undercover agent
came out of the
uh
compound and met with uh well
i thought he was going to meet with
chuck serbian when i was briefed
he was going to come out
and
let chuck know the status after the waco
trib had come out were they going were
they getting out guns were they going to
battle stations that type of thing
at the time of the briefing
i never asked the question as to how
they were communicating they
communicated by phone
the most important conversation we had
in this entire raid took place over the
telephone between the undercover agent
and mr sarabin i didn't ask the question
at the time the plan was given to me
if i had of or if i thought of it
that would never have happened
they would have met in person they would
discuss what they saw there would have
been no communications gap between
what the undercover agent saw and felt
and what chuck was thinking
that to me was was a serious mistake
and
and i didn't catch it at the time
i know our time
are you finished your answer sir yes sir
thank you
mr uh taylor from mississippi
five minutes
thank you mr chairman mr
aggie letter is that right aguilera yes
sir i'm sorry
all right
in page 19
of this it talks about your conversation
with deputy barber who unfortunately has
already left us
his predecessor
preacher he replaced at gunpoint
do you feel like there was adequate
evidence given to you by mr barbara that
this actually took place
that he ran off the previous preacher at
gunpoint actually shot at him that he
was found behind hiding behind a tree
well yes sir i read the report
you believe that to be true
yes sir did that influence your decision
on how you were to serve this warrant
the fact that this man had been shown
to have violent tendencies and the use
of firearms even against another
preacher i had no uh
i didn't partake in the planning of the
raid or the execution of the warrant
did that influence your decision
or the decision do you feel like i'm
okay i
let me let me go a little bit farther to
page 27.
again
the these are statements attributed to
you but not direct quotes
it says aggie letters sought information
from former cult members who gave him
some insight into the extraordinary
degree to which quest dominated the
lives of compound residents
cult members surrendered all their
assets to koresh and permitted him to
have sex with all female members of the
cult
while caress while reports that quresh
was permitted to
sexually and physically abused children
were not evidence that firearms or
explosives violations were occurring
they showed koresh to have set up a
world of his own
where legal prohibitions were discarded
freely
do you believe that to be an accurate
state
according or from the information that i
had received from former members
it was
placed in my probable cause
the affidavit yes
do you think that in fairness to the
four officers who lost their lives and
the 20 officers who were wounded
in fairness to their widows and fairness
to the two children who will not now
have a father
that maybe some of these things ought to
be brought to the attention of this
committee and do you think that in
fairness to those people
this
series that was about to be printed in
the waco tribune has since been created
should be entered into the record
yes sure
don't you think that in fairness to the
atf agents that you should be treated
same as every criminal
and that at least you're given the
presumption that you're innocent until
proven guilty
that we should be treated as criminals
no sir i think that you can be treated
at least as well as the criminals in
this country and given the presumption
that you're innocent until proven guilty
and given the opportunity to prove
yourself innocent don't you think it
would be fair for this committee to do
that
and don't you think it would help your
case if you were able to talk about the
events that led up to the raid
yes sir okay
my
final points i'd like to make is
after talking to deputy bob
at some point in those conversations did
he request or did a member of the
sheriff's department
request the help of the atf or did the
atf just on their own decide they were
going to descend upon waco texas pick on
some poor country preacher
i did the complete investigation on my
own
i didn't request any assistance from the
sheriff's office except for the
intelligence said i had been receiving
from them the question was the other way
around did the sheriff's department at
some point request your help yes sir
they did initially so you did not just
pick waco off the map of the united
states and decide that you would go down
there also requested by a local
governing authority
the law enforcement authority
come down and help yes sir
do you think that ought to be included
in the record
and yes sir in the raid well don't you
think we ought to talk about the events
that led up yes sir sure people will
know that yes sir because i can assure
you there are a heck of a lot of people
in this country who think that y'all
just picked that town in that preacher
and i don't think that's fair to the
four men who died no certainty i don't
think it's fair to the 20 men who got
wounded no sir
is there anything else you'd like to say
mr aguilar
no sir okay thank you very much mr chair
thank you gentlemen's time has expired
mrs
mrs laughlin of california you have five
minutes
thank you mr chairman dr
perry i've read through all of the
material you've
provided about the
evaluation of the children who were
evacuated by yourself and the team and
also the
transcript of of your transmittal i
think of march 11th if i'm reading the
debate correctly to the fbi where you
recount
the status of the children can you
tell this committee what your impression
was about the level of
sexual molestation going on in the
compound after you had examined these
children as well as what information you
had gathered from them about explosive
materials weapons and things of that
nature and what of that did you transmit
to the fbi we
within the first week after working with
these children
a variety of ways it became clear that
there were two primary areas of secret
that they wanted to keep from the
babylonians the non-believers who we
were
in their minds
these included
uh over time as these kids slowly
revealed in a variety of ways what these
were they included two major themes one
was that there was uh this
and they had been told that people would
not understand this this
uh this special relationship that they
were going to have with david and of
course they were writing the sexuality
the fact that sex was openly talked
about that young children were exposed
to inappropriate sexual content and that
by the age of 12
all children were considered adults and
all girls were therefore available to
david for his wife as we heard today
obviously the age of 12 is pushing the
limit he clearly
partook
his pleasures and younger children as
well
at that time it was also clear that
these kids looked at us with smugness
and said well you'll see what'll happen
and you don't know what's going to
happen and
could i specifically ask a question on
because i wasn't very direct on the
second page of your memorandum you talk
about one
child that the children knew beyond what
their years would indicate about weapons
and one young boy in particular
discussing his grenade the grenade
launcher
was that these children knew
a lot more about guns
than you would expect for children this
age children as young as six years old
would pick up a toy wooden gun pull the
bolt back
weigh it as if
getting the balance looked on the barrel
and say this isn't a real gun
could i ask mr johnson were you aware of
this information about
the evidence and the children as to
weapons and possible violations when the
when you reviewed the information
seeking the warrant
there was some information joyce sparks
spoke with a young child that said i
can't wait until i'm a man something of
that nature and she said why and he said
because then i'll get a long gun and
once again that and of itself uh long
gun may not mean a machine gun but it
indicated the kids had knowledge of guns
um as far as the question concerning
sexual abuse the kiri jewel story we
didn't know let me ask finally and then
i want to yield to mr scott uh
mr cereben you mentioned that you were
aware uh that there was a sexual abuse
um going on in the compound as you were
readying for uh
the final days
um
i wonder if um
you could uh tell me we all you take an
oath to uphold the law and the law that
you're
upholding is to enforce alcohol tobacco
and firearms but as a law enforcement
officer was it in your mind
that little girls were being raped
inside the walls of this compound while
while you were and the rest were waiting
to execute this war was that a factor in
timing it
even subconsciously as a law enforcement
officer as a human being it was inside
of you i heard the testimony earlier
today and
as we interviewed these people and and
we heard those stories i mean we we had
talked to her before so and you i i
guess had seen this the sinful
uh
messiah story mr mr chairman i wonder if
we could ask unanimous consent to put
this news article in the record
it's the sinful messiah from the waco
tribune herald that's been referenced
several times
is it
reserving the right to object
is this a um
this is an article that appeared before
the raid on the uh
on the compound
does it mention anything about firearms
violation
i think it talks about the the
sexual abuse that i think was in the
minds of the agents and as human beings
and law enforcement officers was a
factor and an understandable one if i'm
hearing mr serbin correctly as to timing
well continuing my reservation
do the agents have any anything in
writing any memos
from this particular time that
demonstrate that because of
alleged sexual abuse that motivated
their thinking about the planning of
this firearms law enforcement rate this
is the first i've heard
of all of this
i yield gentleman from new york i thank
the gentleman this article which
occurred the day before the raid which
was published by the waco whatever
herald something
tribute herald
um which was published the day before
the raid plays a very important role in
what happened
in a variety of ways if you read the
report of atf there's a whole chapter on
it because
and this is an important question we
will deal with today and tomorrow
one of the
the timing of the re the the uh atf
people went to the waco
herald tribune
tribune herald and asked them to not run
the article when they decided they would
run the article they moved the day up it
may account for some of the speed with
which the raid went i think any of the
gentlemen who were involved will back me
up that this was an extremely important
article in terms of what happened and by
all means it should be in the record
whether it mentioned firearms or not
what is also important here is what atf
thought correctly or incorrectly and we
can debate that
is that the publication of the article
would influence koresh's state of mind
and that was an important factor in
determining
when
and how to do the raid with reclaiming
my time
i understand the gentleman's point
but continuing my reservation for the
moment i've asked two questions i would
be grateful if the person
offering this into the record or one of
the witnesses and clarify it my first
question very simply is does that
article have anything to do with
firearms violations
i think it does yes
the second is
with respect to the the references in
that article to sexual abuse and now the
testimony that because of this
uh uh sexual abuse that motivated the uh
atf to have to do this rate all the
faster i have one if i may interrupt i
don't think that was the testimony that
was not my i'm sorry i did not mean i
did not mean to alter your testimony i
i'll let you phrase it it's getting kind
of late for all of us so i apologize if
i've misstated the article
faced or made us move the the raid up
okay
she asked me as a person
did i have a feeling that i knew that
sexual
assaults or rapes were going on in the
compound did that affect me as a human
being i said yes as a law enforcement
officer or whatever i had a feeling
about that as a law enforcement officer
do you have anything in writing
from right before the raid that
indicated the raid had to take place in
a certain way in a certain speed because
of your concern as a human being about
child sexual abuse no thank you um
i think i've made my points mr chairman
about the documents i think the points
have been made in its favor we've been
letting in about everything to be fair
so i will withdraw my res my reservation
without objection so ordered to be
entered into testimony
uh you mrs laughlin you have two minutes
left uh thank you mr chairman at this
point i would like to yield the balance
of my time to mr scott
thank you
and thank a lady from
from california
excuse me
mr mr johnston
have you ever gotten evidence in court
under the good faith exception to the to
the exclusionary rule
i have uh had a judge rule in the
alternative that evans would be
admissible under that
say that again
in other words i've had courts rule that
there was probable cause but if the
appellate court were to find not then
the agent had good faith in relying on
it in other words an alternative finding
but i don't think i've had to rely
entirely on have you had evidence
excluded
from court because it had been illegally
obtained
no sir
do you know of any evidence that's been
offered
in your jurisdiction where the evidence
was found to be illegally obtained and
was excluded
i don't recall any in the waco division
the western district of texas is huge
i'm sure there has been somewhere but
not not in our division
that i recall let me ask mr
aguilera
do you have any problem obeying the law
sir you have any problem obeying the law
no sir
um
are you aware of any officer who's been
sanctioned for illegally obtaining
evidence
no sir
so the exclusionary rule is about the
only sanction we have against officers
violating the law
i'm not the evidence if you if you
illegally obtain evidence and it's not
admissible in court that's about the
only sanction
you've heard for illegally obtaining
evidence yes sir
and it's the only sanction we have the
only protection we have against law
enforcement officers breaking the law
yes sir thank you
thank you
uh i yield chair yields to the gentleman
from arizona mr
mr chairman shattuck before i start my
question let me make a couple of
statements i uh spent eight years as a
prosecutor or eight years of the arizona
attorney general's office i i apologize
i
got two people talking my ear uh by
prior arrangement we
can i just hold you up for a second
certainly can we shift back over to
jackson lee of texas
thank you very much mr chairman i would
like mr chairman if i could raise a
question with the chair
so that my questions will be understood
by the witnesses i want to ask questions
and i will ask the witnesses to give me
yes or no answers i want to make it
clear that i'm not in any way trying to
limit their response as much as i'm
trying to get a number of questions in
and i want to make and clarify my uh my
particular questions
and let me also mr chairman for my time
starts i see that it has i was asking
you to allow me to do that before my
time starts uh to thank carter collins
on the record
for yielding time to me previously
mr um
malton
you've
had to be
exceedingly quiet over there and so let
me try to
call from you some of the concerns that
i have
it seems that little
carrie jewell said it all when she was
trying to
suggest that a lot of people were trying
to get things out of this and we just
need to fix it
i hope that if we can all eliminate the
garments of hypocrisy that that is what
we are trying to do is to fix it
so as my understanding that there was an
investigation that proceeded
for how long mr moulton uh approximately
five months
investigation conducted by the treasury
department
can you tell me what this book is mr
moulton that's that is the treasury
department report issued in september
1993 that addresses
virtually all if not all the questions
that have been discussed today i'm sorry
i'll do my best to say yes or no that's
all right did you participate in this
inquiry yes i was the project director
of that investigation
in the course of trying to review
extensively
uh what occurred in this tragedy loss of
lives of adults and children
loss of lives of our law enforcement
officers
i want to get right to the point of
focusing on
corrective measures
in this document
is there a corrective measure that says
let us eliminate
um a portion of the exclusionary rule
meaning that
search warrants
are not good anymore let's base them all
on good faith is that is that in this
day there is no suggestion of alteration
of the exclusionary rule in the document
so that worked for you in terms of this
document that's correct
we had a problem as we've heard from the
witness testify in
a point when there was no retreat
this is a point when we heard possibly
that someone tipped the media
in this report do you have
at least a suggestion of some
intervening factor or line authority
that would have given the opportunity
for fair analysis so that a possible
retreat could have occurred therefore
saving lives
the report discusses the importance of
an operation like this being reviewed at
the treasury department substantially in
advance of the raid rather than 48 hours
before the rate as was the case here
one of the things that i heard also
mention because the american people need
to know we hold of high regard this
whole idea of religion
and respect for people's differences
i've heard the seventh-day adventist
church being mentioned
and i would wonder in this particular
document for it is quite distinguishable
from a religion and a cult
do we have in this document any um
suggestion of further training or
enhanced training for our law
enforcement agencies about cults
that the document addresses the need for
law enforcement agencies to consult
experts in
organizations or groups like the branch
davidian uh before they conduct or in
order to evaluate the information uh
that they're being given by members of
the cult and by others
you think cults are different from
religion yeah i think that i think that
dr perry expressed
the difference quite well earlier
mr chairman i have a joint statement of
mr rosedale president american family
foundations and william ryland president
cult awareness network and you had
indicated to me mr chairman i hope i can
have a moment where the clock is
stopping that we would be open to
potentially having witnesses come in and
talk about issues that have
long-standing impact on our ability to
reform i'd like this statement submitted
for the record but i'd like the
opportunity to raise with the committee
possibility of a cult expert coming in
and testifying chairman i ask unanimous
consent
with that
right to object the document is what i
asked generally on behalf it's a joint
statement of uh the president of the
american family foundation and the
president of the cult awareness network
it is relevant mr schiff and i
appreciate your inquiry um because uh
one of the suggestions was
that
our law enforcement agencies in terms of
reform and correction needed additional
training in cult awareness
uh for they may come upon these kinds of
groups across the nation in the course
that played into the tragedy that
occurred and this document is simply a
report on cults and it also addresses
the particular incident in waco
continuing my reservation uh first i
believe that mr perry is on the board of
this organization and he's been a
witness here at this proceedings
he did not get the opportunity to
give all his testimony
no mr perry i don't think that's dr
perry
correct
that's dr perry and i'm not on the board
of i'm on a research advisory board for
the american family foundation which is
comprised of six academics or seven
academics
that's not
that's the extent of my relationship
with those organizations
well continuing my reservation i if i
could just ask
uh does the lady offer is the lady
offering this document
does that mean that we are committed to
the idea that the branch davidian group
was a cult
i offer it in that i don't offer that
capacity at all if i offer it as an
explanatory document not in all i don't
think it's a truth it's a veracity
question
i withdraw my reservation
as far as the admission in the record uh
without objection so ordered as far as a
potential witness uh as we talked about
earlier would certainly be willing to
consider it
mr chairman i wonder because
that we just had whether i can the red
light is on but uh you have 30 seconds
left regardless of what the red light
says
let me just ask uh mr moulton was there
a cover-up absolutely not let me go
quickly to mr owens uh not not by the
treasure i'm sorry not by the treasury
department in the preparation of that
report absolutely not let me ask mr owen
so that my question can be out and you
can answer the question if you would go
again to one of the weapons there that
the gentleman were kind to bring i
simply need you to point to a weapon
that could be converted was there a
weapon in that group that could have
been converted or was a product of being
converted is there anything in that yes
ma'am could you show me that quickly sir
miss owens i thank you very much
and would you explain whether that was
found in the compound
this one has been converted i believe it
was found in the vehicle
i'm told you can't be heard is that i'm
sorry sir maybe you need to
this particular weapon has been
converted
it's a
semi-automatic aks type rifle that's
been modified i believe this weapon was
recovered from a vehicle located in
front of the compound
thank you very much mr chairman
thank you
i would just like to make a comment uh
on behalf of our side as far as these
weapons are concerned we tried at great
length to
try to have access to those weapons and
received a letter dated july 11th from
mr kent marcus principal deputy
assistant attorney general
u.s department of justice saying
uh comments that this will cost the
taxpayers of the state of texas and the
united states many thousands of dollars
we just would have enjoyed the
opportunity to have worked uh with both
sides here to examine those weapons as
well
and uh i think it would have been
helpful i just make that statement uh
yield to the gentleman from arizona
as i understand it a letter was sent
offering
that same letter offering your ability
to examine the weapons the problem was
as i understand it two-fold one of
course failure analysis
whatever their last initial is but which
is in great dispute now but secondly
they just didn't want to break the chain
of
forget what the legal term is
custody because these weapons still are
part of a legal process ongoing just
because of the interest in terms of
getting at the evidence
could i ask the question of how much did
it cost to just bring those weapons up
because it would have been helpful for
our side as well
anybody have any idea this the ballpark
mr
mr chairman just a question wouldn't
that be possible to to uh these weapons
are now here
uh and i i just heard some conflicting
things first i i heard that this was
recovered in the compound and then the
gentleman just testified that
the the weapon he held up was in a
vehicle in front of the compound
uh and then the other one is sort of
charred
and i'm not a weapons expert i've never
even held one of those weapons isn't it
possible now to turn those over
temporarily to the committee and have
someone independently look i think one i
think if i could make a comment exercise
in progress of the chair i think what we
tried to do
uh is to get a third party uh or at
least get get justice department to
x-ray these weapons make information
available to all of us to determine
which which weapons were altered
and you know you have a serious heat
problem in a fire
certain materials do get melted down and
so what we were looking for is to bring
in an expert on a third-party basis to
look at it or at least get uh all of us
involved in the process so we can
examine the evidence because i think
it's an important piece of evidence to
consider
for a very brief
and the problem is justice rates back
because the process required will be
expensive cumbersome and difficult and
of little or no
evidentiary value to the public whom
he's both served we recommend against
the procedure which you have requested
and
besides that it would cost the taxpayers
the state of texas the united states
many thousands of dollars and then we
see the evidence presented here
clarification
mr owen said the weapon had been
modified
modified to do what machine gun
thank you mr modified by whom
i have no idea i guess we don't either
again which weapon are they referring to
one is charred the other weapon he said
was found in a vehicle in front of the
compound
again we have these weapons here and i
see no reason why we can't
have an independent responsible
authority look at the weapons and make a
determination for the benefit of the two
subcommittees
i think at this point we need to move on
well i just i mean there are a couple of
points unanswered here number one they
were found as i heard mr owen say on a
vehicle in front of the building which
is part of the compound the compound is
not just the building but it's the
surrounding area it was indeed on the
compound if you read any of the
literature that's what the compound is
referred to
second to hand over the weapons
whether it be
to this committee
or to a third and third group
the majority ask that failure analysis
paid for by the nra hardly an impartial
source do it and ridiculous suggestions
about the department of justice
to hand it over to any
any
third party would break the chain of
custody and ruin the cases now if you
want to try to sit down and work
something out that's fine finally the
letter that you requested didn't request
two weapons
but requested all the weapons be flown
up here and done that is much more
expensive than a few now that we know
that it can be done maybe that's an
issue for another day i'd like to uh now
the chair now recognizes uh gentleman
from arizona mr chairman
mr chairman
i i the point of the your discussion
came out of my
questioning and i just like the
clarification i'll say it to you um i
think mr owen may not have completed his
answer to the extent
uh that
the question
was
calling for him to answer whether there
were devices um
on the property on the compound or
inside the facilities that could modify
to a fully automatic i'd assume he
didn't complete his answer on that
um that there were device modification
um equipment to modify to a fully
automatic on the premises is that my
understanding
i cannot testify to that ma'am you're
not familiar with that no ma'am thank
chair would like to now recognize mr
shattuck from arizona five minutes
thank you very much let me resume where
i was i've spent a good deal of my
career defending law enforcement i come
to these hearings with mixed emotions
i'm not here to assess blame or to point
guilt my goal isn't political it's not
to point at the administration but there
is an important goal that goes on here
today first of all i'm pleased to see my
colleagues on the other side defending
law enforcement because i find
historically they don't do that but i
think it's occasionally important i
object to that statement i think it's
important that that is
i think it's important that we answer
some questions here
the questions the questions
statement chairman i think i think what
he was doing
i know the evening's getting late you
probably didn't hear it he's trying to
compliment you i think that's the way he
intended it no let's move forward mr
shattuck i think the point funny remark
mr chairman that's an arrogant
denunciation of those of us on this side
of the eye
committee come to order we are hold an
apology committee come to order mr
shattuck please proceed thank you mr
chairman um seems to me the goal of
these hearings is to try to enable the
american people to have faith in law
enforcement at the federal level once
again regrettably
this particular incident has eaten away
at their faith in law enforcement it
seems we can achieve that goal by doing
one of two things one ascertaining what
mistakes were made if any and two
ascertaining whether or not corrective
measures have already been taken to
correct those mistakes i think we've
spent the day focusing on all kinds of
issues that are not issues for example
whether or not mr koresh was a gross
base human being who had no business
being in the position he was in and no
business being able to access children
as he did that is not i don't believe
the issue here but i would like to get
to some of the issues that i think are
important for the american people
because it's my goal to rehabilitate
their faith in law enforcement because
if they have no faith in law enforcement
we don't have an ordered society let me
in that regard begin with you mr
aguilera first as i understand your
testimony it is that you were offered by
mr quresh and you understood you've been
offered by mr crash an opportunity to
come and look at the weapons that he had
in his or weapons or parts of weapons
that he had in his possession
uh mr mcmahon had telephonically
contacted koresh and he asked me to come
to the phone
and uh just just well i've got very
little time did you understand and you
would i think you believe you said you
did did you understand that you were
being offered an opportunity to go look
at those weapons yes sir okay now i
would understand why as a law
enforcement officer you would not want
to take that up at that particular
moment in time my question of you is did
you later take that offer up
no sir did you ever take that offer up
no sir did you tell your supervisor
specifically mister sarah banya that
you'd been offered a chance to go into
the corrupt compound at mr crush's
invitation and to look at the weapons
yes sir it's been in my reports you told
mr saramania that
whether he read the reports or not i
don't know but uh they were in my
reports
okay mr sarah banya
were you aware when you planned the
dynamic raid that one of your agents had
been offered an opportunity to go in and
look at the weapons and see what was
there yes it was sir
and and mr aguilera never went did some
other agent from atf go
no
i think mr sarah banya went no is there
a reason why no one ever went
we discussed this as i said when we had
this committee of people planning the
raid that was one of our options that we
considered why don't we try
to call the dealer and you know
then see if we can get krish off that
way but from all the intelligence we
were getting at that time
when we started this investigation
everything we were told there was armed
guards
and at one time there was there was a
guard house or whatever but things had
changed from from the information that
we were getting back from people still
in the compound that he was now paranoid
of his people that the guns were put up
we didn't want to alert him by you know
going
second time talking about guns and then
he might put the arm guards up and go
back to the way he was before i'm
absolutely baffled that when he had this
standing offer for you to be able to go
and look at these weapons you chose
never to call him back and take that
offer up and find out what was in there
and and why you would not do that and
still plan a dynamic raid is beyond me
um
i mean i i guess i'm trying to
understand why the dynamic raid was
necessary when he had a standing offer
that
that you can come in and look at those
weapons i said the panel considered this
we we talked about it we just thought it
would put him on an offensive mode and
go back to having arm guard you now wish
you'd gone back in and at least taken a
look at the weapons uh tried to take him
up on his offer
we could have yeah yeah okay
um i'm a little puzzled about the whole
uh timing and sequence of the uh actual
entry itself uh you i understand mr
cerebeno were in charge of the actual
raid the day it occurred is that right
my title was the tactical coordinator i
was the head of the srt teams i was
puzzled earlier and i understood that
you did not know and couldn't answer mr
brewster's questions about how many
agents went to the door
tell me that isn't true i assume you
knew how many agents went to the door no
i don't know the specific number that
went the door it was broken into six
different teams
and we had several teams making entry in
the front door three teams that were
going around but i mean i could find
some list and give you the specific
number but i do not know it off the top
of my head but you had overall supervise
the authority for
the entire race i was like the tactical
coordinator and then each
member under me was responsible for his
own team
okay and those were the teams that would
be making you know interesting can you
give the american people any definitive
answer on the question of whether or not
agents fired from the helicopters and
whether or not they fired before or
after uh mr people from the compound
fired uh uh themselves
i was in one of the helicopters no
nobody
shot from the helicopters to the
compound well you were in one of the
helicopters i guess i was asking mr
ceravania because he's in charge of the
whole raid what what can we tell the
american people on the issue of whether
or not
armed federal agents fired first or
didn't file first
we didn't fire first according to
the testimony during the trial
when they were getting out of the cattle
carts they fired upon us i'm a little i
mean i appreciate that i still was
asking mr sarah band because he was in
charge of the raid and i guess if he
doesn't know how many agents were at the
door i'm troubled with how he now knows
whether or not we fired first and and
i was in the first vehicle pulling up on
a compound we had two vehicles we don't
have a picture right now but went down a
250 yard driveway
and then we made a left-hand turn i was
in the first vehicle and i went in front
of the compound and actually stopped
at the end of the compound the second
vehicle
stopped at the front door
before i opened my door to get out we
were being fired on
from the compounds i i was going to the
front door but i never got but a few
feet from when they began to fire at us
so that's why consequently i do not know
what happened at the front door i would
deeply like to believe that we didn't
fire first could i if i could just one
follow-up question did you with regard
to this issue of child molestation which
has been a major issue today and i think
a major distraction did you ever contact
the texas law enforcement authorities
and who would have had jurisdiction over
that you clearly did not did you ever
contact texas law enforcement
authorities who would have had
jurisdiction over child molestation or
statutory rape and invite them to
participate in the raid
no sir i didn't invite them to
participate in the raid however i did
have conversations with the district
attorney there to pursue state charges
on child molestation
and and were they invited to be involved
at all other than no sir
uh gentlemen thank you
um i'm going to do my five minutes and
then we're going to have to recess do a
vote and come back believe it or not
we do this every once in a while it just
happens to coincide with a hearing so
thank you for your patience i passed out
or i'd like to clerk to pass out
document number three
and my questions
i'll start with mr hartnick document
number three says the raid was approved
by the bureau headquarters honor between
two 1193 or so
i know the special agent in charge
ceremony in aquilera met with
high-ranking bureau officials prior to
the raid were you one of those officials
yes sir i was you were
and uh the raid was approved in
washington by high-ranking bureau
officials honored near february 11th
1995 1993.
uh did you approve that on or near that
date yes sir i did he did
and do you know whether or not uh when
it was approved uh it was said to halt
the rate if the element surprise was
lost
i never heard the term element of
surprise now
let me say that surprise was a part of
the plan but
nothing was ever said about the other
the document also says several pages of
surveillance log had been torn out have
you ever heard that before
no sir i hadn't who's responsible for
safekeeping in the surveillance log
uh
littleton i believe excuse me littleton
i believe was a supervisor
at the surveillance
uh
house um
i just never heard that before but but
pages were removed i mean i never heard
that before the pages were removed
okay but you might want to refer to that
the
document number three that we we handed
you
we just like we have a copy of the
document we don't know what it is
it just has a lot of writing on it is it
a note from who to who
okay this is part of the 13 000 pieces
of loose paper the treasury gave us that
was
was unorganized
uh and we were trying to piece it
together but we but we're we think it's
pertinent it certainly involves
well it refers to mr higgins
refers to i mean i think it's very
pertinent
but we i just wanted i'm not trying to
post
who wrote it okay we don't know it's a
post-raid interview with one of their
agents and what i'm asking is the
gentleman that was in charge if he could
shed some light
it says there's markings on the
left-hand side agent john bryant
dallas is about all we can figure out
with the same concerns you do
where were we
were you mr hartnick
about ready to answer
i'm sorry sir i just you mentioned that
notes were torn out of the surveillance
log i was just wondering how does that
happen
i don't know sir i had never heard that
before or i don't recall we're hearing
it before do you know if it was true no
sir i don't okay
so so this may or may not apply then the
interview with the unnamed agent also
says quote personal knowledge that the
surveillance notes for the atf were poor
and incomplete do you have any reason to
believe that the agent being interviewed
is not telling the truth
i know i
why aren't you letting him answer i mean
i know you're good but
so was he
i i don't think i understand
what you're asking i i guess i guess
you know that this is an interview with
one of your agents and
i'm just trying to
get out if the fact that if these logs
get changed or tampered with or pages
get pulled out i'm just wondering if you
know anything about that no sir i don't
uh halfway down the atf's agent's
interview this document says statements
that the atf was outgunned was true
mr hartnick had uh prior
to the raid uh mandated that
uh we all turn in our ar-15s even though
several uh iraq's
racs
uh voiced their complaints um
mr hartnick is that true did you mandate
that the agents turn in their ar-15s and
what is an ar-15
so were these agents knowingly outdone
before they started why did you have
them turned into ar-15s
we were in the midst of
first of all they had all the ar-15s
that they wanted in their raid plan i
think the number
as i recall and i could be wrong was
eight
but what was taking place at the same
time was that we were converting from
the ar-15 to the uh to a nine millimeter
weapon
the reason we were doing that is that
the ar-15 fires a 223 round and 90 of
our work are in the cities
and that round would go through one
house and through another and just keep
on going well when these new weapons
came out
i made a decision after tactical support
and everybody tested these weapons that
the nine millimeter was a much better
weapon to use but in waco they came in
to us and said we want eight at least i
think the number was eight ar-15s they
were all issued to him
but there's still a lot of we put some
ar-15s back in the field because of
places like texas that felt they still
needed
long-range rifles but for the most part
we were removing them from the field but
we weren't out going to waco that's for
sure
okay uh mr cereben document three says
the raid was approved by the bureau
headquarters honor between 211 93 or so
i noticed uh the uh special agent charts
um
met with high-ranking bureau officials
prior to the raid is that true
yes there was a a briefing
on the 11th and 12th of february that we
were there and it was mr hart mr conroy
and the executive staff and then
i think uh the following day you met
with mr hanowski and that's when they
approved the the raid on the 12th
actually i believe
thank you very much uh my time has
expired uh we will now recess for is it
one vote
so we'll recess for 15 minutes
[Music]
until
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the waco investigation hearings continue
later today
we'll show them to you tonight here on
c-span at 10 pm eastern time
texas in the spring of 1993 this was the
first of eight scheduled days of
hearings
subcommittees will come to order
uh the gentleman from oklahoma mr
brewster has 15 minutes
thank you mr chairman
as one who happens to believe that uh
atf and fbi do an awful lot right
uh probably 90 95 percent of your cases
are never heard of by the media or by
the average american
my main interest in this is trying to
figure out uh
what went wrong in the deal
uh
i think that
some of my colleagues here are
attempting to play a role i can assure
you i'm playing no role i want to know
uh as much as i can about the
information and hopefully we can do some
things differently next time so we don't
ever again have a repeat
of of waco
uh
mr donegan do i understand that
you contacted the national guard
concerning possible use of helicopters
because there was a methamphetamine lab
on the premises
no sir
my first contact with
the national guard was for
uh aerial photography work
uh my initial memorandum made no mention
of
a drug nexus i even instructed
one of the agents that made personal
contact with those representatives jose
viegra
to
make sure that he told them that at that
point we had no drug information
at a time later
we had learned
in fact it was within a couple of days
after that
the date of that particular memorandum
we learned that at some time in the past
that a
disassembled methamphetamine laboratory
had been seen by one of the branch
davidians who left
who was away from the compound
and
that
a statement was made by
vernon howe
that
he had called the sheriff's office and
had abandoned that um methamphetamine
lab
facility to them
the
there was a the person telling us the
story said
they never saw that
abandonment take place we checked with
the sheriff's office they had never
received a methamphetamine lab
from anyone from the compound and that's
how that came about
okay
who was first contacted by the deputy
sheriff you mr aguilar
yes sir i was is it common to be
contacted by a deputy sheriff as opposed
to the sheriff or undersheriff
well actually sir
the information was given to me on paper
by special agent charles meyer out of
the austin office
okay who in turn received the
information from lieutenant barber
but is it common do any of you have you
ever been contacted by a deputy sheriff
as opposed to the sheriff
sure
yes sir it is common
we i guess uh
i'm thinking back to oklahoma where we
had a sheriff that a deputy attempted to
frame with fbi a couple years ago
at any rate uh were all of you involved
are any of you involved in the decision
on dynamic entry
you're the the top ranking man mr
hartnett are you not
yes sir i was advised
you were involved in the decision of
dynamic injury
i approve the plan which
the term dynamic entry i really don't
know a a good definition for it nor do i
uh but the raid plan yes sir i am the
person who approved it
what about the rest of you did you have
any involvement in making helping make
the decision on the way that uh
we addressed the problem there
you talked as far as the dynamic entry
or
yes it well there was really a panel of
several
sachs which are special agents in charge
several assistant special agents in
charge
several of our srt team leaders
which
discuss the various options or whatever
and came to the conclusion to do the
dynamic entry
i happen to be one who's convinced
myself at least that mr karesh was a bad
guy
i am convinced that he had altered some
weapons
from the testimony we've heard certainly
you have to believe there were some
child abuse cases and some others
but it's hard for me to understand
how you arrived at the decision of
dynamic entry
uh isn't it true that mr karesh went to
town uh on a fairly regular basis
he'd been there on several occasions one
thing that has been
misunderstood i think for for the last
couple years is
during this investigation
we determined that at the compound
machine guns were being manufactured in
explosive devices
our goal through this investigation was
to
execute a search warrant on that house
to obtain
those illegal weapons other people were
involved in the manufacture and
possession of those
the arresting
of karish was just a side issue if we
arrested him we still had to do the
search warrant on the house
as you know it turned out there was
machine guns and hand that was our goal
we knew that machine guns were being
manufactured we had to get in into there
one way or another if we arrested him
off we still had to do the search
warrant so a lot of people have felt you
know the whole thing was to arrest david
preach that was not our goal
but was there anyone else anywhere in
the group that had the charisma the
leadership ability of a david koresh to
convince people who were engineers and
lawyers to follow him and some of the
crazy things that were done
i mean there were several professional
people in there but he was very
charismatic and and they followed him so
is there any reason to believe that had
you arrested him it would have not been
fairly easy to do the rest of it well
there's two things that could happen i
mean they could if we arrested him he
could have turned into a martyr and then
they would say they've taken our leader
here we have all these machine guns and
hand grenades he's taught him for years
you know the time has come
and you could have lost a whole bunch of
people yes
if i may mr rooster
um
another point i'd like to make out here
is that uh
koresh was observed outside of the
compound on two occasions uh one was i
believe january 17th of 93 and the other
february 24th
of 93.
what three day four days before the rate
no sir
that was 17th uh
this was maybe weeks before the raid
that's rape is the 28th the 28th
february 28th i'm sorry i thought you
said february 24th i'm sorry february
24th yes sir that's four days before yes
sir
and um i'm sorry i made a mistake here
but
we didn't actually obtain the warrant
and the warrant wasn't issued until
february 25th
but you started planning this clear back
about six months ago right and uh
actually the planning of the way i read
it started in december on the dynamic
entry the rate on the on the facility
we started planning it in december
but at that time we were planning for a
siege
we were not planning to do a dynamic
entry
at what point did you determine to do
the dynamic entry
it was in january
and you brought
special response teams in right but
their team leaders came in and that's
why i said we had these meetings for for
months that we went through and
basically you know we weighed the
options of the assault versus the siege
you know and we've got a lot of new
information that that kind of put us
over the hump but if we did a siege i
mean one thing as you've heard some of
the testimony today mass suicide
as we talked to everybody davey was on
the interviews we had our srt team
leaders goals there was a big fear of
everybody that there would be mass
suicide
um
secondly
you know if we tried to do a siege we
knew that there was machine guns in
there we knew that there's hand grenades
they'd have a long time to prepare in
other words by doing a dynamic entry
they wouldn't have time to prepare we
knew that they had
supplies of food and water that could
last for a long time we knew it would be
a long time i think they had mres for
three months
and you know what their own water well
um we knew it would be a disruption to
the community
you know if you did that it'd be a
long-term financial commitment you know
kareesha's in control if you do a siege
you know he calls the shots you know we
were concerned about the sexual abuse
that this was going on that would
continue on we were concerned about the
destruction of evidence
you know that if they made those machine
guns if they made those hand grenades we
said hey we're here as you know to do a
search warrant come out and they don't
come out they could take them apart as
quickly as
they put them in and as it turned out
every one of these things happened and
that was one of the reasons we switched
from the siege to the miss thurman when
you have special response teams uh in it
generally in response to people being
heavily armed
don't you generally when we would use
those
you can bring them in we would use them
in someone's situation they're very
highly trained in individuals and we use
them
as safety both for the people and for
and for the agents because they are
higher they will arm themselves
pardons are the special response teams
well armed themselves yes there are what
do you what's their
ordinary armament they'd have a not you
know their nine millimeter standard gun
and then an mp5 or you know maybe a
shotgun depending on where they were
going or what the specific you know so
what we've heard then about some of the
agents only having nine millimeter
sidearms is not correct
no
some of them only had nine millimeter
yeah i mean they have they have the
option each operation they kind of plan
out what they think they'll need or or
whatever some some that day we knew you
know obviously that there was women and
children and there was some expression
by some of the undercover agents that
we may have to get in a fist fight with
some people or whatever so some of them
were actually concerned that that they
didn't take a second gun that they
actually had there because if they got
into a fight they didn't want to be
trying to hold one gun or whatever if
if you're going into a well-armed
situation why would you not arm them
completely
to the best of anything possible
i mean there were so many things to
consider here there was women and
children you know we knew that they were
they were separated we had you know
teams divided in different areas to take
care of that but you know you need to
have
you know
the weapons that that you need but we
didn't feel they would be armed at that
time or were where we would you know if
uh
if you staged this at three in the
morning
why wouldn't that have been a better
time for surprise than 10 in the morning
the men and women were separated 24
hours a day
there wasn't a lot of light
inside the compound and normally we do
execute our warrants first thing in the
morning we're talking about eight or ten
agents going into a room
or a house
or maybe there's four or five people we
estimated that there were 75 people in
there we knew there was 100 plus members
but they always you know came and left
and there wasn't a solid number
we're sending 75 agents into a building
and you get inside going in different
directions it's dark one one round goes
off
and you know we had a real concern that
the women and children or whatever we
wouldn't see who shot where whatever and
could turn into a tragic incident so
the more i listen the more i can't
understand why david koresh was not
arrested outside
uh you used flashbang grenades uh at the
at the start of it correct
the only um
there was no plan to just use them when
upstairs which people have seen the
video on tv where there's the two rooms
where they're going into one of those
rooms was david karissa's bedroom
the other room was
his armory where they had the machine
guns the hand grenades in there they
were going to look to see if anybody's
in there before they can throw it they
have to make sure there's nothing
flammable where then they throw it in
and it's really just a distraction
device i mean it makes a loud noise and
it's a flash and the purpose of it it's
not to harm anybody or whatever but just
to stun them for a second so you can get
in and safely it's for their protection
and for the agent's protection it's not
an offensive
type of weapon ms hartnett uh there's a
rumor and surely it's unfounded
that the publicity person or public
relations person for atf had released
some kind of a press
communication the night before to media
around the country that something big
was going to come down in texas
yes and we heard that and and
the
person i believe her name was sharon
wheeler she's testified before
committees and and
she just did not give any information
out about waco texas at all she was in
she was in dallas
and she called
called a reporter to ask if he was going
to be in or called two reporters i'm not
quite sure i don't recall but and said
are you going to be in we're going to
have something coming up in the next day
or two as i recall that's how it came
out she never mentioned waco why did she
do that
she wanted to be able to get a hold of
them
if there was a story and they recovered
these arms now these this all came up
after the fact that we heard this and it
came out at hearings before wouldn't it
be ample time after they were recovered
oh yes i mean
but what came out it didn't come out the
way
you know she was accused of calling him
and saying there's going to be a
raid at waco tomorrow and that's that's
just not what occurred
it's always easy to
look at something in hindsight
hindsight's 20 20 and four sided nearly
that good
but when you've had four
federal employees killed
20 wounded
and a large number of civilians
that were killed in the process
i've got to think you're looking forward
to making some changes in the way that
you would do things in the future have
those changes been made to make sure
that a waco never happens again
i'm retired now and uh you don't have to
worry about that anymore well i still
worry about it i understand i still
worry about it i worry about it every
day of my life
uh
i think there are changes i see things
that that that happened to waco that
that we should have done differently um
i think those agents are
within atf are some of the best equipped
best trained most professional law
enforcement people in this country and
always have been and and i think always
will be
i think that their dedication you know
going in there that day they felt they
were well prepared and they felt they
were doing the right thing
and uh we need to correct the things
that went wrong there and there were
things that went wrong particularly on
the helicopters uh that just occurred to
me that we're flying that day were they
national guard or were they armies
national guard
did the governor give them permission to
use them or who had done that
now they come out of that jay
joint
joint task force
they were texas air national guard
yes sir
under the governor's direction
that's correct
so the governor given permission to use
them yes sir okay you mentioned too
about the training of your forces and i
understand they are well trained yet do
i understand that the army spent three
days uh or more
working with them as well
at fort hood
we had asked to use the facility down
there so that everyone knew where they
were going in the plan and the uh
the military actually gave advice on
things that they saw that they felt that
we should change or whatever
but uh
it was not
that we asked them
come and give us training it was we were
borrowing their facility
to use that to have a mock type
situation
so there could be some training and
everybody be familiar where everybody
else was going during the raid
and you had approximately 100 uh batf
personnel there i think pretty close to
it
yes sir
it was like 80 actually down there at
fort hood so you were expecting
problems bringing that large force in is
that correct
i i don't think we were we were
preparing for any event there was
in the plan
things that that took
it was so spread out the compound and so
large
that we wanted to make sure that we
could separate and get those guns
separated before anybody could get to
them
uh we wanted to make sure that we would
get the men
before they were when the element of
surprise was lost who made the decision
to continue
the commander in charge of the raid and
that was well i don't know if the
commander knew that he lost the element
of surprise and that is chuck's ceremony
did you know about the loss of the
element of the surprise truck
first of all far is the the element
surprise it's it's been an issue that's
been also
popped around in the newspaper or
whatever for for years
and there appears that at some level
there was an order given
or someone told somebody you know not to
go if you lost the illinois surprise
let me see if i can understand this in
my mind
somebody goes up to the door knocks on
the door with a search warrant in their
hand
is there someone else standing there
with a weapon as well
in this particular incident yeah
i was not at the front door
but somebody
some atf agent goes to the front door
and knocks on it with a search warrant
in hand and says we're here to arrest
david koresh
and search the building am i correct
right well they would say execute a
search warrant believe this and there's
another guy standing here with a weapon
as a guy by himself
that i don't know i think sir at least
what i've been told is that
i would like to
kind of condense and i will bring it
together quickly
i have been told that as our people came
up in front of the compound and were
disembarking that david korish was
standing in front of his front door
and outside outside
by the door and that two different
agents i believe it was two
called federal agents with a search
warrant
he stepped back inside and the agent who
was there in the front door or by the
front door was wounded the fire just
came right out and and shot the agents
now mr johnston was there at the trial
and heard all the testimony and and
could probably
but those agents were armed themselves
as well yes they were okay
thank you
thank you
uh gentlemen from north carolina mr
heinemann for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to continue this line of
questioning but i see here that
that
day two covers the planning of the raid
so i will i will restrict myself to the
intelligence gathering
prior to that that meeting where the
raid was planned
um i did read this book by mr noble the
uh the reporter department of treasury
on the on the waco incident
and of course he'll be here on the fifth
fourth or fifth day to answer questions
but in that book
on page nine it indicates that um
treasury
department stated that they chose not to
try to lure
david koresh away from the compound
because intelligence reports
he really ventures off compound grounds
that's found on page nine
and certainly today we've we've heard
conflicting testimony from
from someone mr thibodeaux from in the
compound
uh and i'd like to uh i'd like to
address to mr serbin
or perhaps
the agent himself
as to when that when that house that
observation house was set up outside the
compound
the the house was started up in january
in some of the conflicting reports
as far as what you're hearing on how
many times he was off the surveillance
at the beginning was for 24 hours and
then then it broke down to where they
were just basically doing it from
sunlight to
to late at night
um
obviously there were several vehicles in
there that the surveillance house
actually i believe only saw him one time
leave far as the agents observing him
leave there was cars going and come
obviously he could have been in a car
that they that they didn't see it
um there was also conversation with with
the undercover agent
that um
you know he
doesn't go off the compound he said he
was getting paranoid about law
enforcement or whatever so the
combination of the information we had at
the time was that we only observed him
the one time and what he had told the
undercover agent you know we didn't feel
that he was going off the off the couch
who was in charge of that house
there were several agents there uh dale
littleton was actually just to supervise
the uh the undercover agent and then
he was under earl and then earl would
report to me and then dale would also
call me with information directly well
where did that where did that flow of
information terminate did that stay with
you in the waco area or did it go no it
would you know after their reports would
be put on an atf form
3270.2 which it would come through earl
then it would come to me and this was
distributed to
all the sacs all the asacs all these
different srt team members so they got
all the information and then anytime
that we
had a plan as far as meeting in a group
of 15 or 20 to discuss both the case and
what what we were going to do tactically
dale would come and represent the you
know all the undercover agents and give
us a briefing on what was going on
what use did you make of the local
agencies either the texas rangers or the
sheriff's department relative to
intelligence
i spoke to
dps intelligence
and obtain information information that
i already had and secured
i requested information through
headquarters
most of the information that i had or
that they had i had already had been
provided with
so there wasn't much they could give me
other than what i had hey let me let me
at this point i've i pretty much
touched on what i want to touch on the
previous gentleman of course they all
took some of what i was going to ask but
at this time i'd like to yield the
balance of my time to mr bar to continue
his line of questioning
i appreciate the gentleman from north
carolina
mr johnston following up just briefly on
our line of questioning earlier
in my concern over
uh destruction of evidence or
non-production of of evidence
there apparently was a was a settlement
agreement in the
winowski case
are you familiar with that
uh uh and the the reason i'm asking is
par apparently the settlement documents
provided uh for destruction
of uh certain discovery files and i'm
wondering if you're aware of that
uh
uh wanoski had a uh i guess civil
service claim is that right
i know nothing about that at all i guess
that's something that treasury handled
would that would that be unusual if
there is a
a case handled not by the civil service
but by its successor agency the merit
system protection board
and
as part of a settlement in this case
reinstatement with back pay
that uh documents uh would be destroyed
including in this case apparently or
perhaps
documents uh relating to possible
wrongdoing would that be something that
would concern you as a as a government
attorney
if you're saying destroyed as in all in
all destroyed no copies well then that's
obviously concerning because you don't
have any and there's no evidence so i
don't
i guess i've never heard of that process
i hadn't either but then again i haven't
heard of the documents that i that i
showed you earlier but that that would
concern you as a prosecutor yes sir okay
thank you i appreciate the gentleman
from north carolina
gentleman's time expired um
the chair recognizes mr ehrlich the vice
chair of the subcommittee for five
minutes
i'd like to direct i have five minutes
i'd appreciate
i'll try to frame my questions concisely
appreciate concise answers mr aguilera
did any person in a supervisory chain
above you
ever ask you to gather information with
respect to the issue of arresting quresh
outside the compound
the information
i i didn't they didn't request for me
they obtained the information to try and
arrest a court outside no no sir okay
now earlier today mr mcmahon testified
that you specifically declined an offer
from koresh
over the telephone
the heat wherein he allegedly said come
visit
i'll show you the guns
is that a true statement in fact that's
true that's a true statement
however
the only reason i didn't want to talk to
koresh was because i had prior knowledge
and information
that koresh had dealings with mcmahon
and i wanted to further check his
records in order for me to find out
whether or not koresh was dealing
without a license
so you thought that offer was premature
at the time that's why you declined yes
sir yes sir it would have
been non-productive for my case for my
investigation
thank you
mr cerebrant
my question to you sir is did you ever
have occasion
to draft a memo
wherein you suggest that koresh be
arrested outside the compound
i don't remember drafting a memo i do
know that we did consider it and and
tried two or three options to try to do
that but i don't remember drafting a
memo
so your recollection is you did not
actually
draft the memo but
is it your record i don't put words in
your mouth but is it your recollection
that you you remember observing or we
considered a memo we we considered and
actually tried to do a couple things
where we could arrest them off
but i don't remember or recall preparing
any memo
and there came a point in time where
that option was rejected correct
we actually
one of them was to go through the health
and human services where they would call
him off
and say you know we want to talk to you
or whatever and
we went and talked to them they said
well he doesn't show up for three or
four days and we couldn't plan when and
which i tried to explain earlier no
matter where
or when we rested karish we still had to
do a search warrant on the compound and
we knew that would involve a lot of
people so you know like with the health
and he they declined it at the end but
had we done that you know we couldn't
have sat around with with a hundred
agents for five days till he showed up
because we still had to execute the
search warrant on his house
sir is it fair to say that at some point
in time you change your mind with with
respect to
the uh appropriateness of arresting
koresh outside the compound
yeah i would say
when i'm talking of of our decision so
there's a group here of about 15 or 20
people that would discuss this you know
at various times on what and yes we did
it did change he was from the undercover
and we had as davey got information some
of the people that had left the compound
still had people on the compound or
whatever and and the sense was that you
know he was getting you know very
paranoid and not trusting his own people
or whatever
thank you
mr hardin
uh two questions real briefly
is it your testimony sir that the
element of surprise was lost prior to
the raid on february 28th
i have of course heard the element of
surprise since the day after the raid
yes
prior to that time i never heard the
term element of surprise
the
whether or not that
and mr hanowski of course is was the
sack in houston
and i've asked him
many times since the raid
did you feel the raid was compromised
when you went in
and he has said no to this day
and i believe him
thank you sir sir earlier you testified
that
mistakes were made and the remaining
time that we have
and i realize it's very easy has been
repeated many times here tonight it's
very easy being a monday morning
quarterback
what would you have done differently uh
in retrospect
there was a when the undercover agent
came out of the
compound and met with uh well
i thought he was going to meet with
chuck serbian when i was briefed
he was going to come out
and
let chuck know the status after the waco
trib had come out were they going were
they getting out guns were they going to
battle stations that type of thing
at the time of the briefing
i never asked the question as to how
they were communicating
they communicated by phone
the most important conversation we had
in this entire raid took place over the
telephone between the undercover agent
and mr serbin
i didn't ask the question at the time
the plan was given to me
if i had of or if i thought of it
that would never have happened they
would have met in person they would
discuss what they saw there would have
been no communications gap between
what the undercover agent saw and felt
and what chuck was thinking
that to me was was a serious mistake
and
and i didn't catch it at the time
mr i know our time
are you finished your answer sir yes sir
mr uh taylor from mississippi
five minutes
thank you mr chairman mr
aggie letter is that right aguilera yes
sir i'm sorry
all right
in page 19 of this it talks about your
conversation with deputy barbour who on
forcing has already left us
talking about
an attempt for
caress to kill george rhoden or rodden
his predecessor
preacher he replaced at gunpoint
do you feel like there was adequate
evidence given to you by mr barbara that
this actually took place
that he ran off the previous preacher at
gunpoint actually shot at him that he
was found behind hiding behind a tree
well yes sir i read the report
do you believe that to be true yes sir
did that influence your decision on how
you were to serve this warrant
the fact that this man had been shown
to have violent tendencies and the use
of firearms even against another
preacher
i had no
i didn't partake in the planning of the
raid
or the execution of the warrant
did that influence your decision
or the decision do you feel like i'm
okay i
let me let me go a little bit farther to
page 27.
again
the these are statements attributed to
you but not direct quotes
it says aggie letters sought information
from former cult nervous it gave him
some insight into the extraordinary
degree to which dominated the lives of
compound residents
called members surrendered all their
assets to koresh and permitted him to
have sex with all female members of the
cult
while caress while reports that quresh
was permitted to
sexually and physically abuse children
were not evidence that firearms or
explosives violations were occurring
they showed correction to have set up a
world of his own
where legal prohibitions were discarded
freely
do you believe that to be an accurate
statement
according or from the information that i
had received from former members
it was
placed in my probable cause
the affidavit yes i do do you think that
in fairness to the four officers who
lost their lives and the 20 officers who
were wounded
in fairness to their widows and fairness
to the two children who will not now
have a father
that maybe some of these things ought to
be brought to the attention of this
committee and do you think that in
fairness to those people
this
series that was about to be printed in
the waco tribune and has since been
credited should be entered into the
record
that's sure
don't you think that in fairness to the
atf agents that you should be treated
same as every criminal and that at least
you're given the presumption that you're
innocent until proven guilty
we should be treated as criminals no sir
i think that you can be treated at least
as well as the criminals in this country
and given the presumption that you're
innocent until proven guilty and given
the opportunity to prove yourself
instantly don't you think it would be
fair for this committee to do that
and don't you think it would help your
case if you were able to talk about the
events that led up to the raid
yes sir
my
final points i'd like to make is
after talking to deputy barbara
at some point in those conversations did
he request or did a member of the
sheriff's department
request the help of the atf or did the
atf just on their own decide they were
going to descend upon waco texas
and pick on some poor country preacher
i did the complete investigation on my
own
i didn't request any assistance from the
sheriff's office except for the
intelligence that i had been receiving
from them the question was the other way
around did the sheriff's department at
some point request your help yes sir
they did initially so you did not just
pick waco off the map of the united
states and decide that you would go down
there no certainly requested by a local
governing authority
the law enforcement authority
come down and help yes sir
do you think that ought to be included
in the record
and yes sir in in the raid well don't
you think we ought to talk about the
events that led up yes sir sure people
will know that yes sir because i can
assure you there are a heck of a lot of
people in this country who think that
y'all just picked that town in that
preacher
and i don't think that's fair to the
four men who died no certainty i don't
think it's fair to the 20 men who got
wounded no sir
is there anything else you'd like to say
mr aguilar
no sir okay thank you very much mr chair
thank you gentlemen's time has expired
uh
mrs uh mrs laflin of california you have
five minutes
thank you mr chairman dr
perry i've read through all of the
material you've
provided about the
evaluation of the children who were
evacuated by yourself and the team and
also the
transcript of of your transmittal i
think of march 11th if i'm reading the
debate correctly to the fbi where you
recount
this the status of the children
can you
tell this committee what your impression
was about the level of
sexual molestation going on in the
compound after you had examined these
children as well as what information you
had gathered from them about explosive
materials weapons and things of that
nature and what of that did you transmit
to the fbi we uh within the first week
after working with these children
um in a variety of ways it became clear
that there were two primary areas of
secret that they wanted to keep from the
babylonians the non-believers who we
were
in their minds
these included
over time as these kids slowly revealed
in a variety of ways what these were
they included two major themes one was
that there was uh this
and they had been told that people would
not understand this this
uh this special relationship that they
were going to have
with david and of course they were right
the sexuality the fact that sex was
openly talked about that young children
were exposed to inappropriate sexual
content and that by the age of 12
all children were considered adults and
all girls were therefore available to
david for his wife as we heard today
obviously the age of 12 is pushing the
limit he clearly
partook
his pleasures in younger children as
well at that time it was also clear that
these kids looked at us with smugness
and said well you'll see what'll happen
and you don't know what's going to
happen and
could i specifically ask a question on
because i i wasn't very direct on the
second page of your memorandum you talk
about one a child that the children knew
beyond what their years would indicate
about weapons and one young boy in
particular discussing his grenade the
grenade launcher
was that these children knew
a lot more about guns
than you would expect for children this
age children as young as six years old
would pick up a toy wooden gun pull the
bolt back
weigh it as if
getting the balance looked on the barrel
and say this isn't a real gun
could i ask mr johnson were you aware of
this information about
the evidence in the children as to
weapons and possible violations when the
when you reviewed the information
uh seeking the warrant
there was some information joyce sparks
spoke with a young child that said i
can't wait until i'm a man something of
that nature and she said why and he said
because then i'll get a long gun and
once again that and of itself long gun
may not mean a machine gun but it
indicated the kids had knowledge of guns
um as far as the question concerning
sexual abuse the the kiri jewel story we
didn't know let me ask finally and then
i want to yield to mr scott
mr cereben you mentioned that you were
aware uh that there was a sexual abuse
going on in the compound as you were
readying for
the final days
i wonder if um
you could uh tell me we all you take an
oath to uphold the law and the law that
you're
upholding is to enforce alcohol tobacco
and firearms but as a law enforcement
officer was it in your mind
that little girls were being raped
inside the walls of this compound while
while you were and the rest were waiting
to execute this war was that a factor in
timing it
even subconsciously as a law enforcement
officer as a human being it was inside
of you i heard the testimony earlier
today and
as we interviewed these people and and
and we heard those stories i mean you
know we had talked to her before so and
you i i guess had seen this the sinful
uh
messiah story mr mr chairman i wonder if
we could ask unanimous consent to put
this news article in the record
it's the sinful messiah from the waco
tribune herald that's been referenced
several times
is it
reserving the right to object
is this a um
this is an article that appeared before
the raid on the uh
on the compound
does it mention anything about firearms
violation
i think it talks about the the
sexual abuse that i think was in the
minds of the agents and as human beings
and law enforcement officers was a
factor and an understandable one if i'm
hearing mr serbian correctly as to time
well continuing my reservation
did the agents have any anything in
writing any memos
from this particular time that
demonstrate that because of
alleged sexual abuse that motivated
their thinking about the planning of
this firearms law enforcement rate this
is the first i've heard
of all of this
i yield gentleman from new york i thank
the gentleman this article which
occurred the day before the raid which
was published by the waco whatever
herald something
tribute herald
um which was published the day before
the raid plays a very important role in
what happened
in a variety of ways if you read the
report of atf there's a whole chapter on
it because
and this is an important question we
will deal with today and tomorrow
one of the
the timing of the re the the uh atf
people went to the waco
herald tribune
tribune herald and asked them to not run
the article when they decided they would
run the article they moved the day up it
may account for some of the speed with
which the raid went i think any of the
gentlemen who were involved will back me
up that this was an extremely important
article in terms of what happened and by
all means it should be in the record
whether it mentioned firearms or not
what is also important here is what atf
thought correctly or incorrectly and we
can debate that
is that the publication of the article
would influence koresh's state of mind
and that was an important factor in
determining
when
and how to do the raid
with reclaiming my time i understand the
gentleman's point
but continuing my reservation for the
moment i've asked two questions i would
be grateful if the person uh offering
this into the record or one of the
witnesses and clarify my first question
very simply is does that article have
anything to do with firearms violations
i think it does yes
the second is
with respect to the the references in
that article to sexual abuse and now the
testimony that because of this
uh uh sexual abuse that motivated the
uh atf to have to do this right all the
faster i had to if i may interrupt i
don't think that was the testimony that
was not my
i'm sorry i did not mean i did not mean
to
alter your testimony i i'll let you
phrase it it's getting kind of late for
all of us so i apologize if i've
misstated the article
face or made us move the the raid up
okay
she asked me as a person
did i have a feeling that i knew that
sexual
assaults or rapes were going on in the
compound did that affect me as a human
being i said yes as a law enforcement
officer or whatever i had a feeling
about that law enforcement officer do
you have anything in writing
from right before the raid that
indicated the raid had to take place in
a certain way in a certain speed because
of your concern as a human being about
child sexual abuse no thank you um
i think i've made my points mr chairman
about the documents i think the points
have been made in its favor we've been
letting in about everything to be fair
so i will withdraw my uh reservation
without objection so ordered to
uh you mrs laughlin you have two minutes
left uh thank you mr chairman at this
point i would like to yield the balance
of my time to mr scott
thank you um
thank you lady from from
from california
excuse me
um mr mr johnston um
have you ever gotten evidence in court
under the good faith exception to the to
the exclusionary rule
i have uh had a judge rule in the
alternative that evans would be
admissible under that
say that again in other words i've had
courts rule that there was probable
cause but if the appellate court were to
find not then the agent had good faith
in relying on it in other words an
alternative finding but i don't think
i've had to rely entirely on have you
had evidence excluded
from court because it had been illegally
obtained
no sir
do you know of any uh evidence that's
been offered
in your jurisdiction where the evidence
was found to be illegally obtained and
was excluded
i don't recall any in the waco division
the western district of texas is huge
i'm sure there has been somewhere but
not not in our division
that i recall let me ask mr aguilera
do you have any problem obeying the law
sir you have any problem obeying the law
no sir
um
are you aware of any officer who's been
sanctioned for illegally obtaining
evidence
no sir
so the exclusionary rule is about the
only sanction we have against officers
violating the law
i'm not the evidence if you if you
illegally obtain evidence and it's not
admissible in court that's about the
only sanction
you've heard for illegally obtaining
evidence yes sir
and it's the only
sanction we have the only protection we
have against law enforcement officers
breaking the law yes sir thank you
thank you
uh i yield chair yields to the gentleman
from arizona mr shattuck
uh before i start my question let me
make a couple of statements i spent
eight years as a prosecutor or eight
years of the arizona attorney general's
office i i apologize i
got two people talk in my ear uh by
prior arrangement we
can i just hold you up for a second
certainly we should shift back over to
jackson lee of texas
thank you very much mr chairman i would
like mr chairman if i could raise a
question with the chair
so that my questions will be understood
by the witnesses i want to ask questions
and i will ask the witnesses to give me
yes or no answers i want to make it
clear that i'm not in any way trying to
limit their response as much as i'm
trying to get a number of questions in
and i want to make and clarify my uh my
particular questions uh and let me also
mr chairman for my time starts i see
that it has asked you to allow me to do
that before my time starts uh to thank
uh cardis collins on the record
for yielding time to me previously
mr um
malton
you've
had to be
exceedingly quiet over there and so let
me try to
cull from you some of the concerns that
i have
it seems that little
carrie jewell said it all when she was
trying to
suggest that a lot of people were trying
to get things out of this and we just
need to fix it
i hope that if we can all eliminate the
garments of hypocrisy that that is what
we're trying to do is to fix it
so it's my understanding that there was
an investigation that proceeded
for how long mr moulton uh approximately
five months
investigation conducted by the treasury
department
can you tell me what this book is mr
moulton that's that is the treasury
department report issued in september
1993
that addresses
virtually all if not all the questions
that have been discussed today i'm sorry
i'll do my best to say yes or no that's
all right did you participate in this uh
inquiry yes i was the project director
of that investigation
in the course of trying to
review extensively
what occurred in this tragedy loss of
lives of adults and children
loss of lives of our law enforcement
officers i want to get right to the
point of focusing on
corrective measures
in this document
is there a corrective measure that says
let us eliminate
a portion of the exclusionary rule
meaning that
search warrants
are not good anymore let's base them all
on good faith is that is that in this
there is no suggestion of alteration of
the exclusionary will in the document so
that worked for you in terms of this
document that's correct
we had a problem as we've heard some of
the witness testify in a point when
there was no retreat
this is a point when we heard possibly
that someone tipped the media
in this report do you have at least a
suggestion of some intervening factor
online authority that would have given
the opportunity for fair analysis so
that a possible retreat could have
occurred therefore saving lives
uh the report discusses uh the
importance of an operation like this
being reviewed at the treasury
department substantially in advance of
the raid rather than 48 hours before the
rate as was the case here
one of the things that i heard also
mentioned because the american people
need to know
we hold of high regard this whole idea
of religion
and respect for people's differences
i've heard the seventh-day adventist
church being mentioned
and i would wonder in this particular
document for it is quite distinguishable
from a religion and a cult
do we have in this document any
suggestion of further training or
enhanced training for our law
enforcement agencies about cults
that the document addresses the need for
law enforcement agencies to consult
experts in
organizations or groups like the branch
davidian
before they conduct or in order to
evaluate the information uh that they're
being given by members of the cult and
by others you think cults are different
from religion yeah i i think that uh i
think that dr perry expressed uh
the difference quite well earlier
mr chairman i have a joint statement of
uh
mr rosedale president american family
foundations and william ryland president
of cult awareness network and you had
indicated to me mr chairman i hope i can
have a moment where the clock is
stopping that we would be open to
potentially having witnesses come in and
talk about issues that have
long-standing impact on our ability to
reform i'd like this statement submitted
for the record but i'd like the
opportunity to raise with the committee
possibility of a cult expert coming in
and testifying chairman i'd ask
unanimous consent
with that
right to object the document is what i
asked leading in texas on behalf it's a
joint statement of the president of the
american family foundation and the
president of the cult awareness network
it is relevant mr schiff and i
appreciate your inquiry um because one
of the suggestions was
that
our law enforcement agencies in terms of
reform and correction needed additional
training in cult awareness uh for they
may come upon these kinds of groups
across the nation in the course that
that played into the tragedy that
occurred and this document is simply a
report on cult and it also addresses the
particular incident in waco
continuing my reservation uh first i
believe that mr perry is on the board of
this organization and he's been a
witness here at this proceedings
he did not get the opportunity to
give all of his testimony
no mr perry i don't think that's dr
perry
correct
that's dr perry and i'm not on the board
of i'm on a research advisory board for
the american family foundation which is
comprised of six academics or seven
academics
that's not
that's the extent of my relationship
with those organizations
well continuing my reservations if i
could just ask
does the lady off is the lady offering
this document
does that mean that we are committed to
the idea that the branch davidian group
was a cult
i'm not in that i don't offer that
capacity at all mr if i offer it as an
explanatory document not in all i don't
think it's a truth it's a veracity
question
i withdraw my reservation
as far as the admission in the record
without objection so ordered as far as a
potential witness
as we talked about earlier would
certainly be willing to consider it mr
chairman i would wonder because
that we just had whether i can the red
light is on but uh you have 30 seconds
left regardless of what the red light
says
let me just ask uh mr moulton was there
a cover-up absolutely not let me go
quickly to mr owens uh not not by the
treasure i'm sorry not by the treasury
department in the preparation of that
report absolutely not let me ask mr owen
so that my question can be out and you
can answer the question if you would go
again to one of the weapons there that
the gentlemen were kind to bring i
simply need you to point to a weapon
that could be converted was there a
weapon in that group that could have
been converted or was a product of being
converted is there anything
in there yes ma'am could you show me
that quickly sir miss owens i thank you
very much
and would you explain whether that was
found in the
this one has been compound
i believe it was found in the vehicle
i'm told you can't be heard is that i'm
sorry sir maybe you need to
this particular weapon has been
converted it's a
semi-automatic aks type rifle that's
been modified i believe this weapon was
recovered from a vehicle located in
front of the compound
thank you very much mr chairman
thank you i would just like to make a
comment
on behalf of our side as far as these
weapons are concerned we tried at great
length to
try to have access to those weapons and
received a letter dated july 11 from mr
kent marcus
principal deputy assistant attorney
general
u.s department of justice saying
uh comments that this will cost the
taxpayers the state of texas and the
united states many thousands of dollars
we just would have enjoyed the
opportunity to have worked uh with both
sides here to examine those weapons as
well
and i think it would have been helpful i
just make that statement uh yield to the
gentleman from arizona
as i understand it a letter was sent
offering
that same letter offering your ability
to examine the weapons the problem was
as i understand it two-fold one of
course failure analysis
whatever their last initial is but which
is in great dispute now but secondly
they just didn't want to break the chain
of
forget what the legal term is
custody because these weapons still are
part of a legal process ongoing just
because of the interest in terms of
getting at the evidence
could i ask the question of how much did
it cost to just bring those weapons up
because it would have been helpful for
our side as well
anybody have any idea just the ballpark
mr
mr chairman just a question
wouldn't that be possible to to uh
these weapons are now here and i just
heard some conflicting things first i
heard that this was recovered in the
compound and then the gentleman just
testified that
the the weapon he held up was in a
vehicle in front of the compound
and then the other one is sort of
charred
and i'm not a weapons expert i've never
even held one of those weapons isn't it
possible now to turn those over
temporarily to the committee and have
someone independently i think one i
think if i could make a comment exercise
in progress of the chair i think what we
tried to do
uh is to get a third party uh or at
least get get the justice department to
x-ray these weapons make information
available to all of us to determine
which which weapons were altered
and you know you have a serious heat
problem in a fire
certain materials do get melted down and
so what we were looking for is to bring
in an expert on a third-party basis to
look at it or at least get
all of us involved in the process so we
can examine the evidence because i think
it's an important piece of evidence to
consider
for a very brief
and and the problem is justice writes
back because the process required will
be expensive cumbersome and difficult
and of little or no
evidentiary value to the public whom we
both serve we recommend against the
procedure which you have requested and
besides that requested taxpayers the
state of texas the united states many
thousands of dollars and then we see the
evidence presented here
clarification
mr owen said the weapon had been
modified modified to do what
machine gun
thank you mr modified by whom
i have no idea
i guess we don't need it
again which weapon are they referring to
one is charred the other weapon he said
was found in a vehicle in front of the
compound
again we have these uh weapons here and
i see no reason why we can't
uh have an independent responsible
authority look at the weapons and make a
determination for the benefit of the two
subcommittees
i think at this point we need to move on
well i just i mean there are a couple of
points unanswered here number one they
were found
as i heard mr owen say on a vehicle in
front of the building which is part of
the compound the compound is not just
the building but it's the surrounding
area it was indeed on the compound if
you read any of the literature that's
what the compound is referred to
second to hand over the weapons
whether it be
to this committee
or to a third and third group
the majority asked that failure analysis
paid for by the nra hardly an impartial
source do it a ridiculous suggestion
about the department of justice
to hand it over to any
any
third party would break the chain of
custody and ruin the cases now if you
want to try to sit down and work
something out that's fine finally the
letter that you requested didn't request
two weapons
but requested all the weapons be flown
up here and done that is much more
expensive than a few now that we know
that it can be done maybe that's an
issue for another day i'd like to uh now
the chair now recognizes uh gentlemen
from arizona mr chairman
mr chairman
i i the point of the your your
discussion came out of my
questioning and i just like the
clarification i'll say it to you um i
think mr owen may not have completed his
answer to the extent
uh that
the question
was
calling for him to answer whether there
were devices um
on the property on the compound or
inside the facilities that could modify
to a fully automatic i assume he didn't
complete his answer on that
um that there were device modification
equipment to modify to a fully automatic
on the premises is that my understanding
i cannot testify to that ma'am you're
not familiar with that no ma'am thank
you chair would like to now recognize mr
shattuck from arizona five minutes thank
you very much uh let me resume where i
was i've spent a good deal in my career
defending law enforcement i come to
these hearings with mixed emotions i'm
not here to assess blame or to point
guilt my goal isn't political it's not
to point at the administration but there
is an important goal that goes on here
today first of all i'm pleased to see my
colleagues on the other side defending
law enforcement because i find
historically they don't do that but i
think it's occasionally important i
object to that statement i think it's
important that is i think it's important
that we answer some questions here
the questions the questions
statement mr chairman i think i think
what he's doing
i know the evening's getting late you
probably didn't hear it he's trying to
compliment you i think that's the way he
intended it no let's move forward mr
shattuck i think the point funny remark
mr chairman it's an arrogant
denunciation of those of us on this side
of the eye
committee
thank you mr chairman um seems to me the
goal of these hearings is to try to
enable the american people to have faith
in law enforcement at the federal level
once again regrettably
this particular incident has eaten away
at their faith in law enforcement it
seems we can achieve that goal by doing
one of two things one ascertaining what
mistakes were made if any and two
ascertaining whether or not corrective
measures have already been taken to
correct those mistakes i think we spent
the day focusing on all kinds of issues
that are not issues for example whether
or not mr kresh was a gross base human
being who had
no business being in the position he was
in and no business being able to access
children as he did that is not i don't
believe the issue here but i would like
to get to some of the issues that i
think are important for the american
people because it's my goal to
rehabilitate their faith in law
enforcement because if they have no
faith in law enforcement we don't have
an ordered society let me in that regard
begin with you mr aguilera first
as i understand your testimony it is
that you were offered by mr karesh and
you understood you've been offered by mr
crash an opportunity to come and look at
the weapons that he had in his or
weapons or parts of weapons that he had
in his possession
uh mr mcmahon had telephonically
contacted koresh and he asked me to
cover the phone
and um just just i've got very little
time did you understand and you would i
think you believe you said you did did
you understand that you were being
offered an opportunity to go look at
those weapons yes sir okay
now i would understand why as a law
enforcement officer you would not want
to take that up at that particular
moment in time my question of you is did
you later take that offer up
no sir did you ever take that offer up
no sir did you tell your supervisor
specifically mister sarah banya that
you'd been offered a chance to go into
the corrupt compound at mister crush's
invitation and to look at the weapons
yes sir it's been in my reports you told
mr ceremonia that
whether he read the reports or not i
don't know but uh they were in my
reports
okay mr sarah banyan
were you aware when you planned the
dynamic raid that one of your agents had
been offered an opportunity to go in and
look at the weapons and see what was
there yes it was sir
and and mr aguilera never went did some
other agent from atf go
no
i think mr sarah bana went no is there a
reason why no one ever went
we discussed this as i said when we had
this committee of people planning the
raid that was one of our options that we
considered why don't we try
to call the dealer and you know
then see if we can get krish off that
way but from all the intelligence we
were getting at that time
when we started this investigation
everything we were told there was armed
guards
and at one time there was there was a
guard house or whatever but things had
changed from from the information that
we were getting back from people still
on the compound that he was now paranoid
of his people that the guns were put up
we didn't want to alert him by you know
going second time talking about guns and
then he might put the armed guards up
and go back to the way he was before i'm
absolutely baffled that when he had this
standing offer for you to be able to go
and look at these weapons you chose
never calling back and take that offer
up and find out what was in there
and and why you would not do that and
still plan a dynamic raid is beyond me
um
i mean i i guess i'm trying to
understand why the dynamic raid was
necessary when he had a standing offer
that
that you could come in and look at those
weapons i said the panel considered this
we we talked about it we just thought it
would put him on an offensive mode and
go back to having arm guard you now wish
you'd gone back in and at least taken a
look at the weapons tried to take him up
on his offer
well we could have yeah okay um i'm a
little puzzled about the whole uh timing
and sequence of the uh actual entry
itself uh you i understand mr sarah
benjamin were in charge of the actual
raid the day it occurred is that right
my title was a tactical coordinator i
was the head of the srt teams
i was puzzled earlier and i understood
that you did not know and couldn't
answer mr brewster's questions about
how many agents went to the door
tell me that isn't true i assume you
knew how many agents went to the door no
i don't know the specific number that
went the door it was broken into six
different teams
and we had several teams making entry in
the front door three teams that were
going around but i mean i could find
some list and give you the specific
number but i do not know it off the top
of my head but you had overall
supervised authority for
the entire race it was like the tactical
coordinator and then each
member under me was responsible for his
own team
okay and those were the teams that would
be making you know interesting can you
give the american people any definitive
answer on the question of whether or not
agents fired from the helicopters and
whether or not they fired before or
after mister people from the compound
fired uh
themselves out i was
i was in one of the helicopters no
nobody
shot from the helicopters to the
compound well you were in one of the
helicopters i guess i was asking mr
sarabanian because he's in charge of the
whole raid what what can we tell the
american people on the issue of whether
or not
armed federal agents fired first or
didn't file first
we didn't fire first according to uh the
testimony during the trial
when they were getting out of the cattle
carts they fired upon us i'm a little
i'm a little i mean i appreciate that i
still was asking mr saraban because he
was in charge of the raid and i guess if
he doesn't know how many agents were at
the door i'm troubled with how he now
knows whether or not we fired first and
i'm sorry i was in the first vehicle
pulling up on a compound we had two
vehicles we don't have a picture right
now but went down a 250 yard driveway
and then we made a left-hand turn i was
in the first vehicle and i went in front
of the compound and actually stopped
at the end of the compound the second
vehicle
stopped at the front door
before i opened my door to get out we
were being fired on
from the compounds i i was going to the
front door but i never got but a few
feet from when they began to fire at uh
so that's why consequently i do not know
what happened at the front door i would
deeply like to believe we didn't fire
first could i if i could just one
follow-up question did you with regard
to this issue of child molestation which
has been a major issue today and i think
a major distraction did you ever contact
the texas law enforcement authorities
and then who would have had jurisdiction
over that you clearly did not did you
ever contact texas law enforcement
authorities who would have had
jurisdiction over child molestation or
statutory rape and invite them to
participate in the raid
uh no sir i didn't invite them to
participate in the raid however i did
have conversations with the district
attorney there to pursue state charges
on child molestation
and and were they invited to be involved
at all other than no sir
uh gentleman spartan thank you
um i'm gonna do my five minutes and then
we're gonna have to recess do a vote and
come back believe it or not uh we do
this every once in a while it just
happens to coincide with a hearing so
thank you for your patience i passed out
or i'd like to clerk to pass out
document number three
and my questions uh i'll start with mr
hartnick document number three says the
raid was approved by the bureau
headquarters honor of between 211 93 or
so i know the special agent in charge
ceremony in aquila met with high-ranking
bureau officials prior to the raid were
you one of those officials yes sir i was
you were
and
the raid was approved in washington by
high-ranking bureau officials honored
near february 11 1995 1993
did you approve that on or near that
date yes sir i did you did
and do you know whether or not uh when
it was approved uh it was said to halt
the raid if the element surprise was
lost
i never heard the term element of
surprise now
let me say that surprise was a part of
the plan but
nothing was ever said about the other
the document also says several pages of
surveillance log had been torn out have
you ever heard that before
no sir i hadn't was responsible for
safekeeping in the surveillance log
littleton i believe excuse me littleton
i believe was a supervisor
at the surveillance
uh house
um
i just never heard that before but but
pages were removed i mean i never heard
that before the pages were removed
okay but you might want to refer to that
that document number three that we we
handed you
parliament
we just like we have a copy of the
document we don't know what it is
it just has a lot of writing on it is it
a note from who to who
okay this is part of the 13 000 pieces
of loose paper the treasury gave us that
was
was unorganized
uh and we were trying to piece it
together but we were we think it's
pertinent it certainly involves it
well it refers to mr higgins
um refers to i think it's very pertinent
but we i just wanted i'm not trying to
post
it okay we don't know it's a post-raid
interview with one of their agents and
what i'm asking is the gentleman that
was in charge if he could shed some
light
it says there's markings on the
left-hand side agent john bryant
dallas is about all we can figure out
with the same concerns you do
where were we
were you mr hartnick
about ready to answer
i'm sorry sir i just you mentioned that
notes were torn out of the surveillance
log i was just wondering how does that
happen
i don't know sir i i had never heard
that before right i don't recall we're
hearing it before do you know if it was
true no sir i don't
uh so so this may or may not apply then
the interview with the unnamed agent
also says quote personal knowledge that
the surveillance notes for the atf were
poor and incomplete do you have any
reason to believe that the agent being
interviewed is not telling the truth
you know i
don't know who the witness is who the
writer why don't you let him answer i
mean i know you're good but
so was he
i don't think i understand
what you're asking i i guess i guess
you know that this is an interview with
one of your agents and
i'm just trying to
get out if the fact that if these logs
get changed or tampered with or pages
get pulled out just wondering if you
know anything about that no sir i don't
halfway down the atf's agent's interview
this document says statements that the
atf was outdone was true
mr hartnick had uh prior
to the raid
mandated that
we all turn in our ar-15s even though
several
iraq's
racs
voice their complaints um
mr hartnick is that true did you mandate
that the agents turn in their ar-15s and
what is an ar-15
so were these agents knowingly outdone
before they started why did you have
them turned into ar-15s
we were in the midst of
first of all they had all the ar-15s
that they wanted in their raid plan i
think the number
as i recall and i could be wrong was
eight
but what was taking place at the same
time was that we were converting
from the ar-15 to the uh
to a nine millimeter weapon
the reason we were doing that is that
the ar-15 fires a 223 round and 90 of
our work are in the cities
and that round would go through one
house and through another and just keep
on going well when these new weapons
came out
i made a decision after tactical support
and everybody tested these weapons that
the nine millimeter was a much better
weapon to use but in waco they came in
to us and said we want eight at least i
think the number was eight ar-15s they
were all issued to him
but there's still a lot of we put some
ar-15s back in the field because of
places like texas that felt they still
needed
long-range rifles but for the most part
we were removing them from the field but
we weren't out gone to waco that's for
sure
okay uh mr cereben document three says
the raid was approved by the bureau
headquarters honor between two eleven
ninety three or so i noticed uh the uh
special agent charts um
met with high ranking bureau officials
prior to the raid is that true
yes there was a a briefing
on the 11th and 12th of february that we
were there and it was mr hart mr conroy
and the executive staff and then
i think uh the following day you met
with mr hanowski and that's when they
approved the raid on the 12th actually
thank you very much uh my time has
expired we will now recess for
one vote
so we'll recess for 15 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
we'll continue with this hearing in a
few minutes first some programming
information later on our companion
network c-span america and the courts
this evening on america and the courts
we mark the five-year anniversary of
justice william brennan's retirement
america and the courts this evening at 7
pm eastern time 4 p.m pacific
we now continue with the house joint
subcommittee hearing of federal actions
at waco texas in the spring of 1993. a
programming note you can see the second
day of hearings tonight at 10 pm eastern
time
theories will reconvene
many come to order
again i
thank the
patients of the witnesses and the
patients of those
members that are still here this is a
pretty good crowd for this time of night
i think since we started at 10 o'clock
this morning
i'd like to uh the chair yields uh to
our good friend mr conyers michigan for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman
um
on the question of
staleness and the warrant i'd like to
turn to mr johnston
you're aware of the argument against the
award application being stale can you
make any comments about it in reference
to the instant case
i can and let me say before i make the
comments uh i don't claim to be
a
law school professor i'm not jeff
moulton is
but uh we have former u.s attorneys here
their judgment on this and experience
would may well be better than mine uh
however
toward that in the fall of uh 1992
i
wondered about staleness i felt like it
was okay in other words a time period
but i wondered about it and i did some
uh research at the time i have
some of the cases here
because in firearms cases stillness is
treated a little differently
um
and i i'll just
could i warn mr moulton that i may ask
him to share this question after mr
johnson respond
and i i found uh and i'll just refer to
what i found that gave me a feeling that
we were on it
us versus bachelor nine month interval
was not too stale in the silencer case
u.s versus mccall a seven month interval
in a revolver case
u.s services brink low an 11-month
interval
in a
firearms case
u.s versus ron r-a-h-n there was a
two-year interval that scene
stream but there was a two-year interval
between the
facts that occur the alleged legal
activity in the search warrant affidavit
a one-year interval in u.s versus sims
in a 13-month interval in u.s versus
marriott now obviously
you don't want to put yourself in a
position of having an arguably still
affidavit
but after the research i felt like we
were okay with it
thank you mr bolton uh could you make
any additional comments about
the staleness uh argument against the
the warren application
certainly congressman i think courts
when they're evaluating claims of
staleness as mr johnson suggested look
at
a couple of different factors so there's
no mechanical test in terms of number of
months or days or weeks that that
renders information still some of the
things they look at are the nature of
the criminal activity is an isolated
event like the bank robbery and
cash from that bank robbery was an
ongoing pattern of criminal activity
other than they look at is the type of
evidence the evidence that's likely to
be dissipated or taken somewhere else
quickly again like cash drugs okay or is
it something uh that has more permanence
to it is likely to uh likely to remain
and i think mr johnson accurately
suggested that here we've got
a type of evidence a firearm that's not
ordinarily um disposed of quickly
clearly koresh
over a substantial period of time
expressed his interest in possessing
automatic weapons
here and again the criminal activity
here continued over a substantial period
of time i think that
most courts if not all courts would
conclude here that the information of
the warrant was not stale i want to
remind
you as well to point out that the
warrant did include information uh in
the in the late fall early winter
about hearing bursts of gunfire at the
compound so so it's not the case that
all the information was was eight months
old or so of course uh
you're familiar with the fifth circuit
case of batista versus henderson on
family
it goes along with the same direction
that we were moving in uh mr uh cereben
uh isn't it correct that the document
that was introduced by chairman zella
before the break
that was
unidentified
is now
identified
as to be one of a mr larry sparks
yes
yes
do you have it in your head someone just
told me that it's only that when i came
back that it was a doctor from mr
larry's park
[Music]
well who established the identity
well let me let me continue this
question thank you very much mr chairman
how how has this been established as
belonging to mr sparks i don't know
you're not sure
mr chairman i i can't hear the witness
uh could he pull my knife up a little
closer i just came
[Music]
you mr available um let me ask first mr
moulton
um
one of the allegations about this
hearing is it uh
that who asked for the investigation
that was made do you know who asked for
this report to be made
yes
yes uh congressman i do it was it was a
president united states who asked the
report the investigation be conducted
okay so
you know even though we're two years
late this the president asked for this
report much earlier right after he asked
for the report i believe uh on april
19th 1993. okay mr owen let me since you
brought out the
ak-47 with the folding stock
let me ask you a little bit about some
of the weapons and again looking at this
report in
in the charred remains we see the
grenade casings and and also a picture
of looks like a warehouse or the that
bus
that was uh
that was used as a as a bunker
um
in the findings did you find any ar-15s
or aks that had been converted
yes sir okay how many because under
earlier testimony from the gun dealer he
had sold at least 200
weapons
to mr koresh and no telling how many
more he could have bought at gun shows
on his own but do you have any idea of
from the inventory
from a very preliminary examination as
the weapons were brought to the evidence
collections
point
i identified
50 probable machine guns okay when you
say probable machine guns again you know
it's not illegal for me to own
200 um
aks that are semi-automatic that's
correct but it's illegal if i own them
and they've been converted or they're
automatics or machine guns that's
correct okay so
so you feel pretty confident there were
50
automatic weapons
that were found in the charred remains
at mount carmel yes sir
okay what about the grenade casings uh
did you see
any of them that had any
filament in them or anything that you
know because we also heard testimony
that that uh not only were their cases
the casings but there's also ingredients
to be able to
stuff them did you find did anyone find
any congressman i cannot speak to the
hand grenades
okay
does anyone else on the panel who did
any investigation uh can speak with with
personal knowledge because
i guess i i don't like to hear i i guess
i've heard hear say so much today that
it'd be nice to have personal knowledge
i did the work on the hand grenades and
uh
you have to ask them we'll have them
we'll have them here let me ask uh
okay thank you sorry about that
so generously
okay chair now recognizes uh mr mccollum
thank you very much i just want to
clarify a few things with you in the
brief time i've got this evening
gentlemen mr cereben who is larry sparks
he was the the previous supervisor in
austin texas
uh at any time did you have a
conversation with mr sparks or anyone
else where you said to them that you
believe that several of the items
mentioned in the arrest and search
warrants involved in this case were not
true never
that has been reported in some
conversations that we see in the record
of mr sparks are you aware he's made
such a statement
i don't know if mr smart
not necessarily that on that piece of
paper i'm not referring to that piece of
paper what was your question sir i'm
just asking if you were aware mr sparks
may have made such a statement at any
time no all right fair enough uh mr
aguilar i don't have you back as a
witness on another day and in order to
avoid bringing you back i want to ask
you a couple more questions about the
raid day itself even though that's not
the primary topic here you were in a
helicopter that day as i understand it
correct yes sir i was uh you had guns on
that helicopter yes sir i did were those
guns ordered to be downloaded
i had a gun i had you had a gun there
was a well there was only one gun on
that helicopter
i don't have anybody else had one i know
i had my pistol with me how about any
rifles no sir are there any rifles on
that helicopter no sir not the dice not
today are you aware were there any
rifles on any of the other there were
two other helicopters were there not
yes sir but i don't know if you don't
know whether they were or not were you
ordered to have your gun downloaded
no sir i had mine uh you had it loaded
loaded all right uh
do you know if there were any shots
fired from your helicopter that day
there were no shots fired do you know
whether there were shots fired from
either of the other helicopters no i
haven't testified that all right uh
isn't it true you took fire your
helicopter took fire that's correct uh
could you have fired back because of it
under the rules of engagement as you
knew it that day you know i'm not asking
whether you did but i asked you whether
you could have
could i have fired no sir not from where
the position i was in but by you would
have been permitted to have fired back
what i'm getting at
not whether you physically thought you
could but
but under the rules of engagement that
day when you were fired upon could you
not have then fired back
yes sir if i was being fired at yes sir
and you were being fired at at some
point yes sir are you not yes sir thank
you
um i got to clarify one other thing here
uh mr hartnett
mr moulton earlier this evening said
as i recall to the response of the
question ms jackson lee if i'm not
mistaken uh that there was no cover-up
involved in this matter by the treasury
department at all do you agree with that
comment
no i don't why
i feel that the treasury department has
said things since the time of
the raid of waco that that have been
incorrect
i feel that the treasury report where it
says some very good things that should
be done
things that we could correct in law
enforcement i think it also had many
omissions distortions
and false statements in it and why do
you believe those admissions and false
statements are in that report
i believe that they were concerned about
the the fallout from the media that they
couldn't just say that management
at the scene there was made mistakes
but
that wasn't the tone of the report they
felt like they had to write a scathing
report
which made a lot of people suffer like
chuck and and some of those other people
down there that were just doing their
job and it was i think very biased and
unfairly written and you think that was
a cover-up of sorts for what
i think they felt like and i don't know
if cover-up is a term that i would use
uh
i would say that they felt like they had
to
at least when it came to the press
show that they were taking some very
strong action and they weren't
responsible for anything and these
managers down there had done this uh
intentionally
and and that just was not the case and
you said earlier that the element of
surprise was the first time you ever
heard of it was
when that after the day of the raid
that's correct that's part of your
concern
certainly it is because i think that
that
the media picked up on it and you know i
would have to say that i used it too we
all started using it after the raid it
was a foolish thing to do i sort of got
trapped by the media trapped myself
but it throws a whole different
perspective
on what those commanders did down there
and i
just
i think it's three weeks ago i i saw the
assistant secretary noble
on a national broadcast say that
treasury and atf had ordered those
commanders not to go forward if they
lost the element of surprise
and i am the only person who was giving
principally direct orders to those
commanders
and i never gave such an order and i
never received such an order and we did
talk about safety
i mean we must have talked about safety
a hundred times and the director called
me the night before the raid said be
sure to mention it again to him
if anything isn't right you see guns
anything shut it down yes we did talk
about that constantly but the term
element of surprise
i never heard it until the media started
using it our own public affairs after
the raid thank you very much we'll
undoubtedly pursue questioning along
these lines further as the hearings
progress thank you mr harding
i attended a meeting
with mr higgins mr hartnett
chuck serbin
and
i was asked the same question
and i told him that i didn't recall
quite clearly but i do believe that the
element of surprise was asked by mr
higgins
if the element of surprise was going to
be lost
don't don't continue on this on the raid
you would what's the fires when is this
meeting that you attended mr aguilera
this was the meeting that i went up to
the headquarters with uh
chuck serbian and mr hoynes man
uh i believe what they
i don't recall i don't have my notes
with before before it was prior to the
raid how long before roughly uh i would
say maybe two to three weeks
all right we will have to uh come back
and revisit this with you thank you very
much yesterday
mr yan testified that all right all
rifle or all gun chambers were to be
emptied by the atf uh
and i i just was i would just like this
is a pertinent question and and uh
you indicated that your weapon was
loaded
did you did you did you miss did you
violate any rules by that i didn't
violate any rules i'd never heard of
that until today
thank you very much
mr chairman i appreciate your kindness
since mr mccullen brought up my
questioning and i i just needed to know
whether mr
turneth intended to make a blatant
statement that this was a cover-up by
the treasury department there may have
been some misstatements and we are here
to correct and to improve but are you
saying
that this was a blatant
five months report that covered up
all of the
wrongs that might have occurred
no i'm not saying that thank you sir
thank you very much it's been a long day
uh we appreciate uh
i i think you just got one and let's
let's not start another two-hour siege
here uh i i am going to conclude the
hearings i would like to thank you all
the witnesses very much for their
testimony uh we will adjourn many stands
adjourn until 9 30 tomorrow morning hold
on
okay i'm sorry uh i'd like to unanimous
consent the documents that i distributed
to mr johnston earlier uh be uh be
included in the record
without judge without objecting chairman
for another unanimous consent
mr chairman i'd like to ask unanimous
consent that mr hardin be
required to come before this committee
again and explain the extent of the
covenant he will be there if you look at
your scheduled witnesses he's scheduled
thank you very much
[Music]
the programming note you can see the
second day of hearings tonight at 10 pm
eastern we'll hear testimony from former
officials from the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms
[Music]
[Music]
tonight on c-span the second day of the
whitewater hearing